et bien bonjour à tous et bienvenue vous
êtes en direct sur la chaîne
parlementaire Public Sénat vous allez
pouvoir suivre tout au long de cet
après-midi et bien la discussion le
débat un débat extrêmement attendu
autour de cette proposition de loi
pénalisant la négation des génocides on
le sait ce texte vise essentiellement
presque uniquement ce fameux génocide
arménien perpété par les Turcs en 1915
un texte qui soulève les passions au
moment même où je vous parle par exemple
et bien des manifestations proturques ou
pro-arméniennes ont lieu à quelques
mètres d'ici à l'extérieur du palais du
Luxembourg où les forces de l'ordre sont
extrêmement nombreuses on le sait
également he ce texte est à l'origine
d'une forte Denion diplomatique entre la
France et la Turquie ce matin même
Ankara et bien menacé de d'accent tuer
encore les représailles les sanctions à
l'égard de l' de la France quelques
minutes après bien c'était le qu d'orset
qui disait des propos apaisants en
mettant en avant les forts liens
existant et les liens extrêmement
importants existants entre la Turquie et
la France c'est donc dans un contexte
tout à fait particulier que va se
dérouler tout au cours de l'après-midi
la discussion et le débat autour de ce
texte un texte que va défendre dans
quelques minutes le sénateur socialiste
du valde Marne Luc Carvounas merci
d'être avec nous pour entamer cet
après-midi on le voit un contexte très
singulier très particulier qui entoure
la discussion de ce texte est-ce que la
sérénité des débats cet après-midi au
Sénat est assurée écoutez je l'espère
bien sûr le contexte est forcément
particulier singulier au vu de la
période dans laquelle nous entrons
électorale et je tiens quand même
rappeler plusieurs points d'abord que le
travail que mène le groupe socialiste au
sein de la Haute Assemblée a toujours
été un travail en empr de sérénité de
débat et qui s'inscrit totalement dans
le travail que la majorité du groupe
socialiste à l'Assemblée nationale en
2001 avait voulu porter au travers la
loi sur le négationnisme et en même
temps sur les travaux qui ont été les
nôtres encore jusqu'à l'an dernier
lorsque en M nous proposions de
reprendre la loi de 2006 par la haute
assemblée qui n'a ne s'est pas vu reçu
par le groupe majoritaire de l'époque
donc nous avons eu des débats nous les
socialistes tous ensemble qui ont ont
permis dans le sérieux qui est le nôtre
de de voir plusieurs auditions sur
plusieurs semaines encore une fois avec
rger oui pour la première fois le groupe
socialiste a auditionné des historiens
des spécialistes de cette période tout à
fait c'était là la volonté de notre
nouveau président du groupe François
repsamen qui a voulu à la fois pouvoir
permettre le dialogue entre nous déjà et
éclairer peut-être les les positions de
de quelques collègu qui pouvaent
peut-être être emmené par quelques ça
existe pression ici ou là mais encore
une fois les TR semaines qui viennent de
se dérouler les auditions des
ambassadeurs d'Arménie et de Turquie se
sont faites avec la conscience et des
uns et des autres de toutes les parties
nous avons reçu des historiens comme
Pierre Nora ou if TER alors il n'empêche
votre groupe est divisé comme d'ailleurs
la le groupe UMP ici au Sénat sur cette
question la meilleure preuve Jean-Pierre
suur le président de la commission des
lois ici au Sénat et bien a rejeté ce
texte disant qu'il est
antionstitutionnel qu'ez-vous à lui
répondre en quelques mots collè
je-pierre sort est président de la
commission des lois depuis le la
nouvelle majorité ici au Sénat le groupe
socialiste n'est pas divisé encore une
fois les positions des uns et des autres
sont ont toujours été connues et
reconnues je j'imagine que la difficulté
plus du côté des rangs de mes collègues
du groupe UMP qui aujourd'hui sont un
peu sous une injonction présidentielle
dans une précipitation et un bougisme du
président de la République que chacun
reconnaît mon collègue swur qui a
participeré d'ailleurs à tous les toutes
les auditions a été toujours très clair
au bureau du groupe en nous disant que
comme président de la commission des
lois il reprendrait les attendus
qu'avait défendu notre illustre collègue
Robert vanter ce que je regrette c'est
qu'il n'est pas mais les calendriers
sont comme ça de de nos réunions je
découvre une superposition de date qui
n''est pas eu le temps de pouvoir
participer à toutes les auditions et se
rendre peut-être compte que la loi de
2012 n'est pas la loi de 2006 et que les
attendus qu'il porta et qui ont obtenu
aujourd'hui au sein de la commission euh
des lois mais qui ne sera en tous les
cas qui n'est pas la posture du groupe
socialiste euh n'est pas n'est pas n'est
pas la la posture majoritaire alors on
va voir la suite au cours de la
discussion qui vient de de commencer ici
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat je rappelle
que le groupe socialiste au nom duquel
vous allez parler tout à l'heure comme
le groupe UMP et bien défend ce texte
mais d'autres groupes comme le groupe de
Jean-Vincent Placé les Verts les
écologistes se prononceront contre de
même que la grande majorité du groupe
radical pas de consigne de vote du côté
des communistes ou encore euh des
centristes bref il existe quand même un
certain suspense cet après-midi moi je
respecte les postures de tous les
groupes et notamment de ceux aujourd'hui
qui sont les bands de la nouvelle
majorité au Sénat je j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire notamment à certains de mes
collègues comme es ben Bassa que à un
moment où il y a quelques jours nous
votions ensemble une loi concernant
toutes les personnes qui ne
reconnaissaient pas lesarchies dans leur
dans leur statut il était difficile de
comprendre en tous les cas pour les
français en général qu'il puisse y avoir
des lois enclin aller dans notre
histoire commune et c'est normal sur les
et pas vis-à-vis de ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui d'origine arménienne ou nos
Arméniens que nous avons accueillis ici
en France je pense que notre mémoire
collective se doit et c'est là et c'est
là le la fierté du Parlement français de
pouvoir sur des débats difficiles comme
ce fut le cas à l'occasion de la loi
guesso sur le négationisme contre la
Choa de pouvoir emmener les consciences
pour que nous soyons les fer de lance au
niveau de l'Europe est-ce que vous
pouvez nous assurer que vos collègues
quels qu'ils soient ici dans l'hémicycle
don n pas reçu de pression extérieure on
a entendu par exemple les propos
d'ankcara ce matin avec la réponse du
kedorsé est-ce qu'il y eu des
initiatives qui pouvait viser cibler des
des sénateurs des sénatrices les
pressions elles existent de toute part
et surt sujet difficile elles ont existé
je dire le contraire serait mentir aussi
à l'occasion des débats qui ont été les
nôtres de façon moins violente qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale comme on a pu
l'entendre et le comprendre en décembre
dernier maintenant euh je rappellerai
tout à l'heure dans l'émicycle que
lorsque les mêmes pressions s'exerçaient
vis-à-vis de la la France au moment de
la loi de 2001 nos relations
commerciales avec la Turquie se sont vu
en 2002 augmenter de 22 % au niveau de
nos contrats donc toute raison gardé je
pense qu'il ne faut pas sur des sujets
difficiles répondre à des pressions
économiques ou de stratégies
géopolitique merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur d'avoir entamé cet après-midi
enensemble sur Public Sénat la séance a
commencé c'est Patrick olier le ministre
des Relations chargées avec le Parlement
qui ouvre les débats cet après-midi
suivra la discussion générale ça devrait
turer environ 2 he à la suite de quoi et
bien trois motions seront déposées voté
ou rejeté on verra bien sur ce texte
concernant la négation des génocides je
laisse parole tout de suite à Patrick
olier pour cet aprèsmidi de débat ici au
Sénat mer auin de votre commission des
Lois le gouvernement respecte la
sensibilité de
chacun d'autant que nous ne rencontrons
pas dans ce texte des clivages et qui
sont habituelles dans cet hémicycle
chacun a ses raisons de soutenir ou bien
de rejeter ce texte et avant toute chose
je veux rappeler
humblement que l'opinion et les
motivations de tous sont dignes
d'intérêt et de considération c'est
pourquoi j'ai été heureux de lire en
guise d'introduction à votre rapport
monsieur le Président sueur et je cite
qu'il était primordial d'envisager une
telle discussion en écartant dès le
départ toute forme d'amalgame
qui est l'instrument des dialogues
pollués quelle belle écriture et je vous
en félicite en effet nul ne songe ici à
dire comme vous l'avez souligné que
quelqu'un qui doute de l'opportunité des
débats historiques au Parlement fait le
jeu du
négationnisme le négationisme est
l'insulte suprême à la mémoire
collective que nous avons en partage il
bal les souffrances des peuple et
condamne les victimes à
l'oubli ceux qui encouragent cet oubli
de foncatiser des haines qui auraiit pu
et dû s'éteindre avec le temps en
matière de génocide de crime de guerre
de crime contre l'humanité l'oubli est
une insulte au passé il entrave la
réflexion le pardon la guérison des
plaies les plus profondes il interdit
l'accomplissement du
deuil ceux qui oublient le passé sont
condamnés à le
revivre cette phrase du philosophe
Santayana gravé au fronton de tant de
lieux de mémoire nous rappelle le danger
concret du
négationnisme notre société se doit de
lutter contre le poison négationniste et
c'est ce que propose ce texte destiné à
remplir un vide juridique monsieur le
Président ce n'est que ça dont il s'agit
et uniquement de ça remplir un vide
juridique vous êtes mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs des législateurs
avertis sur tous les blancs sur tous les
bancs de cette hémicycle en tant que tel
vous ne pouvez pas vous ne devez pas
vous tromper de débat j'entends en effet
autour de moi des voix qui s'élèvent
pour critiquer cette proposition de loi
en dénonçant son caractère
mémoriel c'est une lecture que le
gouvernement récuse et je vais m'en
expliquer le débat sur l'opportunité des
lois dites mémoriell est légitime et
utile parce que il interpelle tout un
chacun sur sa conception de
l'histoire de la justice et du rôle du
politique dans le débat
historique c'est une question adressée à
toutes les
consciences nul ne saurait mettre en
cause celui dans chacun de vos groupes
dont les convictions personnel serait
bousculé par l'existence même de tel
texte une loi mémorielle est une loi
déclarant le point de vue officiel d'un
état sur des événements historiques
c'est ça une loi mémorielle or cette
proposition de loi n'a rien à voir avec
cette définition absolument rien
elle prévoit simplement de sanctionner
le non respect d'une loi votée mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs il y a 10
ans c'est donc en 1990 et même 20 ans
pour le génocide juif ou en 2001 qu'il
fallait s'élever contre ces textes parce
que c'est à ce moment-là cher sénatrices
et sénateurs qui avait lieu le
débat et bien aujourd'hui il ne s'agit
nullement de reouvrir les débats de
l'époque ils sont clos c'est la loi de
la République Monsieur le Président
c'est la loi de la
République il ne vous a pas demandé de
dire ce que fut l'histoire aujourd'hui
mais bien de traiter ceux qui nient
certains génocides reconnus par la loi
de façon ég
simplement nous avons ici affaire à une
harmonisation de notre arsenal juridique
qui part d'un constat
simple la loi reconnaît certains
génocides c'est un fait qu'on adhère ou
non au concept de loi mémorielle parce
que c'est la loi parce que c'est la loi
monsieur
Gorse mais il demeure une disparité de
traitement entre ceux qui en déni
l'existence selon qu'ils oublient ou
qu'il cible telle ou telle c'est une
situation avéré à laquelle il me semble
difficile de ne pas apporter de réponse
vous ne pouvez pas rester insensible à
cette évidence on peut en effet pas
considérer que deux génocides reconnus
par des lois françaises dans notre
Parlement français soit traité de
manière différente la négation de l'un
pouvant être sanctionné et la négation
de l'autre ne l'étant
pas nous nous nous nous nous inquiétons
aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs simplement de l'harmonisation
pénale sur ce point-là et c'est en cela
que je vous demandais de ne pas réouvrir
des débats révolu de ne pas réouvrir des
débats qui ont eu lieu il y a 10 ou 20
ans bien entendu cette proposition
n'existant que parce que le Parlement a
voté des lois qui elle effectivement
était mémoriel il est logique que le
débat d'opportunité ressurgisse je le
comprends et j'essaie de répondre à ces
arguments mais il convient de fonder vos
décision finale sur la justesse de la
mesure qui vous est proposée et et non
sur la loi à laquelle elle vous renvoie
soit celle de 2001 soit celle de
1990 cette proposition de
loi cette proposition de loi adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale le 22 décembre
dernier vise à réprimer la contestation
ou la minimisation outrancière des
génocides reconnus comme tel par la
loi à ce jour deux génocides ont été
reconnus comme tel par la loi la loi par
la loi guesso du 13 juillet 90 1990 et
le génocide arménien par celle du 29
janvier
2001 or seule la négation de la Choa est
pénalement réprimée est-ce normal le
dispositif pénal qui sanctionne la
négation du génocide juif n'est pas
applicable à d'autres génocides est-ce
normal je dis normal mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs pour des
législateurs pour ceux qui écrivent la
loi peuvent-ils rester indifférents face
à ce vide juridique c'est la question
question que je vous pose madame
Goulet vousêtes trop passionné pour
votre ordinateur
madame beau beaucoup plaide aujourd'hui
pour que la négation de tous les
génocides reconnus comme tel par la loi
française et pas seulement la Choa soit
également réprimé mais c'est justice
mais c'est justice qu'il y ait
effectivement des voies qui s'élève pour
dire il faut qu'il soit réprimé de la
même manière puisqu'ils sont reconnus de
la même manière par la même loi c'est
justice nous ne pouvons nous ne pouvons
accepter l'idée dès lors que la loi
reconnaissait génocide que des faits
identiques en l'occurrence le
négationnisme soit puni de manière
différente il est donc naturel de
demander au législateur de réparer cet
oubli merci c'est l'objet de la
proposition de loi qui vous qui vous est
soumise en discussion aujourd'hui
j'espère que vous allez la soutenir dans
ces conditions son article premier oh
non non monsieur le Président je
m'adresse à ceux qui m'ont rompu en
disant très bien je suis sensible au
soutien son article 1emier insèt un
nouvel article 24 TER dans la loi du 29
juillet
1981 là nous sommes dans le dispositif
de la proposition dispositif juridique
de la proposition qui vous est soumise
qui dispose que ceux qui auront contesté
ou minimisé de façon outrancière
j'insiste out trancière l'existence d'un
ou plusieurs crimes de génocide définis
par l'article 2111 du code pénal et
connu comme tel par la loi française
seront punis d'un an d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 € d'amende cette infraction
peut être commise dans des réunion
publique par affichage ou par diption de
tracte mais aussi sur Internet voilà ce
dont il s'agit rien de plus l'article 2
vise à élargir la capacité d'agir en
justice des associations qui se propose
de défendre l'honneur des victimes de
CRIM de génocide nous ne sommes pas des
pionniers à la matière je voudrais vous
le
rappeler dans le casadre de cette
initiative la France na rien isolé cette
proposition s'inscrit dans un mouvement
d'ensemble qui vise à pénaliser les
propos racistes ou xénophobes ainsi
l'Union européenne a-t-elle adopté en
2008 une décision cadre sur la
pénalisation de certaines formes et
manifestations de racisme et de
xénophobie ainsi six États de l'Union
européenne ont d'ors et déjà adopté un
dispositif de pénalisation de la
négation du génocide juif la France
l'Allemagne la Belgique la Lituanie la
Hongrie Pologne six autres États membres
de l'Union européenne ont aussi un
dispositif de pénalisation de la
négation des génocides sans les nommer
comme ce qui vous est proposé
aujourd'hui Espagne Léonie Malte
Portugal République tchèque Slovénie
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs cela
fait 12 États européens qui sont entrés
dans la mise en œuvre de cette décision
4 de 2008 nous ne faisons en définitive
que de la transcription d'une décision
européenne en France ce sujet avait
d'ailleurs déjà fait l'objet de
plusieurs propositions de loi par le
passé je ne veux pas ignorer que le
Sénat a débattu en 2011 d'un texte un
apparence proche je dis bien un
apparence proche mais en fait tout à
fait
différent je voudrais bien qu'on fasse
la différence entre ces deux textes car
il ne s'agit pas ici de sanctionner la
négation d'un génocide en particulier ni
de viser un événement un événement
spécifique contrairement à la
proposition de Monsieur la
gauche
je vous répète madame qu'il ne s'agit
pas aujourd'hui je répète qu'il s'agit
pas aujourd'hui de sanctionner un
génocide précis qui était mentionné dans
la proposition de loi de Monsieur la
gauche le texte aujourd'hui proposé par
l'assemblée qui a été transformé
d'ailleurs vise au contraire à
sanctionner la négation de tous les
génocides reconnus par la lo française
sans en mentionner aucun
expressément il permet ainsi de protéger
de rendre justice à la mémoire des un
sans heurter la sensibilité des autres
et le gouvernement n'a aucunement
l'intention de
stigmatiser un peuple ou un ou une
communauté monsieur le Président la loi
doit être de portée générale la loi doit
être de porté générale et c'est bien
tout l'intérêt de ce texte contrairement
à la proposition de loi sur laquelle
vous avez eu à vous prononcer en mai
2011 le gouvernement entend par ailleurs
l'objection soulever sur l'entrave que
constituerait cette proposition de loi
au principes fondateur de liberté
d'expression oui liberté d'expression
c'est une préoccupation légitime et le
républicain que je suis est
naturellement et viciralement attaché
mais le goliste que je suis c'est qu'il
n'existe pas de liberté sans
responsabilité que la liberté de l'un ne
seraité celle de l'autre que la liberté
d'expression ne peut être le paravant de
l'insulte ou de la provocation
tout réside dans ce juste équilibre et
c'est bien ce juste équilibre que nous
voulons voir respecter aujourd'hui c'est
l'esprit dans lequel ceux qui ont forgé
notre démocratie envisager l'idée même
de liberté
d'expression rappelons à ce titre
l'article 11 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme de
1789 monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères vous
ne pouvez pas y être insensible qui est
un des fondements de notre Constitution
je cite la libre communication des
pensées des opinions est un des droits
les plus précieux de l'homme tout
citoyen peut donc parler écrire imprimer
librement sauf à répondre à l'abus de
cette liberté dans les cadres déterminés
par la loi nous y sommes c'est
exactement ce que nous vous proposons de
faire que propose ce texte si ce n'est
réprimé un abus outrancier dans
l'exercice de la liberté d'expression
dans le cadre strict de la loi comme cet
article autorise
explicitement monsieur le
Président cette loi ne pourra concerné
des propos privés c'est évident des
discussions de café c'est évident ou des
travaux de chercheurs bien
entendu je veux ici reprendre les termes
de l'article 1er il vise à penir ceux je
cite qui ont contesté ou minimisé de
façon
outrancière par des moyens énoncés à
l'article 23 de la loi sur la liberté de
la presse de
1881 qui prévoit que les intéressés se
soient exprimés je cite rapidement soit
par des discours cris ou menaces
profférés dans des lieux au réunions
publiques soit par des éc imprimé dessin
gravure et cetera image ou tout autre
support par l'écrit de l'écrit de la
parole ou de l'image vendue ou distribué
mis en vente ou exposé dans des lieux ou
en réunion publique soit par des
placards ou des affiches exposé soit au
moyen de communication au public par
voie électronique nous sommes exactement
dans le cadre que prévoit cette
proposition de loi je vaux pas être long
mais je veux répondre point à point à ce
que j'ai entendu depuis que ce débat est
ouvert mesdames et messieurs pour être
plus court après pendant les
interventions qui vont être très
nombreuses dans la discussion générale
on ne se situe donc pas ici dans une
volonté de bayonner les citoyens ou
parmi eux les les intellectuels ou
scientifiques comme je l'ai entendu ou
lu dans certains articles cette mesure
pénale est de la compétence du
législateur elle est de votre compétence
à qui il appartient de définir les
règles ou non desquelles au nom desquel
la liberté d'expression peut s'exercer
pleinement c'est-à-dire dans le
et dans la mesure
enfin sachant que la discussion générale
abordera évidemment cet aspect de la
procédure je ne peux pas l'ignorer votre
commission des Lois adopté une motion
d'irrecevabilité monsieur le Président à
votre initiative souignant qu'il n'est
pas de la compétence du Parlement de
légiférer sur l'histoire et que la
proposition de loi s'oppose à certains
principes constitutionnels dont celui
que je viens d'évoquer au passage
monsieur robertinter d'ailleurs soutenu
la même position dans une récente
tribune parue dans un journal du soir
rédigé et argumenté avec le talent et la
hauteur de vue qu'on lui
connaît je l'ai lu avec attention je
dois dire avec le respect qu'on doit un
juriste si éminent que Monsieur
Badinter je do dire monsieur le
Président qu'avec le respect que je dois
monsieur bter comme le respect que je
dois votre commission
vous n'abordez pas ou ceux qui ont écrit
ça n'abordent pas ce débat sous le bon
angle je le redis encore avant d'achever
mon propos ne nous trompons pas de débat
car la confusion sur l'intention de ce
texte par amalgame soulève des passions
fondé sur l'essentiel mais mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs l'essentiel
tranché il y a 20 ans l'essentiel
tranché il y a 10
ans cet essentiel déjà devenu depuis 20
ans disant la loi de la République et
qui volontairement ou non ce qu'il
disent ça qui prétendent ça néglige la
conséquence que nous abordons
aujourd'hui de cette
essentielle que nous avons traité il y a
20 et 10 ans c'est bien çael que vouz
vous ramener à la réalité du débat que
nous avons toutes ensemble à affronter
aujourd'hui s'il est naturellement dans
les prérogatives monsieur le Président
de votre commission d'apprécier la
constitutionnalité d'un texte en vue de
son examen
je répète qu'avec ce texte il n'agit pas
il s'agit pas de légiférer sur
l'histoire mais bien de compléter notre
droit et notamment une loi votée à la
quasi unanimité il y a 10 ans je serais
heureux de vous donner le nom de tous
ceux qui ont voté pour cette loi il y a
10 ans ça sera intéressant de le faire
plus
tard dès lors et puisque il y a
assymétrie flagrante
entre la répression des négationnistes
dans notre pays mesdamesieur messieurs
les sénateurs sénatrices et sénateurs il
convient d'y
remédier bien entendu nul ne peut
ignorer la réaction de notre allié la
Turquie monsieur le Président la
Commission Affaires
étrangères la Turquie est un grand pays
dont nous respectons le peuple et les
dirigeants et avec lequel nous
souhaitons ardemment développer nos
relations politiques économiques et
culturelles la Turquie joue un rôle
stratégique dans sa région et au-delà N
conscient nul ne le conteste le
gouvernement souhaite rappeler sa
conviction que nos intérêts stratégiques
communs notre coopération pour la paix
et la liberté en Syrie et en Afghanistan
notre appartenance commune à l'OTAN ou
au G20 nos coopérations culturelles
économiqu sont suffisamment forts pour
surmonter les épreuves que peuvent
traverser nos relations et c'est en tout
cas le sens de la lettre que le
Président de la République a fait
parvenir la semaine dernière au Premier
ministre Erdogan mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs cette proposition de loi
participe d'un mouvement généralisé de
répression des propos racistes et
xénophobes elle n pas une loi mémoriel
elle vit simplement à combler un vide
contenu dans notre législation elle ne
contrevient pas au principe essentiel
qui la liberté d'expression pour toutes
ces raisons le Gouvernement est
favorable à cette proposition de loi et
j'invite votre Haus assemblée à
l'adopter dans les mêmes termes je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur
ministre dans la discussion générale la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Sueur rapporteur de la
commission des
lois mon le
président monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues nous examinons donc
aujourd'hui la proposition de notre
collègue député Madame Valérie Boyet
visant à réprimer la contestation de
l'existence des génocides reconnus par
la loi adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
le 22 décembre dernier vous le savez
vous venez de le rappeler monsieur le
ministre ce texte propose de punir d'un
an d'emprisonnement et de 45000 €
d'amende les personnes qui contestent ou
minimisent de façon outrancière
l'existence d'un ou plusieurs crimes de
génocide reconnu comme tel par la loi
française en l'état du
droit ce dispositif s'appliquerait donc
uniquement aux personnes qui contestent
ou minimise de façon
outrancière l'existence du génocide
arménien puisque seul ce dernier a été
reconnu comme tel par la loi du 29
janvier 2001 que vous venez de citer
monsieur le ministre
si cette proposition était adoptée il
pourrait toutefois à l'avenir
s'appliquer à la contestation ou la
minimisation
outrancière d'autres génocides que le
législateur souhaiterait
reconnaître mes chers
collègues je ne m'exprime pas à cette
tribune au nom d'un parti
politique ni au nom d'un groupe
politique je parle au nom d'une
commission la commission des Lois du
Sénat celle-ci a décidé à une large
majorité 23 voix pour contre 9 il y a eu
abstentions de voter une exception
d'irrecevabilité ce qui revient à
rejeter le texte au motif de son
inconstitutionnalité je
déclare que tout exp
politique de notre décision serait veine
puisque je suis rapporteur d'une
décision qui a été voté majoritairement
par des sénateurs de gauche des
sénateurs de droite des sénateurs du
centre des sénateurs
écologistes la question que nous nous
sommes posé et qui a donné lieu un long
débat riche et serein
apporté sur le droit
sur la loi sur ce qui relève de la loi
et ce qui ne relève pas de la loi ce que
la loi doit dire et ce qu'elle ne peut
pas dire en vertu de l'article 34 de la
Constitution tel est mes chers collègues
le débat qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui c'est un débat de
fond au-delà des polémiques et pressions
de toutes sortes c'est sur ce débat et
exclusivement sur ce débat que porteront
mes deux interventions cellees-ci et
celle par laquelle je défendrai
l'exception d'irrecevabilité tout à
l'heure sur cette question
fondamentale chacune et chacun d'entre
vous sera
amené puisque vous le savez tous tout
mandat impératif est nul chacun sera
donc amené à se prononcer en son âme et
conscience à l'issue du
débat j'ajoute qu'il y a une cohérence
et une continuité dans la position de la
Commission des Lois du
Sénat puisque sous la présidence de mon
prédécesseur le président Jean-Jacques
ye également
rapporteur notre commission a voté une
exception
d'irrecevabilité sur une proposition de
loi ayant le même objet le 13 avril
2011 mes chers collègues nous ne devons
pas nous tromper de
débats je sais les espérances et les
craintes que l'examen de cette
proposition de loi à suscité en
particulier chez nos compatriotes
d'origine arménienne qui concerve au
plus profond de même la mémoire
douloureuse des épreuves endurées et de
l'exil
forcé je tiens à réaffirmer ici
solennellement la compassion et le
respect que la représentation nationale
éprouve à l'égard des victimes du
génocide arménien de
1915 l'existence de ce dernier ne fait
aucun doute de nombreux documents
l'attestent et notre collègue madame ben
Bassa qui a fait sa thèse sur l'histoire
de l'Empire ottoman au début du 20
siècle nous a indiqué la semaine
dernière en commission qu'elle avait
elle-même pu prendre connaissance de ces
documents je le
réaffirme il ne s'agit pas ici de
contester ni de minimiser de quelque
manière que ce soit l'existence du
génocide de 1915 et les immenses
souffrances qu'il a causé notre pays
s'est honoré en reconnaissant
officiellement ce gén
même si le recours à une résolution à
l'époque impossible aurait probablement
constitué une voix plus
approprié le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui ne porte pas sur le génocide
arménien le débat que nous devons avoir
aujourd'hui porte sur le rôle de la loi
sur ce qu'elle peut faire et ne pas
faire ce qu'elle peut dire et ne pas
dire ce qu'elle doit faire et ne doit
pas faire les génocides et les crimes
contre l'humanité sont
insupportable car au-delà des
souffrances infligées aux victimes ils
remettent en cause l'identité et la part
d'humanité de tout être humain et
portent atteinte aux valeurs
essentielles de nos civilisations les
souffrances des rescapés et de leurs
descendants sont indicible et nier la
réalité des massacres commis et du
génocide lui-même conduirait à perpétuer
ses souffrances le négationisme est
auieux nous le condamnons tous sans
aucune réserve la question qui nous est
posée aujourd'hui et celle qui consiste
à savoir s'il appartient à la loi pénale
de dire quels événements historiques
peuvent être discutés sur la place
publique et quels événements historiques
ne souffrent aucune discussion quelle
est notre légitimité à nous législateurs
pour dire ce qu'est
l'histoire le Conseil constitutionnelle
à rappeler à de multiples reprises que
je cite la loi lo n'exprime la volonté
générale que dans le respect de la
Constitution je développerai tout à
l'heure les raisons qui ne conduisent à
penser que la présente proposition de
loi encore encour un fort risque de
censure
inconstitutionnelle je voudrais pour
l'instant m'attarder sur les raisons
pour lesquelles dans sa grande majorité
la commission des Lois du Sénat a
considéré qu'il n'appartenait pas à la
loi et en particulier à la loi pénale
d'intervenir dans le champ de l'histoire
et de disposer en matière de vérité
historique et pour résumer mon propos je
diraiis avec Robert Badinter que le
Parlement n'est pas un tribunal et avec
Pierre Nora qu'il ne revient pas au
législateur de faire l'histoire en tant
que représentant de la nation nous
disposons de plusieurs voies
d'expression en tant que législateur
nous vons la loi mais nous disposons
également de plusieurs moyens de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement et de
appelé sur sa politique il y a les
commémorations depuis la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 nous pouvons
voter des
résolutions la loi n'est qu'un de nos
moyens
d'expression en tant que représentant de
la nation nous avons naturellement un
rôle à jouer dans la perpétuation de la
mémoire
nationale laissez-moi citer en cet
instant les propos tenus par notre
éminent ancien collègue Robert Badinter
devant la mission d'un formation de
l'Assemblée nationale sur les questions
mémorielles qui a donné lieu à un très
remarquable rapport signé par le
président Bernard àoyet je cite Robert
badater il faut mesurer ce que peut
signifier pour les descendants de
victimes de CRIM contre l'humanité un
déni de mémoire ce refus de l'existence
de ce qui fut frôle l'intolérable mais
l'émotion et la compassion que l'on peut
éprouver devant ce que juris appeler le
long cri de la souffrance humaine
n'empêche pas le juriste de faire preuve
de distance je suis tout à fait
favorable à la commémoration
c'est-à-dire à la conservation d'une
mémoire aussi vivante que possible la
mémoire est nécessaire c'est un devoir
vis-à-vis des morts mais une chose est
la commémoration sous ses formes
multiples autre chose est le recours à
la loi il est un principe
constitutionnel fondamental que le
Conseil cons in a été amené à mains de
fois à rappeler la loi n'est
l'expression de la volonté générale que
dans le respect de la Constitution
s'agissant de la loi sur les génnocide
Arméniens beaucoup se sont interrogés
sur la compétence du Parlement français
à légiférer sur un événement historique
à mes yeux indiscutable qui est survenu
il y a près d'un siècle dans un
territoire étranger sans qu'on ne
connaisse ni victimes française ni auur
français mais l'important est ailleurs à
l'évidence l'article 34 de la
Constitution ne permet pas au Parlement
de se prononcer ainsi sur un événement
historique comme
lui une forte majorité des membres de
votre commission des Lois estime qu'il
n'appartient pas à la loi dont le rôle
est déédiicter des normes susceptibles
d'être invoqué devant les tribunaux de
se prononcer sur la qualification de tel
ou tel fait historique et les
éventuelles conséquences pénales qui en
découleraient cela reviendrait à
confondre histoire et mémoire et cela ne
pourrait que porter atteinte à la
recherche historique dans notre pays les
historiens sont très inquiets du débat
que nous avons à l'heure actuelle et a
raison notre commission des lois pense à
cet égard qu'il convient de ne pas
entraver leur travail en leur imposant
des conclusions que nous aurions é dicté
cela reviendrait à réinstaurer une
histoire officielle alors que notre
République est au contraire fondée sur
le principe de la libre communication
des pensées et des
opinions comme l'a notamment souligné
notre collègue Catherine Tasca la
semaine dernière en commission nous
pensons également que permettre à la loi
de se prononcer sur des faits
historiques contreviendrait au principe
de la séparation des pouvoirs en tant
que législateur nous édictons des lois
pénales qui punissent les faits qui
portent atteinte à notre société mais
c'est au juges mes chers collègues et
non au législateur qu'il appartient de
qualifier de génocide ou de crime contre
l'humanité tel ou tel événement
laissez-moi citer le grand doyen George
Vedel éminent juriste reconnu de tous
dans le dernier article qu'il a publié
avant sa mort et qui était consacré à la
constitutionnalité de la loi du 29
juillet 2001 je cite le principe de
séparation des pouvoirs législatifs et
judiciaires consacrés tant par la
Déclaration de
1789 que comme principe fondamental
reconnu par la les lois de la République
mais toutre le bon sens un obstacle
infranchissable à ce que le législateur
se prononce sur la vérité ou la fausseté
de tel ou tel fait sur leur
qualification dans une espèce concrète
et sur une condamnation même limitée à
une flétrissure notre commission partage
cette observation enfin plusieurs
membres de notre commission je pense
notamment à Jean-René lecer et à
François zooketo on soulignait la
semaine dernière le risque que
l'adoption de la présente proposition de
loi entraîne entre guillemets une
concurrence des mémoires en effet les
rescapés ou les descendants d'autres
tragédies du 20e siècle elles ont été
nombreuses ou des siècles précédents
d'ailleurs pourrait alors être fondé à
nous demander de reconnaître
officiellement par la loi les
souffrances dont ont dont elles ont été
victimes faudrait-il alors adopter une
loi pour reconnaître une à une chacune
de ces tragédies notre mémoire nationale
est le produit de notre histoire
républicaine comme l'a rappelé gaet
angorse et non l'addition de mémoire
particulière nous devons prendre garde
ici à ne pas risquer de déstabiliser un
édifice facile
fragile au total dans sa grande
majorité notre
commission souhaite attirer l'attention
du Sénat sur les dangers des lois
mémorielles
elle n'est pas la première à le faire en
2008 je l'ai dit la mission
d'information sur les questions mémoriel
présidé par le président de l'Assemblée
nationale berdard accoyet a proposé de
renoncer désormais à la tentation des
lois mémorielles cette préconisation
empreinte de sagesse devrait être
entendue j'ajoute que comme l'a noté
Madame Anne Levade professeur à
l'Université Paris Est le Conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision de
délégalisation
de l'une des dispositions de la loi du
23 février 2005 à considérer je cite que
l'appréciation d'un fait historique en
l'espèce le rôle positif de la présence
française outreem ne relève pas de la
compétence du
législateur en ce qui concerne plus
précisément la proposition de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui qui crée un
délit pénal de contestation ou de
minimisation de faits qualifiés de
génocide par la loi
nous estimons que celle-ci contrevient à
plusieurs des principes fondamentaux de
notre droit j'expliquerai tout à l'heure
plus en détail pour quelle raison nous
pensons qu'elle contrevient au principe
de l'égalité des délits et des peines
qui est un principe fondamental en
matière pénal nous pensons aussi qu'elle
porte atteinte au principe de liberté
d'opinion et d'expression car les
limitations susceptibles d'être apporté
à cette liberté doivent être restreintes
je cite la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme la liberté d'expression vaut non
seulement pour les informations ou idées
accueilles avec faveur ou considéré
comme inoffensive ou indifférente mais
aussi pour celles qui heurtent choque ou
inquiète l'État ou une fraction
quelconque de la population ainsi le vol
le pluralisme la tolérance et l'esprit
d'ouverture sans lesquels il n'est pas
de société démocratique il en découle
notamment que toute formalité conditions
restrictions ou sanction imposé en la
matière doit être proportion don au but
légitime poursuivi comme le souigné
aussi au sein de notre commission
pierreive Colomba la liberté
d'expression a sans doute des
inconvénients mais interdire
l'expression d'idée d'analyse ou
d'opinion divergente ou dissidente
pourvu qu'elle n'incite pas la haine ou
à la discrimination reviendrait à
instaurer un délit d'opinion nous
pensons que la contestation de faits
historique ou l'absurdité
d'unegationisme doivent être combatttu
sur la place publique et quant à la
diffamation à l' raciale ou religieuse
ainsi qu' que la provocation à la
discrimination à la haine ou à la
violence à l'égard d'une personne ou
d'un groupe de personnes en raison de
leur origine elles sont passibles d'ors
et déjà de multiples sanctions pénales
en vertu de plusieurs articles des lois
en vigueur ces articles ont d'ailleurs
déjà été appliqués par nos juridiction
comme je le montrerai tout à l'heure en
défendant l'exception
d'irrecevabilité à l'ég d'auteur de
propos tenus à l'encontre de la
communauté arménienne c'est d'ailleurs
cette constatation qui construit qui
conduit Bertrand Mathieu professeur à
l'université Panthéon Sorbonne a
considéré que la présente proposition de
loi était ou
inconstitutionnel ou inutile puisque le
code pénal contient déjà tous les moyens
que je viens de rappeler enfin nous
pensons que cette proposition de loi qui
ferait peser un risque de poursuite
pénale sur des historiens n'est pas
compatible avec le principe de liberté
de la recherche qui constitue lui aussi
un principe fondamental reconnu par les
lois de la
République certains ont argué monsieur
le ministre que la présente proposition
de loi ne présentait pas le même
caractère d'inconstitutionnalité que les
précédentes car elle transposait une
décision cadre européenne je montrerai
tout à l'heure que cet argument ne
résiste pas à l'examen puisque le
présent texte
et une part essentielle de la décision
cadre dont la finalité est de lutter
contre le racisme et la xénophobie par
ailleurs d'ors et déjà réprimé je l'ai
dit par notre code pénal au total je
veux appeler votre attention sur les
risques de censure constitutionnelle
qu'en cours ce texte ce risque n'est pas
uniquement un risque juridique car si le
Conseil constitutionnel censurait ce
texte s'il décidait de se prononcer à
cette occasion sur la
constitutionnalité de la loi du 29
janvier 2001 reconnaissant le génocide
arménien une censure pourrait être
interprétée comme une victoire pour les
négationnistes ce risque est réel et il
ne peut-être méconnu sous peine de faire
à nos compatriotes d'origine arménienne
un cadeau
empoisonné pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons pour les arguments que je
exposerai tout à l'heure la commission
des lois vous invite à vous l'exception
d'irrecevabilité qu'elle a elle-même
adopté mes chers collègues permettez-moi
pour
finir de vous dire que je suis pour ma
part persuadé qu'au-delà de ce débat
dont je sais qu'il se déroulera au Sénat
dans l'écoute des uns et des autres et
queles que soient les conclusions de
celui-ci la réponse aux questions qui
nous occupe se trouve dans l'infini
respect
du dans l'infini respect que nous devons
à la mémoire des innombrables victimes
du génocide arménien et aussi et
indissociablement dans les universités
dans le travail des historiens soucieux
d'objectivité attaché à faire progresser
la connaissance du passé en un mot dans
la science le savoir et la connaissance
je rêve que sous l'gidees par exemple de
l'UNESCO
des historiens
arméniens des historiens turcs des
historiens européens des historiens du
monde travaillent ensemble à mieux
connaître le passé tâche inlassable
tellement indispensable car tourner vers
l'avenir on ne construit pas l'avenir
sur l'amnésie et sur l'oubli nous le
savons tous mes chers collègues à côté
de l'œuvre de mémoire l'œuvre
l'histoire fondé sur la lucidité et sur
les vertus de la connaissance et sans
doute la manière la plus forte de dire
au martyres que nous ne les oublierons
jamais je vous
remercie dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à madame Isabelle
Pasquet
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues il faut avoir la
lucidité et le courage de reconnaître
que l'examen cet après-midi par notre
haute assemblée de la proposition de loi
sur la répression de la comp estation
des génocides reconnus par la loi
suscite un certain malaise parmi nous
depuis son adoption par l'Assemblée
nationale à une très large majorité mais
en présence d'une cinquantaine de
députés seulement ce texte qui pourrait
en apparent sembler logique et cohérent
a ouvert la boîte de Pandore des
questions et des
doutes curieusement à l'inverse de ce
qui s'était passé ici même au mois de
mai dernier le clivage sur la question
de la pénalisation des génocide ne se
fait plus entre la droite et la gauche
mais entre partisans et opposants à
l'idée de légiférer sur ce sujet que
s'est-il passé depuis qui puisse en
partie expliquer cette situation ce
texte concerne pas explicitement le
génocide arménien mais étant maintenant
reconnu par la loi française il est
implicitement l'inscription il faut le
relever assez précipité de la discussion
à l'ordre du jour de notre Assemblée a
tout à la fois fait ressurgir des
questions de fond qui n'avaient pas
véritablement été tranchées et des
soupçons de manœuvre
électorale le cocktail de ces deux
éléments contribuent à entretenir
entretenir ce malaise dont j'ai parlé le
soupçon d'électoralisme est patent nous
sommes nombreux ici avoir compris
qu'avec cette question particulière
comme pour d'autres l'adoption jeudi
d'une proposition de loi concernant
l'éarchie en était le dernier exemple en
date le président de la République tente
d'amadouer telle ou telle catégorie de
la population pour obtenir une majorité
à l'élection présidentielle après
lesarquis qui sont bien utiles pour
récupérer des voix ce sont maintenant
nos 500000 compatriotes d'origine
arménienne qui sont eux aussi utilisés
je dis cela sans
détour car que ce soit les déclarations
du président de la République ou
l'attitude de nos collègues de la
majorité présidentielle
elles sont insidieusement électoralistes
et prêtent le flan à de telles critiques
certes
Nicolas Sarkozi avait promis de
légiférer sur cette question lors de son
voyage en Arménie l'an dernier mais
quelle raison peut bien expliquer que
lui n guerre agacé par les demandes de
repentant sur les actes de notre pays
soit aujourd'hui si pront à l'exiger
d'un État souverain une telle
précipitation sur un sujet aussi délicat
aussi douloureux aussi complexe et
suspecte à l'approche de l'élection
présidentielle sujet complexe et
soulevant d'ailleurs tant de questions
juridique et constitutionnel qu'il est
difficilement acceptable de délibérer si
rapidement la commission des lois n'a
disposé que d'une semaine à peine pour
rédiger son rapport mais c'est également
l'attitude de nos collègues de la
majorité présidentielle qui ajoute au
doute que l'on peut avoir sur la
sincérité de la démarche en effet alors
qu'une proposition de loi traitant de la
même question était venue ici même en
discussion en mai 2011 vous aviez pour
la pour la repousser utiliser des
arguments totalement contraires à ceux
que vous utilisez aujourd'hui pour
justifier ce retournement acrobatique le
président du groupe um n'a aucunement
hésiter à avouer qu'il s'agissait de ne
pas gêner le président de la République
tout est dit les arrière-pincées
électoralistes éclate au grand
jour
électoralisme s'il vous plaît électoral
laissz poursuivre l'orateur s'il vous
plaît électoralisme communitarisme
lecture politique de l'histoire c'est
dans ce contexte confus passionné mais
aussi malsin que se déroule notre
discussion et pourtant une question
aussi grave mérite du respect de la
dignité et de la cohérence pour notre
part c'est la démarche qui a toujours
été la nottre nous voulons rester
cohérents logique avec nous-mêmes mais
également fidèle à notre engagement
auprès de nos compatriotes d'origine
arménienne et à la solidarité active que
nous leur avons toujours
manifesté la cohérence est de considérer
que la reconnaissance il y a 10 ans par
une loi française du génocide des
Arméniens dans l'Empire ottoman doit
maintenant être prolongé par des
sanctions
pénales mon collègue et ami gu ficher
pour qui j'ai une pensée toute
particulière aujourd'hui qui
certainement en train de nous regarder
premier signataire d'une proposition de
loi similaire à celle que nous examinons
aujourd'hui et déposé par notre groupe
en juillet 2005 puis redéposé
régulièrement jusqu'en la dernière fois
en 2 10 dans son exposé des motifs
souligner dans son exposé des motifs
l'importance du travail qui est resté à
accomplir pour tirer toutes les
conséquences de la loi portant
reconnaissance du génocide arménien
c'est la même logique qui avait animé la
loi guesso de 1990 sur la contestation
des crimes contre l'humanité figurant en
annexe à l'accord de Londres du 8 août
1945 mais aussi du génocide du peuple
juif tel que défini par le tribunal
militaire de
nurmberg cette loi ne pouvait évidemment
pas à l'absence d'une reconnaissance qui
n'interviendra que plus tard prendre en
compte le génnocide du peuple arménien
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
aujourd'hui nécessaire de compléter les
dispositions de la loi
2881 sur la la liberté de la presse à
laquelle elle fait référence et de créer
un délit pénal non seulement pour
contestation mais aussi pour
minimisation
ou transancière d'un génocide désormais
juridiquement reconnu en France c'est
aussi une question de logique juridique
et de coordination pénale il serait naïf
de croire que les français d'origine
arménienne sont aujourd'hui sur notre
territoire à l'abri de manifestation
d'opinion ou d'acte visant nier ou à
contester les génocide dont ont été
victimes leurs ancêtres car il y a bien
eu au sens juridique du terme une
entreprise délibéré de massacre et
d'élimination programmé d'un peuple par
des troupes agissant sous les ordres
d'un gouvernement cela ce n'est pas une
assemblée politique qui le dit ce sont
des historiens qui ont travaillé
scientifiquement selon les règles de
leur discipline en rassemblant documents
et témoignages et en les soumettant à un
examen critique comme le texte dont nous
discutons la contestation la
minimisation de ces faits doit donc
pouvoir être sanctionné il s'agit de
reconnaître les souffrances héritées du
passé d'offrir une réparation symbolique
aux pires blessures de l'histoire
d'interdire la négation des pages les
plus dramatiques du siècle passé c'est
simplement de cela qu'il s'agit non pas
de limiter la liberté d'expression ni
d'entraver la recherche historique
périodiquement le gouvernement turc
suscite des manifest tion de
négationnisme qui prennent la forme de
profanation de lieux de mémoire arménien
de Stell de monuments commémoratif
ou bien encore de propos révisionnistes
et négationnistes qui se propagent en
toute impunité sur Internet nous avons
tous encore en mémoire ce type de
manifestation violentes et les actes de
profanation commis à Lyon en 2006 qui
visaient explicitement la communauté
arménienne au-delà de simple délit de
droit commun il faut aussi pouvoir
prendre en compte la signification
profonde de tels actes il ne faut plus
que le négationnisme les actes de
propagande qui nient leur mémoire
puissent être à l'œuvre dans notre pays
ils doivent être pénalisés au nom des
pressions du gouvernement turc exercé
sur notre pays il faut aussi relever
cette impressionnante manifestation
samedi dernier à Paris plus d'une
dizaine de milliers de ressortissants
turcs venus de toute l'Europe on scander
des slogans qui démontraient sans
ambigué leur volonté de nier le génocide
des Arméniens nos compatriotes d'origine
arménienne attendent à juste titre de
pouvoir être protégés dans ce domaine
ils attendent de nous que justice soit
rendue à la mémoire de leur peuple qui
ne puisse en France y être porté
atteinte sans sanction la pénalisation
qui est créée par ce texte relève tout
simplement du droit élémentaire de
chacun à ne pas être publiquement
injurié de la possibilité d'obtenir
réparation quand son yé les raisons et
les conditions dans lesquelles se
déroule un massacre ce que sanctionne ce
texte c'est la négation en tant en tant
qu'elle représente une incitation à la
haine qui provoque un trouble à l'ordre
public en légiférant notre Parlement
confirmera le vote historique de 2001 et
pourrait au plan international conforter
la position de la France dans son rôle
de défenseur des droits de l'homme
partout dans le monde dans notre pays la
négation et la contestation de pratiques
génocidaires doivent pouvoir être
réprimé tout toutes les fois qu'elle
constitue une atteinte à l'ordre public
démocratique et une atteinte à la
démocratie tout court cela n'est
pourtant pas possible en l'état actuel
de notre droit de même ces pratiques
étant clairement contraire au Droit de
l'Homme définis par des Déclaration
universelle opposable en droit
international en les niant on porte du
même coup atteinte à ces déclarations et
on affaiblit lapportée des garanties
qu'elle présente pour les
citoyens en outre les réactions
couroussées du gouvernement turc qui a
rappelé son ambassadeur multiplié les
pressions et Brandi des menaces de
rétorsion diplomatique et économique
traduisent clairement la conception d'un
État qui pratique une forme de
négationnisme officiel sur la question
du génocide arménien et où la liberté
d'expression sur ces questions n'existe
pas ce contre quoi les autorités turques
s'élèvent ce n'est pas seulement
l'opportunité d'une loi réprimant le
négationnisme c'est la réalité même du
fait
génocidaire ce négationnisme sournois
ainsi Dieu qui se réfugie derrière le
respect de la liberté de penser conforte
les partisans de sanctions nécessaires
pour s'en défendre ceci
étant comme d'autres membres de mon
groupe je suis consciente des
difficultés que soulève cette
proposition de loi je suis aussi
sensible aux nombreuses interrogations
et fortes réticences qu'ell suscite il
faut évidemment s'interroger sur la
compétence de nos assemblées
parlementaires à qualifier des faits
historiques et et et a encadré d'une
manière ou d'une autre le travail des
historiens comme l'a soutenu avec son
talent habituel monsieur suer rapporteur
de la commission des lois la légitimité
de l'intervention du législateur dans le
jugement de l'histoire et sa
compatibilité avec plusieurs principes
fondamentaux de notre droit entraîneront
de grands risques
d'inconstitutionnalité de la même façon
on ne peut que s'inquiéter de la
détérioration de nos relations avec la
Turquie mais également de la perte
d'influence de notre diplomatie dans la
région notre pays se prive de marge de
manœuvre internationale sans pour autant
aider la réconciliation entre la Turquie
et l'Arménie à reconnaître le génocide
arménien si l'on souhaite sincèrement
que la Turquie se penche sur son
histoire est-ce la meilleure méthode
enfin certains pensent même qu'il y a
une contradiction à prendre le risque de
faire dépendre notre politique extérieur
du poids de toutes les communautés qui
fond de notre pays et a ensuite comme le
fait le gouver ement prétendre lutter
contre le
communitarisme je regrette je ne rejette
pas ces arguments qui s'opposent à
l'adoption de ce texte ils sont partagés
par un certains membres de notre groupe
tous ces critiques et ses interrogations
ont suscité des différences
d'appréciation et ont partagé le groupe
communiste républicains et citoyens et
au final le plus grand nombre de
sénatrices et de sénateurs de notre
groupe votera en faveur de l'adoption de
ce texte certains voteront contre contre
et les autres ne participe pas ne
participeront pas au vote je vous
remercie je vous remercie ma cher
collègue le la parole est à Monsieur
Jacques mzard du groupe
RD voilà suite ici au Sénat de cette
discussion de ce fameux texte sur la
répression des contestations de
l'existence des génocides vous l'avez
entendu la discussion générale vient
d'être entamée euh par Isabelle Pasquet
pour le groupe communiste vienent
ensuite Jacques mzard le président du
groupe RDSE les radicaux qui va prendre
la parole dans quelques instants on sait
que le groupe radical votera contre
cette loi euh également comme vous
Nathalie Goulet sénatrice de l'Union
centriste et républicaine de l'Orne vous
allez voter contre cette loi tout à
l'heure madame Pasquet euh et évoquit un
certain malaise en évoquant la
discussion de ce texte ici au Sénat cet
après-midi c'est un texte c'est un mot
ce mot de malaise que vous reprendriez
de votre bouche oui d'abord on a on a
déjà évoqué ce texte le 4 mai dernier
deuxièmement il est d'une hpocrisie
extraordinaire puisqueen réalité le seul
génocide visé par la loi c'est le
génocide arménien puisque la loi guesso
est intervenue en ce qui concerne la
Choa donc c'est déjà une hypocrisie
terrible et en plus c'est une promesse
électorale du président de la République
et donc c'est un texte de pure
opportunité de purure opportunisme
pourrait-on dire qui n'a rien à voir
avec le droit et moi je trouve que le
président sueur a eu une expression
absolument claire et et
incontournable en disant que cette loi
était untit constitutionnel il aailleurs
une motion à ce propos tout à l'heure
qui sera défendu par Jean-Pierre suer et
une motion également qui dit que
finalement le Parlement ne doit pas
faire l'histoire c'était le gros
alimentaire dués argumentaire du
président de la commission des lois mais
c'était aussi l'argumentaire du
président yest du président d'Inter et
de tous les parlementaires qui ont qui
ont voté l'exception d'irrecevabilité le
4 mai dernier donc rien n'a changé sauf
la proximité des les élections
présidentielles alors pourquoi vous-même
vous allez voter contre cette loi au
sein de votre groupe où il n'y a pas de
consigne de vote particulièr là encore
les avis sont partagés voilà on est on
est très heureux au groupe de l'Union
centriste et républicain nous n'avons
pas de consigne de vote on nous a pas
demandé de rester chez nous on n' pas
demandé d'aller boire un café au moment
du vote on nous a pas demandé de nous
abstenir et on nous laisse la parole
donc c'est déjà une grande chance parce
que c'est pas par dans tous les groupes
la même la même chose non euh ce qui a
c'est que bon moi je suis totalement les
arguments du président euh sueur euh et
j'ajoute des arguments qui euh qui ont
trait à notre position diplomatique dans
la région
euh l'Arménie d'aujourd'hui est alliée à
l'Iran et à la Russie ce qui moi me
dérange pas du tout mais ce texte heurte
nos alliés Turcs de l'OTAN et et il faut
le comprendre parce qu'en fait c'est la
Turquie d'hier qui peut-être condamnée
aujourd'hui mais c'est la Turquie
d'aujourd'hui qui est blessée
deuxièmement nous nous sommes aussi en
position dans le Caucase puisque la
France copréside le Groupe de Minsk qui
arbitre la guerre entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan parce que ça ça ne date
pas de 100 ans l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan sont aujourd'hui en guerre
l'Arménie occupe des territoires
azerbaïdjanais notamment au carabak et
la France est co-président du Groupe de
Minsk en prenant parti pour l'Arménie
contre la Turquie la France perd sa
neutralité dans le Groupe de Minsk en
Azerbaïdjan on se demande si on va
conserver ou pas une coprésidence donc
si vous voulez le la Turquie est un
immense allié diplomatique c'est un
joker diplomatique dans le golf persi au
proch au Moyen-Orient et je pense que ce
texte est totalement inutile de ce point
de vue et décrédibilise la France donc
vous approuvez les propos par exemple du
ministre des Affaires étrangères Alain
Jupé qui juge ce texte inopportun
aujourd'hui absolument mais il ne
s'exprime pas assez fort et et
probablement pas assez pour avoir
emporté la conviction du président de la
République qui a amené ce texte sur les
fonds baptismau puisque que que ce soit
à l'Assemblée nationale ou au Sénat ce
texte vient sur un créneau um ou
gouvernemental autrement dit vous
comprenez la décision d'Ankara de
menacer de nouvelles représailles
économiques financières militaire que
sais-je si ce texte ce soir est adopté
au Sénat moi je veux pas rentrer dans
les considérations de de sanction
économique parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'un pays qui a pas de ressources un
pays pauvre un pays modeste ou un pays
comme l'Arménie qui est finalement sous
le jou n'urit pas d'argument j'allais
dire solide argument solide et et et
n'aurait pas de droit sur la scène
internationale ce qui est pas très digne
ce qui pas trèsd donc si vous voulez les
sanctions économiques bon le président
fait un choix le président va dans le
Caucase il dort à Erevan il passe 4h à
Bakou il va s'incliner sur les victimes
du génocide et pas sur l'allée des
martyres à Bakou le président fait un
choix à partir du moment où il fait un
choix mais le pays en supportera les
conséquen mais moi je je je place pas
les représailles économiques dans ma
réflexion ma réflexion elle est
essentiellement juridique elle suit le
le président de la commission des lois
comme le précédent d'ailleurs
Jean-Jacques yest à qui faut vraiment
rendre hommage et et elle elle se place
en tant que membre de la commission des
affaires étrangères d'un point de vue
diplomatique na Goulet si ce texte est
adopté ce soir au Sénat on ne le sait
pas encore mais c'est très vraisemblable
pu on fait des décomtes précis et des
voix et des sénateurs présents
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer un recours devant le
Conseil constitutionnel sur ce texte ah
il va falloir trouver 60 courageux pour
le signer moi je le signerai bien
entendu je pense que mon collègue mard
les G mais il y a un risque parce que si
vous voulez en en déignant
l'argumentaire de de Robert badinterre
et de Jean-Pierre Sueur dans ces cas-là
on aurait aucun risque aller au Conseil
constitutionnel mais comme on est aussi
très conscient de ce que cet
argumentaire est un bon argumentaire si
on défère le texte d'aujourd'hui devant
le Conseil constitutionnel on va
provoquer
irrémédiablement l'abrogation ou la la
résolution du texte de enfin
l'annulation de la loi de 2001 sur le
génocide et comme donc il y aurait une
sorte d'effet dominau sur cette dans
cette affaire mais c'est le principe du
recours et de la réforme
constitutionnelle mais comme on n'est
pas des négationnistes si vous voulez
c'est on est quand même un peu piégé
vous voyez puisque puisque le recours va
va forcément psof factcto entraîner
l'annulation de ce texte qui est
inconstitutionnel mais entraînera comme
vous l'avez dit dans un effet de domino
la loi de 2001 et on va tous se
retrouver négationniste ce qui est pas
le sujet puisque personne ne ni
aujourd'hui l'existence du du génocide
arménien merci en tout cas beaucoup
Nathalie Goulet de ce vos éclairage en
particulier juridique sur ce texte qui
dont la discussion se se continue je
rappelle que tout autour du palais du
Luxembourg et bien il y a des
manifestations prourque proarménienne
avec un un service d'ordre très vigilant
autour du Sénat cet après-midi suite de
la discussion c'est Jacques mzard le
président du groupe des radicaux le
groupe RDSE ici qui va voter en tout cas
argumenter argumenter pour voter contre
ce texte on l'écoute monsieur le garde
des
saut en tant que ministre de la justice
il est de ma responsabilité de vous
indiquer que ce texte répressif pose un
certain nombre de problèmes de
conformité aux normes juridiques
supérieur interne et international il
ajouté que ce texte soulevait des
interrogations au regard de deux grands
principes d'une part le principe de
l'égalité des délits et des peines or la
proposition de loi ne repose sur aucune
définition précise d'effets constitutifs
du génocide qui serait inscrit dans une
convention internationale ou établie par
une décision définitive rendue par une
juridiction
internationale monsieur Mercier déclaré
adosser la sanction pénale à la
reconnaissance du génocide arménien ne
me paraît pas suffisant la portée
normative de ce texte semble incertaine
et il argait aussi en second lieu de la
liberté
d'expression monsieur le ministre ici
présent comment pouvez-vous aujourd'hui
désavouer votre éminent collègue il ne
s'est pas démis dois-jeen conclure qu'il
s'est soumis mes chers collègues comment
pourrions-nous oublier l'intervention
ici même du président badinterre qui a
conjugué avec son immense talent le
chemin du droit et la voix du cœur il
nous a encore rappelé la même chose dans
son article du Monde d'il y a quelques
jours que ce texte est
inconstitutionnel et que la
jurisprudence constante du Conseil
constitutionnelle si une loi qui lui est
soumise repose sur une loi antérieure
qui ne lui a pas été déférée la question
de la constitutionnalité de cette loi
antérieure pourra être soulevée et la
loi de 2001 sera anéant
d'ailleurs quelle hypocrisie que
l'argument de certains d'affirmer que le
vote de ce texte qui nous est soumis
permettra au Conseil constitutionnel de
trancher sur la loi de
2001 c'est à juste titre que Robert
Badinter nous a demandé de refuser
d'examiner un texte inconstitutionnel et
de ne pas nous laisser abuser par le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui nous a
déclaré qu'instaurer un débat général de
négationnisme du génocide
découlant d'une décision cadre de
l'Union européenne de 2008 était normal
car le texte proposé ne mentionne pas
l'incitation à la haine que doit
comporter la négation du génocide contre
une communauté et la référence à
l'article mes chers collègues du Doyen
Vedel publié en 2005 sur la question de
la constitutionnalité de la loi de 2001
relève d'une argumentation imparable oui
le premier texte constitutionnel qui
condamne la loi de 2001 et l'article 34
de la Constitution et ça c'est une
réalité
intangible et il rappelle doyen Vedel il
rappelait que la loi de 2001 ne portait
sur aucune des notions visées par le
texte qu'elle pose ou non des règles au
sens de l'article
34 tout aussi grave rappelait-il était
l'usurpation par le législateur de
compétences concernant les relations
internationales et la conduite de la
diplom e vous en faut-il davantage nous
souhaitons oui que ce texte fasse
l'objet d'un examen par le Conseil
constitutionnel oui ce texte est
contraire au principe de la liberté
d'expression protégé par les articles 11
de la Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et par l'article 10 de la Convention
européenne de sauvegarde des droits de
l'homme et des libertés fondamentales
car vous savez tous que la restriction à
cette liberté par la Cour européenne
était soumise est soumise à des
conditions strictes et mes chers
collègues la rédaction de la proposition
de loi elle-même est une aberration
juridique en édictant des sanctions
contre ceux qui auront minimiser de
façon
outrancière l'existence d'un ou
plusieurs crimes de génocide le délit de
minimisation
outrancière mériterait une explication
du garde des saut mais vous allez
certainement nous vous l'appter monsieur
le ministre on atteint clairement le
maximum de la médiocrité juridique en
outre nous savons nous savons que
l'arsenal de notre droit pénal
actuel suffit sans aucun problème à
faire sanctionner les provocations à la
haine raciale ainsi que l'apologie de
crime contre l'humanité oui pierre
norura a raison de parler de cynisme
politicien d'un texte insupportable car
mettant en cause la recherche historique
et scientifique il a raison de marteler
qu'en démocratie la liberté par
l'histoire et la liberté de tous
monsieur le ministre en novembre 2008 le
président de l'Assemblée nationale
présenter le rapport de la mission
d'information sur les questions
mémorielles première et principale
proposition le rôle du Parlement n'est
pas d'adopter des lois qualifiant ou
portant une appréciation sur des faits
historiques à forciorie lorsque celle-ci
s'accompagne de sanctions pénales ce
rapport est complet intéressant empreint
du recul et de la sérénité nécessaire il
met en garde contre la prolifération de
tel texes demain sera-t-il question d'un
génocide vendien reviendrton sur le
massacre des qatars mettrons-nous au
pilori l'Espagne et les États-Unis pour
les massacres des
Amérindiens de quel droit le Parlement
français s'investit-il d'une telle
mission certes pas de sa propre
constitution certes pas de l'histoire de
notre République au-delà du droit est-ce
le moyen d'apaiser les relations entre
l'Arménie la Turquie l'Azerbaïjan est-ce
le moyen de favoriser le lien social en
France entre français d'origine
arménienne et turque est-ce le moyen de
dire au gouvernement turc et à son
peuple que certaines évolutions
actuelles nous inquiète voire que nous
les déplorons n'est-ce pas plutôt le
chemin pour le rédire davantage dans une
approche nationaliste dure et
d'accélérer le processus de prise de
distance avec les principes du kémalisme
comment imaginer que ce dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui un siècle après
les faits ne serait pas ressenti par les
Turcs quatre générations ayant passé
comme une agression vexatoire et inutile
la Turquie est un grand pays héritier de
plusieurs histoires trait d'union entre
l'Orient et l'Occident la France s vit
reconnaître des siècles durant une place
particulière nous n'avons aucun droit de
leur infliger une quelconque repentance
mes chers collègues l'adoption d'une
telle proposition de loi ne peut grandir
le département le Parlement elle ne peut
que l'affaiblir loin de valoriser son
rôle son utilité par rapport à
l'exécutif le Parlement s'en fait
l'exécuteur d'œuvre dont cet exécutif
répugne à assumer directement la
paternité la France est grande quand
elle montre au monde qu'elle ouvre le
chemin des libertés dans ses lois sur
son territoire la nation des droits de
l'homme issu du siècle des Lumières ne
saurait se reconnaître dans de
déplorables gesticulations législatives
Jean Denis Bredin disait justement
devant la mission à coyé la loi non plus
que la justice ne peut redresser
l'histoire l'humilité si est à la
grandeur d'une nation pour ceux qui nous
entendent qui nous regardent qui
attendent que nous soyons les premiers
fidèles au grand principe du droit
fondateur de notre idéal républicain
nous devons rejeter ce texte dans les
oubliettes de
l'histoire je vous remercie chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Roger carucci pour le groupe
UMP
le
rejet monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
président de la commission des lois on a
entendu depuis maintenant une petite
heure bien des choses et je dois dire
que ça prouve que nos groupes par
définition sont eux-mêmes partagés des
choses parfois contradictoire issu de
tous les
bancs moi je voudrais simplement et sans
donner dans dans un juridisme
excessif dire quelques
mots merci monsieur le Président d'abord
euh franchement il y a un débat qui est
un faux
débat sur faut-il des lois mémorielles
quel est le rôle des historiens quel est
le rôle des politiques quel est le rôle
du Parlement moi j'ai été dans un temps
antérieur l'élève et le disciple en
histoire avec S Provence de la l'un des
plus grands spécialistes de l'histoire
turque Robert
mantran et j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec
lui mais comment pouvez-vous demander
aux
historiens de
qualifier comment pouvez-vous demander
aux historiens de prendre la
responsabilité de faire les choix des
responsables politiques qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce que les
responsables politiques ont peur de
faire leur choix eux-mêmes et disent et
disent merci monsieur le Président et
disent c'est pas à nous c'est aux
historiens de le faire pardon de vous
rappeler et relisez tous nos historiens
français des 19e des 20e siècles ils
sont eux-mêmes très divisés y compris
sur la manière dont ils ont appréhendé
la montée du nazisme les réalités de la
guerre de 14 les réalité de la 2uxème
guerre mondiale alors à un moment donné
il faut laisser les historiens trava
travailler il faut laisser les
historiens analyser réfléchir
approfondir rechercher mais vous n'avez
pas à dire aux historien c'est vous qui
devez définir et prendre la
responsabilité qui est celle des états
ça n'est pas aux différentes écoles
historiques et aux différents historiens
qui sont souvent d'ailleurs en
contradiction et c'est normal les uns
avec les autres de définir et de dire
sinon je vous le dis dans la plupart des
cas on vous dira que comme les écoles
historiques ce sont en contradiction
vous ne déciderez jamais de rien parce
que les historiens vous diront c'est pas
à nous de dire de qualifier nous nous
apportons les faits vous vous décidez
non non certainement pas mais vous êtes
là un représentant du peuple merci
Monsieur carer toujours est-il que
évident naturellement c'est au Parlement
de chacun des États de dire de dire en
fonction des choix qui sont les leurs
quelles sont les décisions qui sont
prises le Parlement français et c'est
ainsi le Parlement français a voté pas
aujourd'hui a voté il y a plus de 20 ans
pour le premier texte il y a plus de 10
ans pour le second la reconnaissance de
deux génocides le génocide de la Choa et
le génocide arménien sauf que pourquoi
comment c'est comme ça sauf que les deux
ne sont pas sanctionnés de la même
manière le premier est sanctionné de
manière pénale si vous le critiquez
l'attaqueer le niz de manière
outrancière et le second pour le moment
ne l' pas c'est quoi attendez c'est quoi
l'égalité c'est quoi
l'équité merci président mais si vous
avez reconnu les deux il faut
naturellement que les deux soi traités
de la même manière quelle que soit la
manière don soit traité chacun des deux
mais il faut évidemment que les deux
soient traités de la même manière sinon
ça n'a pas de sens et ça veut dire que
vous avez reconnu des génocides dans
lesquels vous avez créé vous-même une
hiérarchie il y a ceux qui seraient
pénalement répréhensibles et il y a ceux
qu'on pourrait critiquer contester par
conséquent il y a là une anomalie et une
évidence
anomalie alors j'entends bien et moi je
sincèrement et là je faux pas non non
merci je n'interroms jamais personne
j'aimerais bien que ce soit le cas non
mais ce que ce que je dis sincèrement
c'est que merci ce que je dis
sincèrement c'est que ou bien il fallait
pas voter à l'époque la reconnaissance
des génocides ou bien une fois que vous
les avez voté les deux il faut
évidemment les sanctionner les deux de
la même manière et
sincèrement sincèrement j'entends bien
on dit est-ce qu'il faut des lois
mémorielles je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
franchement dans un temps où je
n'exerçais pas des fonctions uniquement
politiques j'étais un digne inspecteur
général en histoire j'étais le premier à
dire dans les réunions d'inspection
générale c'est pas à nous de qualifier
et on ne le faisait pas et on ne le
faisait pas si les historiens ne le font
pas si les responsables politiques le le
font pas qui le fera qui le fera
personne personne ne le fera ça veut
dire qu'on laisse les
gens éventuellement victime de
commentaires ou de critiques transè le
texte de aujourd'hui d'ailleurs en
rajoutant le terme outrancière et tout à
fait dans la cohérence moi je vais vous
dire j'entends bien et et je n'ai cassz
peu de temps je veux pas faire un long
discours mais j'entends bien ce qui est
dit par rapport à la Turquie je suis
comme ça on va être tranquille un
admirateur inconditionnel de l'histoire
de l'Empire ottoman je n'oublie pas je
n'oublie pas et Madame Bassa sera sans
doute d'accord avec moi je n'oublie pas
que du temps de l'Inquisition en Europe
occidentale et en France la Sublime
Porte recevait elle les parias je
n'oublie pas que lorsqu'en France nous
avons évoqué les dit Nantes l'Empire
turque a reçu les protestants et les a
valorisé je n'oublie pas que dans
l'histoire turque il y a une histoire
glorieuse un empire qui a été bien plus
tolérant que bien des États d'Europe
occidentale je n'oublie pas mais je dis
seulement à l'actuel gouvernement turc
toute histoire toute histoire l'histoire
de France comme les histoire de tous les
pays du monde toute histoire ne peut
malheureusement pas être que glorieuse
et il y a parfois ici ou là à certains
moment des problèmes des tâches qu'il
faut reconnaître pour avancer lorsque
Jacques Chirac a en 1995 fait la
déclaration qu'il a fait il a été et il
l'a fait à l'honneur de l'ensemble des
formations politiques et de l'ensemble
des Français lorsque nous avançons sur
un certain nombre de sujets quels que
soient les données est politique nous le
faisons à l'honneur de tous lorsque le
gouvernement turc a décidé il y a
quelques années de réouvrir le dossier
de discuter avec les Arméniens d'essayer
de trouver des solutions c'est à son
honneur de l'avoir fait mais
aujourd'hui il y a non il est pas
question d'arrêter il est question
seulement de dire que pour celles et
ceux qui originair d'Arménie descendant
d'Arménien ici en France nous n'avons
pas le même devoir de protection qu'
l'égard de toutes celles et de tous ceux
qui appartiennent à la communauté juive
en France pourquoi comment les massacres
d'Adana valent pas les massacres
d'ailleurs si et les choses sont là les
massacres sont les massacres les
victimes sont les victimes et les
descendants des victimes sont les
descendants des victimes ils ont le
droit au même honneur que les
autres merci Monsieur
carci la parole est à madame Esther
Benbassa pour le groupe écologiste je
demanderai chers collègues de laisser
vos collègues s'exprimer sans les
interrompre tout particulièrement
Monsieur carer d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur et
président de la commission des lois
chers
collègues c'est en pensant à la
préceprice arménienne qui m'a pris le
français à Istanbul et à la famille
Papazian avec laquelle j'ai grandi dans
le même immeuble que j'ai rédigé cette
intervention j'ai ressenti tôt enfant
cette atmosphère lourde des maisons
arméniennes effet diffus etue d'une
souffrance intime sans remède
méconnu les Arméniens n'ont pas comme
les Juifs eu leur Nuremberg par la loi
du 29 janvier 2001 reconnaissant le
génocide arménien la France a un peu
comblé ce manque mais ce n'est que
lorsque la Turquie elle-même franchira
ce pas que justice sera faite cela nul
ne peut le faire à la place de la
Turquie lieu du
crime l'utilisation du mot prête parfois
à des débats tantôt vain tantôt indigne
construit sur le grec Genos race et le
latin caedes meurtre massacre le mot
génocide a été créé en
1944 par Richard Lemkin un avocat juif
ayant perdu toute sa famille dans les
années noires c'est sa connaissance du
génocide arménien de
1915 et des persécutions antijuivees qui
l'a conduit à définir le génocide comme
je cite tout plan méthodiquement
coordonné pour détruire la vie et la
culture d'un peuple et menacer son unité
biologique et spirituel un génocide a
bien été perpétré par les Jeunes Turcs
aidé par des Kurdes dans l'exécution des
massacres même si certains Kurdes
refusèrent de collaborer et abritèrent
des survivants aucun historien sérieux
ayant travaillé sur cette sur les
minorités pendant cette la période
ottomane ne peut nier ce fait et si la
Turquie tant tarde à temps à reconnaître
ce génocide c'est qu'elle n'a jamais été
dans la position de l'Allemagne vaincue
de
1945 qui ne put qu'admettre ces crimes
c'est aussi parce que la nation turque
moderne s'est de fait construite sur
l'éradication de la présence
nonmusulmane Anatolie ou bat son cœur
certes l'histoire des relations l'Empire
ottoman et de la Turquie avec ses
minorités non mususulmanes ne se résume
pas à ce génocide ni au PO gr ni aux
déportations de la République
nationaliste elle est tout autant
l'histoire de l'accueil de ces minorités
et d'une pluriséculaire tolérance à leur
endroit reste que la Turquie se doit
décrire aussi les pages noires de son
passé or la société civile turque bouge
dans ce sens depuis un moment et
j'ajoute en contournant l'état l'appel
d'intellectuel turc de 2008 de demandant
pardon aux Arméniens en témoigne seul
moyen de contrer un double processus
négation du génocide arménien d'un côté
véritable industrie nationale en Turquie
turcophobie des Arméniens de la diaspora
en l'occurrence en France de l'autre
alimentant le myth du turc barbare qui
sert d' libi aux adversaire de l'entrée
de ce pays musulmanans dans l'Union dans
l'Union
européenne cette loi soit bricolé dans
la hâte maquillé pour passer deux forces
ne contribuera ni à la reconnaissance
turque du génocide ni au rapprochement
arménno-turque au
contraire de la loi guesso le grand
historien Pierre Vidal Naé qui avait
perdu les siens dans les camps de la
mort disait ceci on peut comprendre une
telle loi en Allemagne mais en France
elle est
inutile je dirais la même chose de la
loi dont nous débattons on peut
comprendre une telle loi en Turquie mais
pas en France d'autant que l'EN France
elle-même a encore beaucoup de travail à
faire dans l'écriture des page sombre de
sa propre histoire exaction coloniale
comprise j'ai tendance à penser que
l'arrivée de cette loi en pleine période
électorale ne facilite pas le jugement
du législateur
écartelé entre sa conscience et la
discipline de parti l'histoire ne
saurait s'écrire au Parlement et moins
encore avec de telles arrières pensées
outre qu'elle muselle la liberté
d'expression et la liberté
intellectuelle cette sorte de loi
encourage enfin une compétition des
mémoires un communautarisme
préjudiciable à la cohésion nationale
pour toute ces raisons je suis favorable
à la motion d'exception
d'irrecevabilité proposée par notre
commission des lois le groupe écologiste
votera donc pour les motions de
procédure et si elles ne sont pas
adoptées pour les amendements de
suppression à défaut de l'adoption de
ces amendements notre groupe votera
évidemment contre cette proposition de
loi et je fini en rendant hommage au
président de la commission des lois pour
son discours humaniste
et tous les membres de la commission des
lois
merci je vous remercie chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Hervé Marseille du groupe
UCR
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois peu de textes soumis
à notre Haute Assemblée soulève autant
de passion à l'évidence de débat de
controverse que cette proposition de loi
ce texte a un titre il ne s'agit pas de
la reconnaissance du génocide il s'agit
de la répression de la contestation de
l'existence des génocides reconnu par la
loi les prises de position de nombreuses
personnalité ces derniers jours le
contenu des débats ont involontairement
ou à dessin créé une confusion une
ambigué en mélangeant le rôle du
Parlement les lois dites mémorielles la
constitutionnalité du texte à voter ou
encore la persévérance dans la négation
par certains du génocide des Arméniens
perpétré dès
1915 le texte à l'étude rappelons-le est
un texte strictement pénal et il s'agit
en aucun cas de réécrire l'histoire en
effet depuis le 29 janvier 2001 ceci a
été dit à abondamment depuis le début de
cette discussion la France a reconnu
l'existence du génocide arménien et le
Parlement l'avait d'ailleurs voté de
façon très consensuel comme en Russie au
Canada en Argentine en Italie ou encore
en Allemagne une nation et
singulièrement son parlement ont me
semble-t-il le droit de se forger une
idée du passé pour fonder son projet
pour l'avenir le présent texte ne fait
que compléter la portée normative dont
il était originairement privé cela a été
fait par ailleurs également en Suisse et
en Slovaquie 11 années se sont écoulées
nous appartient dans notre rôle de
législateur de servir la devise de la
République et de veiller à l'égalité de
traitement des citoyens devant la loi
comme l'a dit avant moi notre collègue
kucci est-il admissible qu'il puisse
exister une différence suivant les
génocides que nous avons reconnu
imaginons la situation dans laquelle un
individu aurait tenu des propos
négationnistes à la fois à l'encontre de
la Choa et du génocide arménien comment
justifier qu'on ne puisse pas exercer de
recours pénal dans un cas alors même que
l'auteur de ces dans l'autre cas serait
poursuivi dans le cadre de la loi guesso
la France a reconnu de génocide est-il
normal que la contestation du génocide
arménien ne puisse pas être aussi
réprimé que la contestation du gécide
des Juifs c'est dans cet esprit mes
chers collègues que cette proposition de
loi nous offre une occasion de nous
prémunir contre les attaques
négationnistes certes ce texte ne couvre
pas l'intégralité du problème que je
viens de soulever mais il a au moins le
mérite d'en appurer l'un des aspects les
plus douloureux tout d'abord il est
indéniable et chacun l'a reconn connu
ici quelle que soit son opinion qu'il y
a un génocide en Arménie les travaux les
rapports produits lors de l'étude de la
loi de 2001 l'ont amplement démontré
pour autant à aucun moment ce texte ne
souhaite graver l'histoire dans le
marbre la recherche scientifique
historique doit pouvoir continuer je dis
bien scientifique c'est d'ailleurs ce
que le tribunal de grande instance de
Paris a exprimé dans l'affaire Lewis cet
historien négationniste le 21 juin 1995
de la manière suivante attendu que même
s'il n'est nullement établi qu'il est
poursuivi un but étranger à sa mission
d'historien et s'il n'est pas
contestable qu'il puisse soutenir cette
question une opinion différente de celle
des associations de mendress il demeure
que c'est en occultant les éléments
contraires à sa thèse que le défendeur a
pu affirmer qu'il n'y avait pas de
preuve sérieuse du génocide arménien
qu'il a ainsi manqué à ses devoirs
d'objectivité et de prudence en
s'exprimant sans nuance sur un sujet
aussi sensible que ses propos
susceptibles de raviver injustement la
douleur de la communauté arménienne son
fautif et justifie une indemnisation
dans les conditions énoncées au
dispositifs il me semble chers collègues
que les rédacteurs du texte que l'on
examine aujourd'hui ont suivi les
préoccupations de l'autorité judiciaire
en reprenant l'idée qu'il est possible
de discuter de l'existence même des
génocides à condition que cela se fasse
avec rigueur et sans excès comme l'a
rappelé monsieur le Président de la
Commission tout à l'heure c'est ainsi
que j'approuve pleinement la rédaction
de l'article 24 TER qui vise les
contestations
outrancières une littérature abondante
affirme que la loi de 2001 comme le
texte qui vient d'être voté par
l'Assemblée nationale pour pénalisé
serait inconstitutionnel en visant
l'article 34 de la Constitution celui-ci
énumère non limitativement les
principaux domaines de la loi et dans ce
domaine et le domaine pardon a été
largement étendu par la jurisprudence du
Conseil
constitutionnel la reconnaissance du
génocide arménien relève à mes yeux de
la loi qui a consacré ici un acte une
volonté politique la menace d'une
question préalable
d'inconstitutionnalité a d'autant moins
de sens que cette démarche voulue par le
président de la République est destinée
à protéger les libertés publiques la loi
de 2001 n'est àortie d'aucune contrainte
elle est purement déclarative la liberté
d'expression n'est pas en cause car la
proposition de loi qui nous est soumise
vise le négationnisme outrancier le juge
le juge monsieur le Président de la
Commission des loi et lui seul peut sur
le fondement de l'article 211-1 du Code
pénal qualifier juridiquement les faits
dès lors rien ne s'oppose à cette
proposition de loi et rien ne justifie
la motion
d'irrecevabilité ce texte de devrait
donc remporter tout le soutien qu'il
mérite dans notre Haute Assemblée
rejeter la motion de la Commission et
adopter cette loi permettrait de montrer
que la France pays des droit de l'homme
ne fléchit pas devant les menaces
proférées par ceux qui refusent tout
discours en dehors de la doctrine
officielle d'État cela permettrait de
réaffirmer la voix du Parlement français
qui condamne les actes racistes
xénophobes antisémistes ou
négationnistes c'est par là même le
moment d'affirmer notre lutte sans
distinction sans hiérarchisation à
l'encontre de tous les crimes contre
l'humanité et non pas les crimes de
guerre j'ai entendu madame Benbassa à
l'instant faire état de la position de
la France dans certains conflits bien
sûr il y a eu des crimes de guerre ce
n'était pas des génocide et contre tous
ceux qui permettent à des actes barbares
de survivre et d'atteindre des hommes
des femmes et des enfants qui portent en
eux une douleur déjà bien lourde c'est
également poursuivre le chemin deux fois
millénaire liant la France et l'Arménie
le président de la République l'a
exprimé récemment lors de son
déplacement à Erevan en octobre dernier
c'est dans les terribles épreuves du
siècle passé que a fini de se nouer
l'amitié indéfectible entre l'Arménie et
la France au lendemain de la première
entreprise d'extermination de l'histoire
moderne les dizaines de milliers
d'Arméniens ont cherché et trouvé refuge
en France ils y ont trouvé une seconde
patrie sans jamais oublier l'Arménie
notre pays terre d'asile pour beaucoup
d'Arméniens au début du siècle dernier a
le devoir comme nouvelle patrie de
protéger tous ses enfants y compris les
fils de ses enfants adoptés pour toutes
ces raisons mes chers collègues je
voterai contre la motion proposée par la
Commission des lois avec des membres de
notre groupe qui est partagé comme la
plupart des groupes de cette assemblée
et donc nous voterons avec certains
d'entre eux contre la motion
d'irrecevabilité je vous remercie de
votre
attention je vous remercie chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Kaltenbach pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues depuis mon élection c'est la
première fois que je monte à cette
tribune et je suis particulièrement ému
et fier de le faire pour expliquer
pourquoi le groupe socialiste apporte
son soutien à ce texte qui tend à
sanctionner la négation des génocides
reconnu par la loi donc celui des
Arméniens de
1915 je suis ému car depuis de longues
années je suis engagé au côté de mes
amis arméniens de clamar et d'ailleurs
pour que ce génocide soit reconnu et
respecté et j'espère que nous allons
clore aujourd'hui le volet législatif de
ce combat je suis fier car avec cette
loi le Parlement montrera que nous ne
réunions pas nos valeurs sous la
pression d'un État étranger aussi
puissant
soit-il ce sont la vérité la justice et
l'amitié qui doivent nous guider la
vérité car ce qui s'est passé en Turquie
ottoman en 1915 est bien un génocide
aujourd'hui tous les historiens sérieux
qui ont travaillé sur le sujet le
reconnaissent les preuves sont aussi
nombreuses
qu'acablantes la justice car la loi de
2001 n'avait pas prévu de dispositif de
sanction contre celles et ceux qui la
violeraient malheureusement le
négationnisme s'est développé et est
devenu de plus en plus virulent nos
concitoyens d'origine arménienne ont le
droit d'être protégés contre ces propos
et ses actes négationnistes qui sont
autant de coups de poignard dans leur
cœur comme l'a écrit ellisel tolérer le
négationnisme c'est tuer une seconde
fois les victimes la Choa bénéficie de
la loi guesso il est alors naturel que
la négation du génocide des Arméniens
soit aussi sanctionné pourquoi il y
aurait-il deux poids de mesurees
l'amitié enfin car nous avons des liens
anciens avec l'Arménie que ce génocide a
indéfictiblement renforcé et ce n'est
pas un hasard si des dizaines de
milliers de rescapé ont trouvé reféuge
en France ils se sont parfaitement
intégrés ont payé le prix du sang je
pense à missac manouchan et à bien
d'autres ils ont aussi par leur travail
contribué au développement économique de
notre pays et que dire des nombreux
artistes qui contribuent au rayonnement
de la France en définitive ils ont
trouvé une seconde patrie leurs enfants
leurs descendants sont français mais
tous ont conservés un morceau d'Arménie
au fond du cœur et cette plie mal
refermée du génocide sur laquelle les
négationnistes jettent du sel par
poignet certes je suis un modeste maire
de banlieu parisienne mais je peux vous
dire que l'enjeu du vivre ensemble dans
des territoires qui accueillent des
populations diverses et fondamentales et
ce vivre ensemble n'est possible que si
chacun se sent reconnu respecté et
protégé notre République doit protéger
tous ses enfants quel que soit leurs
histoire et leur parcours si ces femmes
et ces hommes ont décidé de lier leur
avenir à celui de la France la
République doit être soucieuse de leur
permettre d'honorer sereinement la
mémoire de leurs ancêtres personne sur
notre territoire ne doit pouvoir leur
nier ce
droit c'est cette volonté qui anime le
socialisme depuis plus de 10 ans le 29
janvier 2001 nous avons porté la loi de
reconnaissance du génocide arménien
cette reconnaissance officielle est
partagée par plus d'une trentaine
d'états et d'institutions régionales et
internationales
devant la recrudescence sur notre sol
d'ACT négationniste les socialistes ont
été à l'initiative de l'adoption par
l'Assemblée nationale de la proposition
de loi du 12 octobre 2006 permettant de
sanctionner la contestation de
l'existence du génocide des Arméniens ce
texte a été présenté au Sénat le 4 mai
2011 dans le cadre de la niche
parlementaire du groupe socialiste mais
a été rejeté par la commission des lois
déjà et ensuite par l'ancienne majorité
de la Haute Assemblée au motif de sa
soi-disant
irreçabilité cette démarche entreprise
il y a une décennie les socialistes
veulent la conduire à son terme Martine
auri au nom du PS l'a rappelé au
printemps dernier et notre candidat
François Hollande en a pris l'engagement
en septembre depuis mon élection j'avais
d'ailleurs redéposé une proposition de
loi avec une douzaine de
sénateurs la proposition de loi qui nous
est soumise l' à l'initiative de l'UMP
mais nous la voterons car sur ce sujet
il faut dépasser l'éclivage partisan
pour nous c'est le résultat qui compte
nous soutenons de longues dates la cause
arménienne nous sommes fidèles à nos
engagements alors c'est vrai nous avons
dû nous adapter à un calendrier serré
mais nous l'avons fait de manière
sérieuse en desffet avec mon collègue
Luc Carvounas pour le groupe socialiste
nous avons organisé des auditions afin
d'éclairer l'avis de nos collègues qu'il
me soit permis d'ailleurs de regretter
que la commission des lois n'en ait pas
tenu compte 15 personnes dont les
ambassadeurs d'Arménie et de Turquie ont
répondu à notre invitation et ont pu
témoigner devant les sénateurs des
historiens des journalistes des
écrivains des intellectuels des
responsables associatifs d'origine
turc-arménienne des juristes ont exprimé
des opinions très différentes sur la
question je les remercie de nouveau pour
leur précieux concours légiférer c'est
écouter débattre et décider à l'issue de
ces échanges je suis encore plus
convaincu de la nécessité de sanctionner
le négationnisme et en le faisant le
législateur est bien dans le rôle que
lui confère la Constitution ces
dernières semaines les détracteurs de la
loi ont utilisé de nombreux arguments
pour éclairer le débat et ne laisser
aucune amertume dans cette loi qui n'est
que du petit lait pour les défenseurs de
la vérité et de la justice qu'il me soit
permis d'y répondre tout d'abord des
voix se sont élevées pour dénoncer une
soi-disant volonté du législateur
d'écrire l'histoire je tiens à rappeler
que les parlementaires socialistes ont
toujours soutenu les lois dites
mémorielles qui leur semblaient être
conformes aux valeurs humanistes de la
République et quand la réalité des faits
n'était pas contesté par les historiens
ce fut le cas pour la reconnaissance
officielle du gén arménien comme ce fut
le cas aussi pour la reconnaissance des
traites et des esclavages comme crime
contre l'humanité les socialistes ont
cependant toujours refuser que le
Parlement vote des textes comme la loi
du 23 février 2005 en ce qu'elle portait
un jugement de valeur en reconnaissant
le rôle positif de la France outremè
l'UMP voulait imposer aux enseignants
une lecture de l'histoire sur la
colonisation qui était loin de faire
consensus bien au contraire et cela les
socialistes l'ont toujours
refusé je sais que certains de mes
collègues sont réservés car il craignne
que ce type de dispositif législatif
entrave le travail des chercheurs je
crois qu'il faut préciser tout d'abord
qu'une telle loi tendant à réprimer la
contestation de l'existence des
génocides va présenter l'immense
avantage de libérer le champ
d'investigation des historiens des
faussaires et des
manipulateurs je voudrais aussi rappeler
que la loi guesso votée en 1990 pour
protéger du négationnisme la mémoire des
victimes de la Choa n'a jamais gêné le
travail des historiens il faut surtout
souligner que la proposition de loi sur
laquelle nousous prononçons ce jour vise
à incriminer la contestation ou la
minimisation d'un génocide quand elle
est faite de manière
outrancière le fait d'ajouter par
rapport au texte de mai dernier
l'élément intentionnel fondamental en
droit pénal permet au législateur de
démontrer qu'il ne vise pas tant la
contestation du génocide en tant que tel
que l'incitation à la haine raciale dont
est
porteuse pour ce qui serait une atteinte
à la liberté d'expression personne ne
serait contesté que dans tout État
démocratique la liberté d'expression
connaît des limites ces limites ont ici
pour but de prévenir toute incitation à
la haine induite par le négationnisme
ensuite cette proposition de loi ne
transformera pas le Parlement en
tribunal en effet alors que la
précédente proposition rejetée le 4 mai
dernier était muette sur les éléments
constitutifs du génocide contesté
l'actuelle proposition incrimine la
contestation ou la minimisation d'un
crime de génocide tel que défini à
l'article 211-1 du Code pénal le fait de
renvoyer à une définition pénale du
génocide lève le grief
d'inconstitutionnalité tiré une
violation du principe de l'égalité des
délits on ne peut donc plus accuser le
Parlement de vouloir se muer en tribunal
car c'est seulement le juge qui sur le
fondement de l'article 211-1 du Code
pénal sera amené à qualifier
juridiquement les faits par ailleurs je
crois qu'il faut rappeler qu'il existe
des verdicts des cours martiales de
Constantinople en 1919 et 1920 à
l'encontre des principaux responsables
et organisateurs du génocide et c'est
précisément au cours de ces procès qu'on
été reconnu la nature des crimes contre
la conscience de l'humanité et contre
les normes
universelle la France ne sera pas en
outre comme j'ai pu le lire dans le
rapport de la commission des lois le
premier pays à mettre en place un tel
dispositif
législatif la Slovaquie dispose une
telle législation et la Suisse a déjà
condamné un négationniste en considérant
que la négation du génocide arménien est
un motif qui appartient à la catégorie
des mobiles racistes et nationalistes
qui ne relève pas du débat
historique un autre argument employé
contre ce texte serait que le vote de
cette loi pourrait conduire à
l'inconstitutionnalité de la loi de 2001
ce fut notamment un des motifs avancés
par Robert baninter lorsqu'il vota
l'exception d'irreceabilité le 4 mai
dernier contre la précédente proposition
de loi et je veux ici le remercier pour
la précieuse contribution qu'il continue
voilà l'image Philippe kalttenbach
sénateur socialiste qui vous l'avez
entendu défend euh pour son groupe
socialiste ici au Sénat et bien ce
fameux texte très controversé sur la
contestation de l'existence des
génocides qui je vous le rappelle cet
après-midi dans la haute assemblée et
bien se déroule dans d'un atmosère très
particulière il a relativement peu de
monde dans dans l'hémicycle euh à côté
de moi borveau coencat merci d'être avec
nous madame vous présidez ici le groupe
communiste au Sénat le groupe CRC est-ce
que vous avez l'impression en entendant
les uns et les autres les orateurs de
cet après-midi qu'aujourd'hui le Sénat
le Parlement fait en en quelque sorte
l'histoire non le Parlement ne fait pas
l'histoire ce sont les historiens qui
font l'histoire mais les les pays et les
politiques donc ont tout à fait le droit
et là je conteste ce qui est dit sur sur
la la diicot is entre les historiens
d'un côté et les les les politiques de
l'autre puisque les historiens
contribuent à écrire l'histoire par
leurs travaux de recherche mais ce sont
les politiques qui choisissent à un
moment donné de prendre position car on
va pas demander aux historiens de
prendre position à la place des
politiques et donc que la France
reconnaisse un génocide ça c'est tout à
fait dans dans son droit ce qu'elle a
fait d'ailleurs par une une loi en 2001
je veux d'ailleurs préciser que la
premier parlementaire qui a déposé une
proposition de loi pour reconnaissance
du génocide arménien c'est un député
communiste GUID du colonet qui est mort
depuis mais voyez c'était bien avant que
la loi de 2001 ne soit votée donc bien
entendu quand Jacques Chirac a reconnu
la participation de de de la France euh
au à l'occupation enfin plutôt au
l'ffaire du veldive entre autres voilà
le veldive et aux exactions contre les
Juifs en France il a reconnu au nom de
la France cette partie de l'histoire
donc elle était établie cette histoire
mais le elle était établie mais la
France n'avait pas reconnu qu'elle avait
participé hein c'était bon c'était
l'occupation c'était les nazis bon donc
vous voyez bien que on peut pas faire à
géométrie variable selon que on pense
que il voilà là euh on est dans une
quelque chose de plus compliqué est-ce
que vous pensez néanmoins que ce cette
proposition de loi qui est discutée
actuellement déménation déménation de
l'Assemblée madame boignier UMP est une
proposition un texte qui aujourd'hui est
légitime et qui s'inscrit j'allais dire
dans la foulée de la loi précédente qui
elle reconnaît le génocide arménien il
est tout à fait légitime en droit
contrairement à ce que disent
certains ce qui peut être contestable
c'est le fait que ce soit par une loi
c'est-à-dire que mais le la
reconnaissance du génocide en 2001 parce
que voilà ça aurait pu être sous une
autre forme mais à l'époque le Parlement
ne disposait pas d'autre forme
d'expression que la loi donc la loi a
servi de véhicule au fait que le notre
pays reconnaisse l'existence du génocide
arménien largement prouvé justement par
les historiens une majorité d'historiens
mais donc si vous voulez à partir du
moment où la France a reconnu
ce génocide et bien c'est vrai que les
les descendants des des martyres
Arméniens de 1915 ils veulent que cette
loi a des effets et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils se sont appuyés sur ce qui
existe concernant la Choa avec la loi
guesso qui permet de en fait de punir en
quelque sorte ceux qui mettrait en cause
cette reconnaissance comme on dit
pénaliser la mise en causeénaliser la
mise enause cause alors où il y a un
problème qui évidemment peut se poser
que je n'ai pas manqué de me poser
moi-même c'est c'est vrai que la Choa
était reconnu sur la base de d'un
tribunal international ad dooc à
l'époque nurember et c'est vrai que
depuis euh cette époque là on a avec la
Cour pénale internationale on a des des
instruments internationaux qui
permettent d'établir de façon euh
rigoureuse la définition de ce que peut
être un génocide voilà mais donc ceci
dit cette loi existe et donc eux attend
à juste titre que cette loi a des effets
c'est-à-dire qu'alors que la France a
reconnu le génocide arménien il puisse
pas y avoir des des gens en France qui
sans cesse mettent en cause et euh on a
fait état d'un certain nombre de choses
des profanations de sépulture bon des
choses comme ça qui sont effectivement
inadmissibles voilà mais le le problème
en réalité il est
plus disons d'opportunité aujourd'hui
parce que franchement là on est on est
dans une incompréhension totale que le
Président de la République qui est
l'inspirateur quand même de la loi
opportune de Madame
Boyer qui au moment enfin en campagne
électorale demande de discuter en
urgence en quelque sorte de ce cette
proposition voilà c'est ça qui vous mal
à l'aise j'allais dire le côté
certains le dénonc ici bien sûr parce
que il faut n'oublions pas qu'il y a à
peine 9 mois l'UMP global dans sa grande
majorité je crois mais a voté contre la
une proposition identique déposé à
l'époque par
le des sénateurs socialistes donc si
vous voulez quand même arriver à un
tel telle chicane en quelque sorte pour
des raisons directement électoraliste
quand on sait en plus ce qui n'est
absolument pas notre mon cas ni celui de
mon groupe que quand même le président
de la République s'est illustré par
souvent par ses réticences au nom de la
France mais enfin qui sont des
réticences quand même très personnelles
à ce que les les les Turcs puissent
accéder à l'Union européenne donc voyez
c'est c'est quand même quelque chose qui
est un petit peu troublé la le le le
problème des des Arméniens est un petit
peu perturbé
par cetteosition cette loi d'opportunité
donc on vous sent un petit peu tiraillé
alors vous êtes la présidente du groupe
CRC communiste au Sénat est-ce que vous
allez voter cette loi vous êtes divisé
aussi comme d'autres groupes ici cette
le fait que les les pistes sont brouillé
en quelque sorte par cette proposition
très électoraliste c'est vrai que dans
mon groupe un certain
nombre ne vont pas prendre part au vote
parce que il trouve que c'est c'est très
criticable de de mettre cette
proposition de loi en débat
9 mois après l'autre avec voilà des
positionnements tout à fait différents
sans qu'il bon et donc ils ont décidé de
pas prendre part au vote j'ai quatre
sénateurs de mon groupe qui vont voter
contre parce que finalement après
réflexion bien que souvent ils aient
approuvé la proposition que nous avons
nous-même déposé euh en 2005 qui était
exactement la même et qui au fond à
l'époque ils étaient d'accord à l'heure
actuelle bon voilà il considèent qu'il y
en a voilà c'est la manière qui gênne
vos collègues je l'IM beaucoup beaucoup
personne ne remet en cause dans mon
groupe la reconnaissance par la France
du génocide arménien donc on va arriver
à ce qu'une majorité du groupe vote
pour quatre contre et quelques-uns qui
ne prennent pas part au vote voilà le
résultat de cet ambrog gliot dans lequel
le président de la République et le
gouvernement nous ont placé nous nous
sommes fidèles à au fond à cet
engagement je vous dis qu'il a
maintenant 20 ans
de que la France la volonté que nous
avons exprimé que la France reconnaisse
le génocide arménien donc voilà bien
merci beaucoup madame Nicole borveau
Cohen seat vous allez certainement
rejoindre l'hémicycle où se poursuit la
discussion autour de ce texte de
négation des des génocides c'est
Monsieur un sénateur socialiste que je
crois s'exprime aujourd'hui et qui
s'exprime en faveur de ce texte je
reçois tout de suite Jean-Michel baayet
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous monsieur
baayet euh vous faites partie du groupe
RDSE le ce fameux groupe des des
radicaux ici au Sénat ils sont très
majoritaires oui voilà voilà un groupe
qui a décidé on a entendu Jacques mzard
tout à l'heure de voter contre cette
proposition de loi alors vous allez
voter contre pourquoi aujourd'hui pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est
qu'il n'appartient pas au au
parlementaires d'écrire l'histoire c'est
l'affaire des historiens or nous sommes
en plein dans un débat
historique certes loin de nous loin de
l'idée des Radicaux de Gauche loin de
moi l'idée de contester l'horreur du
massacre des
Arméniens lors de l'Empire ottoman en
1915 et d'ailleurs il faudra
effectivement que la Turquie accepte de
se pincher sur son histoire l'histoire
de tous les pays et est faite de M de
grandeur et de moment autres d'ombre et
de lumière en disant cela est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment de peut-être
décevoir la communauté arménienne
aujourd'hui en France avant de venir là
je veux finir sur les lois mémorielles
donc il s'agit bel et bien justement
j'allais y venir d'une loi mémorielle ce
n'est pas au Parlement de dire
l'histoire c'est aux historiens et c'est
incestablement une faute de la part du
président de la République même s'il
s'agit d'un texte régim parlementaire
que d'avoir sollicité l'avis du
Parlement sur ce texte décevoir me
dites-vous la communauté arménienne non
elle est nombreuse en France hein 600000
personnes oui bien sûr d'ailleurs comme
par hasard ce texte qui en période
présidentielle mais il ne s'agit pas de
de vouloir faire plaisir à qui so que ce
soit ou de craîre de dceroir qui que ce
soit il s'agit de faire notre travail de
législateur et il s'agit d'essayer de
dire les choses telles qu'elles se sont
passées oui il y a eu massacre non ce
n'est pas la responsabilité du Parlement
que d'adopter des lois comme celle-là
surtout pour pénaliser un génocide avec
toutes les difficultés d'application
deuxème raison pour laquelle je va voter
contre tout cela n'est pas
constitutionnel je vais pas rentrer dans
une démonstration de droit mais enfin
essayons de légiférer convenablement et
de pas nous exposer à ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel nous renvoie dans nos
cordes troisièmement enfin autre raison
de mon opposition la Turquie est un très
grand pays et nous ne cessons depuis des
années de stigmatiser la Turquie ils ont
frappé à la porte de l'Union européenne
en 1987 il y a 25 ans quand je vois je
m'en réjouis d'ailleurs je suis un
Européen convaincu fédéraliste vous le
savez que la Croatie a voté hier son
adhésion à l'Union européenne elle
n'existait pas alors que la Turquie
demandait déjà son entrée nous ne
cessons de leur faire des complications
de les rejeter disons-le parce que
certains voudraient faire croire qu'il
s'agirait d'un pays musulman dangereux
c'est tout le contraire regardez
l'histoire de la Turquie c'est un grand
État laïque c'est un état tout vers
l'Occident c'est un état auquel nous
devons tendre la main nous faisons se
faisant aujourd'hui tout le contraire
comment vous appréciez dès lors jeallis
dire ce que dit aujourd'hui Ankara
Ankara qui menace de de durcir les
représailles de durcir d'éventuelles
sanctions vis-à-vis de la France je le
regretterai si cela avait des
conséquences culturelles ou économiques
mais à partir du moment où on fait des
erreurs diplomatiques de cette taille
fatalement on pe les poauasser donc
gangara réagit peut-être même sur réagit
il faut qu'ils gardent leur sang-froid
et leur sérénité parce que ils se
sentent blessés dans leur amour propre
que de voir et dans leur nationalisme au
bon sens du terme que de voir que le
Parlement français légifère sur
l'histoire turque qu'est-ce que nous
penserions si dans quelques jours le
Parlement espagnol ou suédois légiférait
quant à la colonisation française ou
sous le massacre des qatars ou des
vandéens que penseraient les Américains
si on tentait des lois comme ça sur le
génocide des Indiens voilà il appartient
à chaque pays d'écrire sa propre
histoire aux historiens mais pas aux
parlementaires et encore moins d'un pays
étranger autrement dit Jean-Michel
baayet vous êtes vous seriez d'accord
avec le ministre des Affaires étrangères
français Alain Jupé qui dit aujourd'hui
que ce texte est un texte inopportun
totalement vous savez et vous l'avez
noté dans cette affaire nous sommes
complètement trans majorité opposition
je vois des socialistes monter la
tribune pour défendre le texte je vois
des gens de droite le combattre en
l'occurrence Jupé a totalement raison
merci beaucoup Jean-Michel Baillet
d'avoir été avec nous cet après-midi ici
au Sénat où se poursuit cette discussion
autour de la négation des génocides je
ne sais pas qui était la tribune mais ça
doit être Luc
Carvounas le sénateur socialiste du
valde mararne qui je vous le rappelle il
était à notre micro tout à l'heure va
voter tout à l'heure en faveur de ce
texte on se retrouve bien sûr dans
quelques minutes à tout à l'heure en une
année plus de 22 % supplémentaires que
l'année précédente alors
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je regrette
que certains de mes collègues quelqu
soit leur appartenance politique
subissent des pressions d'où qu'ell
viennent à l'Assemblée nationale ou au
Sénat ou répondent à des recommandations
politiques dont je ne sais d'où elles
viennent de quel lieu en dehors de cette
enceinte je me pose ici lubrment deux
questions deux questions quelle valeur
donne-t-on à notre conscience quelle
conscience donnet-on à notre mémoire
partageons l'avis de Serge clarsfeld qui
estime que reculer sur ce texte serait
une défaite morale pour la France en
cohérence avec la position commune de
notre président du Sénat Jean-Pierre
belle celle du groupe socialiste rappelé
par son président François repsamen en
cohésence avec l'engagement de François
Hollande je soutiens au nom du groupe
socialiste l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi et mes chers
collègues pour conclure je citerai
simplement ces paroles du président
François mitteran à propos du génocide
arménien François miteran président de
la République déclarait à propos de ce
génocide ce génocide doit s'inscrire
dans la mémoire des hommes et ce
sacrifice doit servir d'enseignement aux
jeunes en même temps que de volonté de
survivre pour qu'on sache à travers le
temps que ce peuple que ce peuple
n'appartient pas au passé qu'il est bien
présent et qu'il a un avenir je vous
remercie bien merci chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Bruno Gilles pour
le groupe
P bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur et
président de la commission des lois mes
chers
collègues avec la loi du 29 janvier 2001
relative à la reconnaissance du génocide
arménien de
1915 le Parlement français a donné une
place à celui-ci dans la mémoire
collective de l'humanité mais cette loi
en l'État demeure incomplète puisqu'elle
ne s'est pas doté du moyen de combattre
les idéologies hostiles à une telle
reconnaissance en incriminant pénalement
sa négation à l'instar de ce qui a été
pré prvu dans la loi dite guesso du 13
juillet 90 concernant le génocide
organisé par les nazis deux propositions
de loi visant à suppl ceementque ont été
inscrites à l'ordre du jour du Parlement
ces dernières années mais elles n'ont
pas abouti l'une votée le 12 octobre
2006 à l'Assemblée nationale où je
siégeis d'ailleurs ne fut jamais
inscrite à l'ordre du jour du Sénat et
l'autre d'initiative sénatoriale a été
rejeté par notre haute assemblée le 4
mai
après l'adoption d'une motion
d'exception d'irrecevabilité j'ai à
titre personnel soutenu ces deux
propositions de loi notre droit pénal
s'inspire très largement de la
Convention pour la prévention et la
répression du crime de génocide adopté
par l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU le 9
décembre
1948 en effet l'article 2111 du code
pénal définit le génocide comme le fait
en exécution d'un plan concerté tendant
à la destruction totale ou partielle
d'un groupe national ethnique racial ou
religieux ou d'un groupe déterminé à
partir de tout autre critère arbitraire
de commettre ou de faire commettre à
l'encontre de membbres de ce groupe l'un
des actes suivants atteinte volontaire à
la vie atteinte grave à l'intégrité
physique ou psychique soumission à des
conditions d'existence de nature
entraîné la destruction totale ou
partielle du groupe mesures visant à
entraver les naissances transferts
forcés d'enfants de tes actes mes chers
collègues caractérisent les massacres et
la déportation organisées par le
gouvernement des Jeunes Turcs en 1915
qui ont abouti à la disparition des
2/ers de la population arménienne de
l'Empire ottoman ces faits sont assez
communément admis ils étaient d'ailleurs
reconnu officiellement par une douzaine
d'états par le Parlement européen par
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe avant que la loi de janvier
2001 n'ajoute à la liste la
reconnaissance officielle de la France
une nouvelle proposition de loi visant à
réprimer la contestation de l'ex de
l'existence des génocides reconnus par
la loi vient d'être voté le 22 décembre
2011 à l'Assemblée nationale à
l'initiative de notre collègue Valérie
Boyer nous sommes aujourd'hui appelé à
l'adopter au Sénat cette proposition de
loi concerne actuellement le seul
génocide arménien il ne s'agit pas pour
nous aujourd'hui de dire l'histoire la
France depuis janvier 2001 reconnaît
officiellement l'existence du génocide
arménien elle ne le reconnaîtrait pas
moins demain si la proposition de loi
que nous examinons n'était pas votée ce
qui est en jeu aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues ce n'est pas la liberté des
historiens mais toute idéologie de haine
d'incitation à la violence fondée sur la
manipulation et la contestation des
faits généralement établis et reconnu
officiellement ement par la loi ainsi le
fait de contester ou de minimiser de
façon Rancière publiquement l'existence
d'un ou plusieurs crimes de génocide
défini à l'article 2111 du code pénal et
reconnu comme tel par la loi française
sera constitutif au titre de l'article
1er de cette proposition de loi d'une
infraction modifiant la loi du 29
juillet 1881 sur la liberté de la presse
toute personne qui enfraindera ce
principe par des discours des écrits des
dessins des affiches ou par voie
électronique sera puni d'une peine d'un
an d'emprisonnement et de 45000 €
d'amende le tribunal pourra en outre
ordonner l'affichage ou la diffusion de
la décision de condamnation l'article 2
lui donne la possibilité à toute
association régulièrement déclaré depuis
au moins 5 ans à la date des faits qui
se propose par ses statuts de défendre
les intérêts moraux et l'honneur des
victimes de génocide de crimes de guerre
de crimees contre l'humanité ou de crime
ou de délit de collaboration avec
l'ennemi d'exercer des droits reconnus à
la partie civile en ce qui concerne la
nouvelle infraction créé par l'article
1er nous avons légiféré sur deux
génocides la Choa et le génocide
arménien le premier a été à sorti d'un
dispositif pénal l'autre n cette
hiérarchie de génocide est insupportable
en raison de la discrimination qu'elle
opère entre les victimes et à l'égard de
notre conscience pouvons-nous admettre
que son aurit une graduation dans la
reconnaissance de semblables tragédies
dans notre compassion selon tel ou tel
génocide et dans la condamnation de leur
négation comme l'a d'ailleurs très
justement signalé notre collègue
François zooketo en commission des lois
un événement est un génocide où il ne
l'est pas il ne serait pas
compréhensible qu'ayant affirmé
certaines valeurs à l'occasion de la loi
de 2001 nous renonçons aujourd'hui à
sanctionner ce qui ne les respectent pas
même même s'il existe un risque
d'inconstitutionnalité je n'estime pas
moins pour les raisons évoquées que nous
devons laisser le processus législatif
aller à son terme prenez une telle
position contrairement à ce que
diffusent certains lobby et au pressions
que nous subissons depuis plusieurs
semaines ce n'est pas sérigé contre un
état ou contre un peuple et d'ailleurs
le peuple turc d'aujourd'hui n'est pas
responsable de la tragédie à laquelle
ils n'ont pas participer l'histoire
admet le génocide arménien nous rappelle
également les liens profonds entre nos
deux pays au nom des Arméniens réfugiés
des massacres de 1915 que nous avons
accueilli sur notre sol et dont les
descendants font partie intégrante de
notre nation nous devons mettre un terme
au négationnisme dont ils sont la cible
maises chers collègues nous devons
toujours avoir à l'esprit que dans
chacun de nos choix dans chacun de nos
actes dans chacun de nos votes les
valeurs qui ont motivé notre engagement
dans la vie publique je ne renirai pas
moi les valeurs de justice qui m'animent
il est juste mes chers collègues que le
droit protège la mémoire des victimes de
génocide il est juste qu'il préserve
l'honneur de leurs descendants il est
par conséquent juste et de notre devoir
d'inscrire dans la loi la sanction
pénale prévue par cette proposition de
loi c'est pourquoi je rejetterai la
motion d' recevabilité et la question
préalable qui vont nous être
soumises je vous remercie chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Jean-Vincent Placé pour le
groupe écologique
monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
mais mes chers collègues beaucoup de de
choses ont été dites c'est tout à la
fois le le le l'intérêt d'écouter c'est
qu'on apprend beaucoup de choses et
qu'on a l'occasion d'entendre les
arguments c'est l'inconvénient d'arriver
en fin de débat car j'appartiens plutôt
à une tradition qui veut ne pas répéter
les arguments déjà entendus aussi je
vais essayer de d'être toucher de
d'apporter des éléments complémentaires
et
euh les présidents sueur et mesar dans
une intervention particulièrement
exhaustive et je tiens à saluer la
République universaliste qui était dans
les propos du président mard qui
complétait d'ailleurs très heureusement
les propos de Madame Benbassa ce qui
fait que on voit que notre autre
assemblée peut réunir sur un même débat
monsieur le Président mard et Madame ben
Bassa et je m'en réjouis
particulièrement
euh chers collègues il n'y a rien de
plus difficile pour un responsable
politique que de devoir porter une
appréciation euh d'exprimer un un
sentiment sur la souffrance de tout un
peuple et moi je souhaiterais que il n
ait pas dans cette haute assemblée dans
notre Haute Assemblée certains qui
voudraient être plus affectés plus
sensible plus touché par la souffrance
du peuple arménien et des compatriotes
d'origine arménienne par rapport à ce
génocide évidemment de
1915 et
euh j'ai eu l'occasion de lire beaucoup
pendant ces dernières semaines
effectivement la réalité de cette
histoire de 1915 1916 et même au-delà
d'ailleurs et évidemment cette
souffrance là s'est perpétué à
l'ensemble des générations d'enfants et
de parents et de la communauté
arménienne et c'est vrai que ainsi
intervenir en disant bien sûr il y a eu
ce génocide arménien et dire tout à la
fois que euh on va voter NON à cette
proposition de loi c'est difficile parce
que il y a le rôle du sénateur qui est
au-delà de la souffrance y compris
ressenti dans leur chair par cette
communauté il y a la responsabilité du
sénateur de la Haute Assemblée de dire
et cel a été excellemment fait sur des
considérations de philosophie du droit
alors évidemment euh et par ailleurs je
le dis et ça a été dit par le président
mard je comprends aussi que nombre de
députés et nombre de sénateurs ici sont
particulièrement sensibles aux arguments
et ce n'est pas du tout d'ailleurs de
l'ironie de ma part à des communautés
présentes sur leur territoire d'élection
auquels ils sont attentifs et il se
ressentent davantage encore cette
souffrance mais notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues elle
n'est pas là notre rôle dans la haute
assemblée et de dire ce qui doit être
puni ou non le rôle du juge et de dire
si une personne a enfint cette loi ou
non et le rôle de l'historien pas
d'ailleurs les historiens professionnels
mais quelque part l'ensemble des
citoyens et de dire l'histoire de penser
l'histoire de considérer l'histoire
d'avoir un avis sur cette
histoire alors pour nous les sénatrices
et sénateurs il y a un texte fondateur
qui est dans cet hémicycle notre loi
suprême ce texte c'est la constitution
de la 5e République que je n'approuve
pas dans S telle réalité notre devoir
oui est de la respecter
de la protéger il y a aujourd'hui C
trutre texte est trutre texte que ce
qu'on appelle une loi mémorielle qui
soulève un véritable enjeu mais qui
apporte une mauvaise solution cela a été
dit par déjà le président mesar le site
de nouveau citant le président
aquyer le
rôle le rôle du Parlement n'est pas
d'adopter des lois qualifiant
ou portant une appréciation sur des
faits historiques
à forciori à forceori lorsque celle-ci
s'accompagne de sanctions
pénales mais le Parlement est dans son
rôle quand il est dicte des normes ou
des limitations destinées à défendre des
principes affirmé par le préambule de la
Constitution notamment pour lutter
contre le racisme et la xénophobie cette
recommandation du rapportinformation de
2008 qui a été je le rappelle voté à
l'unanimité sous l'influence du
président de l'Assemblée nationale
et bien évidemment est pertinente et
nous y souscrivons totalement nous
voterons donc unanimement contre cette
loi mais nous disons le débat ne fait
que commencer non sur les lois
mémorielles nous ne changerons pas
d'avis sur le sujet mais sur la justepos
de la séparation des pouvoirs parce que
là nous devons porter le débat là où
doit avoir lieu et particulièrement en
Turquie je pense que la position de la
France qui avait été dite par ac que
sans reconnaissance de ce génocide
arménien par la Turquie il ne saurait y
avoir parce que nous portons d'autres
sujets sur les droits de l'homme sur les
libertés dans l'ensemble du monde et
c'est la parole de la France qui est
importante et bien sans cette
reconnaissance oui il ne serait être
possible que la Turquie intègre l'Union
européenne voilà la façon de soutenir
politiquement ses positions plutôt que
de l'inscrire dans la loi française
résolution commémoration droit français
droit international nous avons de
nombreuses ressources pour faire bouger
les lignes tout en respectant le droit
et notre Constitution alors quelqu
considération également sur le rôle du
Sénat que j'ai déjà indiqué mais je
voudrais tout de même à un moment et je
le dis aussi par rapport à à nos
concitoyens qui nous regardent et qui
s'interrogent légitimement sur ce que
sur ce à quoi sert notre Haute Assemblée
si notre haute assemblée le 4 mai et je
me tourne effectivement vers le
président Larcher vers le président
Gaudin vote une exception
d'irreevabilité à l'initiative de son
président la commission des lois avec
des arguments très forts repris très
justement par le
présidentur quel est le sens de
l'utilité du Sénat si sur un sujet comme
cela où évidemment il n a pas eu de
nouveau depuis le 4 mai 2011 et
uniquement parce que Madame Boyet
monsieur le Président Godin que vous
connaissez bien s'intéresse à ce sujet à
la demande du Président de la République
et bien d'un coup d'un coup les mêmes
qui le 4 mai 2011 votent contre cette
exception pour cette exception et bien
change totalement d'avis quel est
l'honur et la dignité des parlementaires
ainsi d'avoir cette volteface inv
vraisemblable inv vrai semblable à quoi
cela sert le Sénat à quoi cela sert
d'avoir une telle versatilité sur un
sujet aussi
grave concluez chers collègues enfin moi
j'aurais voté la même
chose ch collègu enfin et je conclus
j'ai été interrompu monsieur le
Président enfin et je conclus quand je
regarde quand je regarde ce que doit
être le sens de la loi ce que doit être
la position de la France sur des sujets
comme celui-là on voit dehors des
milliers de compatriotes d'origine
arménienne et des milliers de
compatriotes d'origine turqu qui sont là
en train de
manifester est-ce que nous attendons
cela de la France y compris sur la scène
internationale des lois qui divisent qui
séparent qui jettent du sel sur les
blessures non ce que nous voulons c'est
le travail de mémoire la réconciliation
le rassemblement et il ne faut pas
fragiliser la société les sociétés
surtout en empruntant le chemin
dangereux de la vérité d'État proclamé
et je conclus c'est vrai cette question
est évidemment totalement tabou en
Turquie et nous devons lutter pour que
pied à pied on puisse dans la société
turque faire ce travail mais avec cette
proposition de loi votée c'est
exactement le contraire qui va se passer
et cela renforce la vérité d'État et je
conclus en vous disant donc à la
question le législateur est-il dans son
rôle nous disons non à la question
rend-ton vraiment le service à la cause
arménienne avec ce texte nous disons
encore non nous voterons donc contre ce
texte la parole est à Madame Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe
UCR monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues même motif
même punition que notre ami Vincent Jean
Vincent placet parler en 10e position ce
n'est pas très facile quoi qu'il en soit
le président de la République a fait en
quelque sorte le derevan alors le
Parlement doit de nouveau légiférer sur
la pénalisation du négationnisme du
génocide arménien et à quelques mois des
élections présidentielles la nouvelle
majorité du Sénat ne veut pas laisser
passer cette occasion de s'exprimer nos
compatriotes Arméniens qui ont eu une
partie de leur famille massacrée en 1915
sur le front russo-ottoman avant
l'effondrement des deux empires ont
droit à notre compassion le texte
reconnaissant le génocide des Arméniens
voté en 2001 marquait solennellement
cette position le devoir de mémoire fait
partie de l'honneur d'une nation à ce
titre deux catégorie d'ayant droit sont
absolument prioritaires ceux qui sont
morts pour notre survie et nos libertés
et ceux qui ont été tués parce qu'ils
luttaient contre nous pour leur survie
et leur liberté massacre commis s sous
couvert de nos politiques coloniales
esclavagiste ou collaborationnistes ces
deux catégories de victimes nous
interpellent au-d de la mort et du temps
qui passe hors ces deux cercles qui
étraignent notre mémoire il y a tous les
massacres et génocid auquels nous
n'étions pas partie prenante ils sont
nombreux la requête des Ukrainiens sans
cesse rejeté de reconnaissance de
lolomodor 5 millions de mort le G du
Rwanda du Cambodge et d'autres victimes
de la barbarie viendront demain devant
notre Parlement et nos tribunaux
chercher ce que l'histoire ne leur a pas
ou pas encore donné alors pourquoi ne
pas laisser l'histoire s'écrire par les
historiens une commission internationale
monsieur le Président vous en avez parlé
cette proposition a été faite en 2005
par le gouvernement turc une commission
qui aurait accès à tous les documents y
compris les archives arméniennes le
gouvernement turc a dit qu'il
accepterait par avance les conclusions
queles qu'ell puissent être le
gouvernement arménien de l'époque avait
refusé et puis il existe depuis 2004 la
plateforme de Vienne qui a publié en
2009 un épé requ il de documents
Ottomans français britanniques
américains allemands austro-hongrois pas
un seul document arménien en effet les
Archives nationales arménienne ne sont
pas accessibles aux questions sensibles
ni celles de la Fédération arménienne de
Boston ni cell du patriarcat arménien de
Jérusalem dans ce contexte je tiens à
saluer la position de notre commission
des lois et de son président et avant
lui celle du président yest dans
exactement dans la même lignée cet
hémicycle retentit encore des paroles de
Robert Badinter le 4 mai dernier la
notion de génocide me fait horreur je
dirais qu'elle nous fait horreur à tous
et comment serait-il autrement mais
encore une fois la réconciliation la
reconnaissance du génocide par la
Turquie et les indemnités qui en
découleront viendront avec le temps et
la sagesse des hommes pas par les
contraintes extérieures ma position
n'est pas dictée je le dis aux nombreux
amis arméniens qui m'ont gravement
calumnié paru une quelconque amitié
turque ni par tel et tel conflit encore
moins par une absence de sympathie
envers la communauté arménienne ma
position n'est pas non plus dictée par
la crainte de représaille économique
cela voudrait dire qu'un pays modeste
sur le plan économique n'a pas le droit
à la justice internationale et à la
reconnaissance qui n'est pas du tout ma
position j'ai une conviction je pense
que les victimes de ce génocide mérite
mieux qu'un texte voté en toute hâte par
moins de 10 % de l'Assemblée nationale
la veille de Noël je pense que les
victimes et leurs familles méritent
mieux que d'être un enjeu électoraliste
je pense que les victimes du génocide
Arméniens ont droit à la reconnaissance
de l'Histoire avec un grand hache cell
qu'écriront ensemble turc et Arméniens
le jour venu pas une reconnaissance
tronquée dictée par un pays tiers en
adoptant ce texte aujourd'hui le
Parlement français va compromettre la
position diplomatique de la France le
président a promis le Parlement va tenir
alors partie prix et pris pour l'Arménie
contre la Turquie pour l'Arménie
d'aujourd'hui contre la Turquie d'hier
mais c'est la Turquie d'aujourd'hui qui
est visée et heurté par nos débats pour
l'aménie allié inconditionnel des Russes
et des Iraniens dans le cocas qui me
dérange pas tellement parce que chacun
sait que je milite pour le débat avec
l'Iran contre la Turquie membre éminent
de l'OTAN Joker diplomatique au
ProcheOrient et dans le golfe Persique
pour l'Arménie qui occupe des
territoires azerbaïdjanais a contraint 1
million d'Azerbaïdjanais à l'exil qui
s'est rendu coupable de Massa comme à
kodjali ville du haut karabak contre
l'Azerbaïdjan allié résolu de l'Europe
perdant ainsi toute crédibilité au sein
du groupe de mins qui doit régler les
problèmes de la guerre la guerre
d'aujourd'hui entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan le président n'a pas
choisi de dormir a choisi de dormir à
Erevan de passer quelques heures à Bakou
de sans s'incliné sur la tombe de
l'allée des martyres à Bakou plus qu'un
symbole un aveu un affront alors se pose
la question le président aurait-il fait
de même et le même serment d' Réan si la
Turquie n'avait pas été un pays musulman
je ne veux pas répondre à cette question
mais elle me taraude et je vous la
soumets d'ailleurs je note que le site
nouvelle d'Arménie parle d'une
manifestation étrangère sur le
territoire national quand nos
compatriotes français d'origine turque
manifestent à Paris je présume à les
lire qu'il seraiit moins français que
les Français d'origine arménienne émigré
de la 3è génération moi-même je
m'interroge sur ce genre de propagande
je compte sans beaucoup d'espoir sur la
sagesse du Sénat pour mettre un terme à
ce naufrage législatif et à tous mes
collègues tentés de ne pas prendre part
au vote je demande je leur demande de
voter l'exception d'irrecevabilité et
puisque nous sommes entre nous monsieur
le ministre je vais vous faire une
suggestion puisque vous voulez honorer
la communauté arménienne et puisque vous
voulez célébrer l'amitié avec l' ménie
et l'honneur du peuple arménien je vous
propose de transférer les cendres de
misac manouquan au Panthéon je vous
propose de l'élever à titre Postume
Grand Croix de la Légion d'Honneur car
le chef de l'armé du crime comme on
disait cette affiche rouge c'est
l'honneur de l'Arménie c'est l'honneur
de la France et c'est notre histoire je
vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
et à Monsieur Bernard Piras du groupe
socialiste monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
lorsque le le peuple français par
l'adoption de la loi du 29 janvier 2001
a reconnu l'existence de génocide
arménien de 1915 il a redonné une place
dans la mémoire collective au premier
génocide du 20e siècle en votant ce
texte nous avions déjà conscience que ce
premier pas en appelait un second à
savoir sanctionner la négation de ce
génocide sur notre territoire la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui n'est donc qu'une suite
logique et incontournable ce texte donne
un sens et une portée à la loi de 2001
la position que je défends partagé par
bon nombre de mes collègues qui
s'associent pleinement à mes propos
notamment Gérard Colom Didier Guillaume
jean Besson et Jean-Noël
Guerini pour nous cette position n'est
pas dogmatique ni électoraliste comme
tente de le faire croire ceux qui déni
comme tout bon démocrate j'ai pris
connaissance avec attention
des arguments avancés pour refuser la
proposition de loi qui nous est soumise
y compris celle du
rapporteur en toute
objectivité aucun né n'a emporté mon
adhésion et encore moins ma
conviction ce texte serait communautaire
électoraliste je le redis pas pour moi
en réalité il a une portée générale en
s'appliquant à tous les génocides
reconnus par la loi française cette
préoccupation dépasse tous les clivages
politiqu les divisions que nous
constatons aujourd'hui au sein de la
Haute Assemblée en est une démonstration
flagrante l'absence de fondement de
l'argument électoraliste aurait été
certes encore plus évidente si la
majorité sénatoriale n'avait pas
repoussé le 4 mai 2011 la proposition de
loi déposé à cette fin réduire notre
débat comme tente de le faire certains
contradicteur à une lutte d'influence de
deux importantes communautés présentes
sur nos territoires est une grave erreur
et constitue une attitude dangereuse
ce texte serait une loi mémorielle faux
faux monsieur placé il s'agit de la
simple transcription d'une disposition
cadre de l'Union européenne qui vise à
sanctionner les fait de négation d'un
génocide voilà Bernard pirass qui
s'exprime en ce moment même à la tribune
de la Haute Assemblée ici au Sénat sur
ce fameux texte que vous pouvez suivre
en direct depuis le début de
l'après-midi sur République Sénat qui
concerne la contestation de l'existence
des génocides merci carucci d'être avec
nous cet après-midi comment quel regard
portez-vous sur ce cette discussion de
cet après-midi une discussion un peu
curieuse peu de sénateurs en particulier
sur les bancs de la euh de la droite ici
au Sénat oui mais bon au-delà du fait
qu'on est à lundi je v pas rentrer dans
ce genre de détail mais euh beaucoup de
gens sont un peu gênés par le texte il
faut bien le dire dans tous les groupes
donc il y a des partisans comme des
adversaires qui ne sont pas venus pour
des raisons multiples mais l'essentiel
c'est que le débat est lieu et ce débat
doit se conclure après les motions par
un vote alors on verra bien moi j'ai
pris position bien sûr pour ce texte
pour des raisons simple c'est que les
parlementaires français ont reconnu en
tout et pour tout deux génocides la Choa
en 1990 le génocide arménien en 2001
pour La Choa on a prévu des sanctions
pénales pour ceux qui contesteraient de
manière outrancière l'existence de la
Choa on l'a pas prévu pour le génocide
arménien donc il y a une logique à ce
texte selon vous moi je considère qu'il
y a une logique parce que à moins de
dire que fa une hiérarchie des génocides
que il y a un génocide qui est plus
grave que l'autre auquel cas on rentre
dans un débat qui quand même est assez
particulier moi je considère que que ce
soit les Juifs qui doivent être
naturellement protégés par rapport à
ceux qui dis s'est rien passé pendant la
deuxème guerre que ce soit les Français
d'origine arméniennes qui n'ont pas à
accepté qu'on dise il s'est rien passé
en Arménie en 1915 dans le cadre des
deux génocides les sanctions pénales
doivent être prévu ce qui ne veut pas
dire qui a contestation critique de
l'histoire ottomane ou de l'histoire
turque je l'ai dit dans l'hémicycle moi
je suis un admirateur sans borne de
l'histoire ottomane il fut un temps où
il y avait l'Inquisition en Europe où il
y avait la révocation de lesdant en
Europe et les gens Juifs protestants et
cetera trouvé refuge en Turquie et dans
l'Empire ottoman donc l'Empire ottoman a
été un empire de grande tolérance mais
comme toutes les histoires nationales il
y a des tâches nous en 1995 le président
Chirak a reconnu la responsabilité de
l'État français de Vichi dans la
déportation et dans les crimes de guerre
pendant la deuxème guerre mondiale
franchement que la Turquie évolue par
rapport à la reconnaissance de ce qui se
passait en arm il y a un siècle c'est
pas plus mal et je pense d'ailleurs que
le gouvernement turc a plus ouvert que
ses prédécesseurs avec les historiens
avec l'Arménie mais il faut avancer mais
pourtant la Turquie est visiblement très
fâchée de la lecture et de la discussion
de ce texte mais c'est normal parce que
comme toujours dans ces cas-là avant le
vote des textes on fait pression on fait
monter la pression on dit que l'opinion
turque ne pourrait pas accepter je je
peux comprendre c'est toujours
désagréable de voir dans un autre pays
mis sur vous la responsabilité d'amass
je peux comprendre et et sincèrement euh
mon amitié mon soutien avec l'ensemble
de la nation turque me me mal à l'aise
par rapport à ça pour autant on est bien
obligé de dire il y a 600000 français
d'origine arménienne en France on peut
pas leur dire vous il s'est rien passé
pour vos grands-parents et vos
arrière-grs-parents qu'on trouve des
solutions qu'on avance au rythme de
l'État turc par rapport ensuite à ce qui
fait avec l'Arménie c'est la
responsabilité de l'État turc mais pour
nous il y a une responsabilité nous
avons voté la reconnaissance de deux
génocides les deux génocides dans leurs
contestation doivent être sanctionnés de
la même manière Roger carouti vous
récusez toute idée même lointaine
d'électoralisme dans cette loi écoutez
dans ce texte et pour ce texte aussi
bien François Hollande d'un côté que
Nicolas Sarkozi de l'autre côté se sont
déclarés en faveur de ce texte
récupération par qui alors et dans les
deux cas dans les deux groupes il y a
des gens qui vont voter pour il y a des
gens qui vont voter contre il y a des
socialistes qui vont voter pour des
socialistes qui vont voter contre il y a
des UMP qui vont voter pour il des UM
qui vont voter contre la balle au centre
enfin au centre pas au centre politique
au centre du jeu vous êtes optimiste
pour les votes de ce soir je suis
prudent donc j'espère que jusqu'au bout
on va convaincre mais je suis prudent
parce que c'est très très difficile
merci beaucoup Rodier carouti vous le
voyez il y a un véritable suspense ici
que qui perdure au sein de l'hémicycle
du Sénat où se poursuivent les
discussions Bernard pirass sénateur des
bouches du rô est à la tribune il est
sur les mêmes position que celle
défendue à l'instant même à notre micro
par Roger caroutier on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes Bernard Piras dans
l'hémicycle de la Haute Assemblée à tout
à l'heure et systématiquement oublié
alors qu'elle m'a paraît supérieure au
fait de l'absence de juridiction
internationale de
l'époque sanctionner le fait de de
négation de génocide et bien une action
politique en votant ce texte nous jouons
pleinement notre rôle de parlementaire
et ne nous égarons pas mes chers
collègues dans quelques années nous
serons fiers d'avoir contribué à cet
acte politique empli de justesse et
d'humanité Gard de ces éléments le refus
de Volter la présente proposition de loi
apparaît m'apparaît incohérente ce qui
se fiche dans cette position n'en tire
pas les conclusions qui s'imposent la
loi du 29 janvier 2001 se veut
uniquement déclarative il lui manque un
aspect normatif autrement dit l'absence
d'outil juridique dans l'arsenal
législatif français empêche le juge de
sanctionner la méconnaissance des termes
de la dite loi du 29 janvier 2001 en
vertu du principe de la l'égalité des
incriminations et des peines le juge se
trouve ainsi démuni face une loi qu'il
ne peut pas faire respecter c'est le
sens de cette seconde loi à partir du
moment où nous partageons tous le même
sentiment à savoir que les émellements
de 1915 constituent bien un génocide
aucune raison objective ne peut
légitimer le refus de voter la présente
proposition de loi j'ai donc la convion
qu'enant le texte qui nous est soumis
nous feront u de conviction de courage
et de cohérence dans l'action politique
j'espère sincèrement que la majorité des
sénateurs partagera ce sentiment je
compte sur vous
merci je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Jean-François Humbert
pour le groupe
ummp monsieur le Président Monsieur
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues c'est en ma qualité de
président du groupe d'information sur le
Tibet que je souhaite apporter un
éclairage complémentaire à nos
débats je ne prononcerai pas de manière
définitive sur l'intérêt ou la
légitimité des lois dites mémoriell ni
sur la constitutionnalité d'une
incrimination pénale de la constation de
l'existence des génocides mon propos est
autre je veux profiter de
l'attention que le Sénat accorde
aujourd'hui à la très grave question des
génocide pour rappeler que l'un d'entre
eux est en cours aujourd'hui sur les
haut plateaux
tibétains je sais que cette affirmation
va se heurter à une certaine
incrédibilité
incrédulité d'autres sestimant bien
informés vont me rétorquer que
l'oppression exercé par les autorités
chinoises sur les Tibétains aussi
pesante soit-elle ne peut pas être
assimilé un génocide et pourtant et
pourtant à cela je répondrai par deux
considérations premièrement il ne faut
pas oublier que l'occupation du Tibet
par la Chine en
1949 a été suivi par l'élimination
physique de centaines de milliers de
Tibétains le gouvernement tibétain en
exile à daramsala en Inde estime le
nombre des victimes à 1200000 personnes
sur une population totale qui s'élevait
à 5 ou 6
millions certes comme il est d'usage en
matière de génocide son auteur
c'est-à-dire le gouvernement chinois ni
l'ampleur de ces
chiffres certains universitaires
occidentaux l'ont également révisé à la
baisse
l'estimant plus proche de 700 à 800000
victimes ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
dans les premières décennies de
l'occupation du Tibet il y a bien eu un
début de génocide physique qui a
d'ailleurs été reconnu en
1960 par une commission internationale
de
juristes
deuxièmement il y a d'autres manières de
faire disparaître un peuple que
d'éliminer physiquement les hommes et
les femmes qui le
constituent il suffit de le priver de sa
langue de sa culture et de sa
mémoire c'est la stratégie qui est
actuellement mise en œuvre de manière
très consciente et organisée par les
autorités chinoises ou
Tibet derrière l'autonomie de façade et
les droits reconnus en théorie au
prétendu minorités nationale par la
Constitution c'est Jean-Claude Humbert
actuellement qui s'exprime dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat jean-claudeber
sénateur UMP un autre sénateur UMP à mes
côté Serge d'assau sénateur de lesson
Serge d'assau je vous ai regardé dans
l'hémicycle vous étiez très attentif en
tout cas vous étiez déjà présent et très
attentif à ces débats quel est le le
regard que vous portez sur cette
discussion de cet après-midi qui est
quand même un peu curieuse il faut bien
le il faut bien le dire écoutez moi je
regrette une chose on parle beaucoup de
juridique on parle pas d'économie or la
Turquie est un partenaire important sur
le plan des exploortations y compris
peut-être comme des gens comme vous des
industriels comme vous non non pas pour
moi non vend pas d'avion en Turquie non
mais ils achètent des voitures ils
achètent beaucoup de produits agricole
et il y en a pour 10 à 11 milliards donc
c'est sûr c'est sûr que si le Tex est
voté et bien 11 milliards vont
disparaître parce qu'ils vont être pas
être contents et pour faire quoi pour
faire des hisires judiques des question
ce qui s'est passé il y a longtemps et
dont on ne parle plus un moment où la
France est en difficultés économique où
on a des problème de chômage où on ne
travaille pas assez et on parle de ces
trucsl moi je veux bien mais je suis pas
forcément d'accord donc vous avez une
vision j'allais dire pragmatique de ce
dossier bah c'est évident vous savez
aujourd'hui la France est en difficulté
financière son budget est en déficite
elle est elle a un déficit énorme sur le
plan d'exportation et voilà on reparle
de problème qui ont lieu en en 1901 ou
je sais pas quand mais c'est pas le
moment on a un problème de déficit
budgétaire énorme et on sent on
sintéresse pas et ça le vrai problème
les 39h on dit tout le monde on
travaille par on TR 39h mais disons-le
donc donc pour vous vous pensez comme
Alain Jupé le ministre des Affaires
étrangères ce texte est inopportun
aujourd'hui oui totalement ou totalement
donc vous allez voter contre bien sûr
les en tout cas en faveur des motions de
de d'irevabilité qui vont être débattu
tout à l'heure oui vter pour la motion
de
rervabilité avec certains petits
camarades socialistes ver bon voilà peut
avoir des idées communes temps en temps
c'est pas mauais d'ailleurs merci
beaucoup sergeass d'avoir été avec nous
on va retrouver tout de suite
l'hémicycle Jean-François Humber qui
s'exprime sénateur UMP je recevrai dans
quelques minutes pour quelques instants
Valérie Boyer qui vous le savez est à
l'origine de cette proposition de loi
qui arrive aujourd'hui en discussion au
Sénat à tout à l'heure pour
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues beaucoup de passion
entoure ce texte et beaucoup de voix
fortes compétentes et très éloquentes se
sont exprimé de part et d'autres et ici
sur cet événement si douloureux du
génocide arménien que nous avons reconnu
par la loi du 29 janv 2001 je les ai
écouté avec une grande attention cette
proposition de loi vise donc à réprimer
ceux qui auront contesté l'existence
d'un ou plusieurs crimes de génocide
définis par le code pénal et reconnu
comme tel par la loi française
aujourd'hui le seul génocide arménien
elle compléterait ainsi la loi du 29
juillet 1881 sur la liberté de la presse
qui peut-être insensible aux attentes de
nos compatriotes Arméniens d'origine
pour pour beaucoup leurs aînés sont
arrivés en France précisément pour fuir
les terribles exactions dont ils étaient
victimes et qui ne comprend leur forte
émotion à l'évocation de ce passé
tragique que certains esprits
malveillants ont parfois cherché à
contester cependant pour compassionnelle
qu'elle soit cette proposition de loi ne
répond pas sans faille à l'intention
qu'anime que redire après nombre de nos
collègues de ce qu'il faut penser des
lois mémorielles même si monsieur le
ministre je vous ai bien écouter le
texte n'est qu'un complément destiné à
réparer un oubli il s'y rattache
cependant clairement les lois mémoriel
amène le législateur à prendre position
sur des questions qui relèvent de
l'histoire or il me semble que si le
législateur fait parfois l'histoire il
n'est pas de sa fonction de l'écrire
nombre d'historiens sérieux s'insurgent
contre ce qu'il qualifie parfois de
dérive d'autre part d'éminents juristes
soulignent aussi l'impossibilité pour le
législateur de se prononcer sur
l'histoire sur la vérité ou la fausseté
de tel ou tel fait en mai dernier les
débats sur le même sujet nous ont
rappelé les problèmes de conformité à la
Constitution qui ne manqueraiit pas de
se poser les moyens de sanctionner le
négationnisme existent déjà et peuvent
être appliqués monsieur le rapporteur
les a rappelés j'évoquerai simplement
dans ce propos quelques aspects plus
politiques du texte dont nous débattons
qui relèvent j'en ai bien conscience de
notre temps faut-il rappeler que la
France a reconnu il y a 11 ans le génoci
voilà la suite des débats ici au Sénat
c'est emroiss duup pont le sénateur UMP
qui s'exprime actuellement ici dans la
salle de conférence toujours beaucoup de
monde beaucoup de médias et en
particulier des médias étrangers des
médias Arméniens Turcs ça ne vous
étonnera pas Bernard Piras vous êtes
exprimé il y a quelques minutes dans
l'hémicycle pour dire tout le bien que
vous pensiez de cette loi une loi que
vous allez voter j'allais dire sans
aucun complexe ce soir sans aucun sans
aucun complet ce soir je suis un un de
ceux qui av managé la loi de 2001 ici au
au Sénat avec je suis un de ceux qui
l'avaient présenté aussi en mai 2011 et
donc vous pensez que cette loi cette ce
texte discussé aujourd'hui et la simple
continuité c'est la logique même de
l'affaire pour compléter la loi 2001
écoutez il y a une loi il y a une loi si
jamais derrière il y a pas il y a pas
des dispositions qui sont prises pour
pénaliser cette loi elle n'a pas de sens
elle n'est que elle ne serait que
déclarative et pas norm
c'est là la façon de donner des moyens
au juges au juges d'appliquer la justice
et de de pénaliser alors on a entendu
certains arguments cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle en disant que finalement
dans le code pénal ben finalement il y
avait ce qu'il fallait il y avait les
outils juridiques qu'il fallait pour
éventuellement sanctionner ben écoutez
peut-être peut-être qu'ils y sont mais
cela ne fera que les renforcer donc qui
peut qui peut le plus peut le
moins d'cun dis que cette loi est
électoraliste vous-même j'imagine que
dans votre électorat dans votre
département la Drome et bien vous avez
certainement des électeurs soit
francoturc soit francoarméniens ou
arménien écoutez j'ai dans dans dans ma
ville il y a il y a 10 % de population
qui sont des français d'origine
arménienne il y a aussi une communauté
turque aussi qui qui qui est là présente
mais bon moi je n'ai pas fait ça en
fonction de de ça d'autant plus que à
l'époque où j'avais mené le débat en
2001 je n'étais ni maire ni élu de de ce
coin-là non c'est une une une une
vieille histoire pour moi où très jeune
j'étais élevé avec des des Arméniens et
j'ai connu rapidement sans savoir ce que
c'était que exactement un génocide parce
que à cet âge-là on a du mal à à savoir
mais que il y avait eu quand même des
méfit qui étaient qui é qui étaient
considérables et la population
arménienne de votre département de votre
ville et bien est venue vous
sensibiliser j'imagine à ces soucis à
ses soucis à ces cette histoire qui
marque toute une une communauté de
l'Arménie alors ce n'est pas ma
population de façon particulière c'est
les
associations nationales parisiennes qui
qui sont venus avec qui j'ai créé des
des liens dans le j'étais président du
du groupe d'amitié France Arménie au
Sénat donc ça a créé un certain nombre
de liens aussi comment vous écoutez dès
lors tout ce que dit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui encore ce matin encore
Ankara qui menasse et bien de poursuivre
des certaines représailles économiques
ou
financières chaque fois qu'il se passe
quelque chose c'est comme ça les choses
se se
solutionnont dans la dans la dans dans
la suite l'intérêt économique il est
réciproque euh donc à un moment donné il
faudrait bien que ça se normalise les
choses s'étaient déjà passées pour la
loi de de de janvier 2001 les mêmes
choses avaient av avaient été faites
j'ai même à l'époque des menaces de mort
à domicile donc voilà donc cela c'est
c'est un petit peu une une une une
logique une habitude mais je pense que
les choses devraient se normaliser et
puis en réalité il faudrait que la
Turquie finisse par reconnaître pourquoi
en Turquie les quelques-uns qui
reconnaissent le
génocide eux sont
sanctionnés c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui donc il y a en à partir de
2008 là 2009 pour le 24 avril un certain
nombre d'intellectuels historiens turcs
s'était exprimé un petit peu plus il y
avait une tolérance il y avait pas eu de
de de répression ça serait bien que ça
continue comme ça qu'elle finisse par le
reconnaître certes si cela se fait cela
posera le
problème de des territoires et le
problème des dédommagements et je crois
que c'est un petit peu pour cela que pu
la Turquie a tellement dit sur les
livres d'histoire nier ce ce ce ce
génocide que elle a d elle reconnaît
comme des exationss des massacres 500000
morts 500000 oui ou oui oui oui mais à à
Constantinople quand ils ont été quand
ils été jugés en
1919 le terme de génocide n'existait pas
encore mais c'était bien un nombre
beaucoup plus conséquent de d'exaction
merci beaucoup de votre point de vue
Bernard Piras qui donc voterz sans état
d'âme ce soir cette loi sur la
contestation des négations de génoyde
merci encore Bernard Piras dans quelques
instants Valérie Boyer qui je vous le
rappelle est à l'origine de cette
proposition de loi sera avec moi dans
cette salle des conférences à quelques
mètres seulement l'hémicycle du Sénat
tout à
l'heure considérant que ce texte c'est
proposition de loi qui crée un délit
pénal de contestation ou de minimisation
outrancière des génocides reconnus par
la loi française était contraire à
plusieurs principes reconnus par notre
Constitution mes chers collègues je vais
aborder successivement quatre principes
auxquels nous considérons que cette
proposition de loi
s'oppose il y a d'abord un risque de
contrarier
au principe de la légalité des délits et
des
peines bien qu'elle s'en inspire la
présente proposition de loi diffère en
réalité du dispositif retenu par la loi
gesso s'agissant de la pénalisation de
la contestation de la
choix en effet le dispositif de la loi
guesso est adossé à des faits précis
reconnu par une convention
internationale l'accord de l' du 8 août
1945 par une juridiction internationale
le tribunal de Nuremberg et par les
juridictions françaises au terme de
débats contradictoires auquels ont
participé des magistrats
français comme l'avait observé notre
ancien collègue Charles
Lederman rapporteur de cette loi pour
votre
commission l'infraction créée par la loi
guesso n'a pas pour but d'instituer une
vérité officielle mais de faire
respecter l'autorité de la chose jugée
qui s'attache aux décisions de justice
la loi Guess ne protège donc pas une
vérité historique elle apporte une
protection particulière au respect de
l'autorité de la chose jugée par des
juridictions internationales et des
jridiction française ou reconnu par la
France c'est ainsi que dans dans un
arrêt du 7 mai
2010 la Cour de cassation a estimé que
la question de la constitutionnalité de
la loi guesso je cite ne présentait pas
un caractère sérieux dans la mesure où
l'incrimination critiquée se réfère à
des textes régulièrement introduits en
droit interne définissant de manière
claire et précise
l'infraction la situation est très
différente s'agissant du génocide
arménien de
1915 qui a été commis avant l'adoption
de la Convention de
1948 pour la répression du crime de
génocide et dont les auteurs n'ont
jamais été jugés ni par une jurridiction
internationale ni par une juridiction
française de ce fait sur un plan
strictement juridique il n'existe pas de
définition précise ni dans une
convention internationale ni dans des
décisions de justice revêtu de
l'autorité de la chose jugée des actes
constituant ce génocide et des personnes
responsables de son
déclenchement cette difficulté pourrait
également valoir pour d'autres génocides
que le législateur pourrait souhaiter
qualifier comme tel par la loi j'appelle
par exemple votre attention que lors des
débats à l'Assemblée nationale un
amendement a été déposé c'est un fait
afin de permettre la reconnaissance
officielle par la République française
du génocide vendé1 de
179394 comment définir ce
dernier plusieurs propositions de loi
ont par ailleurs été déposées au cours
des années récentes au Sénat ou à
l'Assemblée nationale tendant à
reconnaître par la loi l'existence du
génocide zigane pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale ou encore celle du
génocide ukrainien de 1932- 1933 et la
liste mes chers collègues pourrait être
hélas très longue comme l'a écrit
Bertrand Matthieu la liste potentielle
des martyres de l'histoire est infinie
la réécriture où le gel de toute
recherche en serait la conséquence
inévitable il convient en outre de
souligner l'imprécision des termes
retenus par la proposition de loi le
fait je cite de contester ou minimiser
de façon outrancière l'existence d'un
génocide est plus large que sa seule
négation la contestation ou minimisation
peut porter sur les lieux les auteurs
les méthodes employées le champ temporel
des massacres sans forcément nier de
façon générale qu' génocide a été commis
ces termes seraiit susceptible de
soulever de réelles difficultés
d'appréciation s'agissant d'événements
historiques sur lesquels subsistent
encore des parts d'ombre au total le
champ de l'infraction créé par la
proposition de loi nous apparaît
contraire au principe de la légalité des
délit et des peines et je vous rappelle
mes chers
collègues que le Conseil constitutionnel
considère que ce principe est
respecté dès lors que l'infraction est
définie je cite dans des condition qui
permettent aux juges auquel le principe
de l'égalité impose d'interpréter
strictement la loi pénale de se
prononcer sans que son appréciation
puisse encourir la critique de
l'arbitraire il ne s'agit pas là d'une
simple question formelle mais bien
substantielle car comme l'indique le
commentaire officiel de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel qui constitue la
référence en cette matière
celle de la relative à la loi
d'orientation et de programme pour
l'avenir de l'école du 21 avril 2005 je
cite la liberté ne serait plus assurée
si la loi comportait trop de zones
grises trop de bornes flou et de limite
incertaines tel est le premier argument
qui tient au principe de la légalité des
délits et des peines 2è argument
le principe de la liberté d'opinion et
d'expression la création d'un délit de
contestation de l'existence d'un
génocide reconnu par la loi apparaît
contraire au principe de liberté
d'opinion et d'expression tel qu'il est
protégé par l'article 11 de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen ainsi que par l'article 10 de la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme vous le savez tous mes chers
collègues l'article 11 de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme de
1789 dispose je cite la libre
communication des pensées et des
opinions est un des droits les plus
précieux de l'homme tout citoyen peut
donc parler écrire imprimer librement
sauf à répondre de l'abus de cette
liberté dans les cas déterminés par la
loi certes cette liberté n'est pas
absolue elle admet des restrictions
destinées à protéger des droits et des
libertés également reconnu par la loi
l'article 10 de la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme vise notamment la
sécurité publique la prévention des
infractions la protection de la santé ou
de la morale ou encore le respect de la
vie privée encore faut-il que ces
restrictions soient proportionné aux
objectifs poursuivis ainsi si la loi
guesso à part est compatible avec le
principe de liberté d'opinion et
d'expression c'est parce qu'elle tente à
prévenir aujourd'hui la résurgence d'un
discours antisémite c'est ce qu'a jugé
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
dans une décision garudie du 24 juin
2003 en l'espèce force de constater
qu'heureusement aucun discours de nature
comparable à l'antisémitisme ne pas ré
visé aujourd'hui en France et de façon
massive no compatri d'origine arménienne
de ce fait la création d'un délit de
contestation ou de minimisation de
l'existence du du génocide de 1915
pourrait être considéré comme excédent
les restrictions communément admise pour
justifier une atteinte à la liberté
d'expression il s'agit là d'un risque
très sérieux soulevé par la plupart des
constitutionnalistes que nous avons
consulté ou qui se sont prononcés sur
cette question 3è
problème atteinte à la liberté de la
recherche je vous rappelle mes chers
collègues que le principe de la liberté
de la recherche scientifique découle
d'une part des principes de liberté
d'opinion et d'expression que je viens
d'évoquer et d'autre part du principe
d'indépendance des professeurs de
l'enseignement supérieur que le Conseil
constitutionnel regarde comme un
principe
constitutionnel depuis une décision en
date du 20 janvier
1984 selon celle-ci je cite par leur
nature même les fonctions d'enseignement
et de recherche demande dans l'intérêt
même du service que la libre expression
et et l'indépendance des personnels soit
garantie par les dispositions qui leur
sont applicables or la création d'un
délit de contestation ou de minimisation
d'événement historique qualifiés de
génocide par la loi ferait peser un
risque certain sur sur des travaux
scientifiques que des historiens
seraientent amenés à conduire de bonne
foi dès lors que leurs conclusion fondé
sur l'étude de sources historiques
serait regardé par certains comme
contestant ou minimisant ces événements
tragiques enfin 4è argument l'atteinte à
la compétence du
législateur j'attire votre attention mes
chers collègues sur le fait qu'en
inscrivant dans la loi la condamnation
de ceux qui contestent l'existence des
génocides reconnu comme tel par la la
loi française le législateur se
conférerait à lui-même une nouvelle
compétence celle de reconnaître des
génocide que ne lui reconnaît pas la
Constitution par ailleurs or comme le
rappelle le commentaire de la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel déjà cité je
cite la présence dans une loi d'un texte
qui n'est pas au nombre de ceux que la
Constitution soumet au vote du Parlement
doit être censuré car sous la 5e
République et contrairement au régime
précédent
le Parlement ne peut voter sur tout
objet de son choix en effet comme vous
le savez contrairement au Parlement des
3e et 4e République le notre en vertu de
la Constitution est doté d'une
compétence d'attribution c'est donc
uniquement le pouvoir constituant qui
pourrait nous conférer le pouvoir
d'exercer des compétences dont la
présente proposition de loi présuppose
que nous en
disposons je termine en vous disant mes
chers collègues que certains ont pu dire
que cette proposition de loi ne
présentait pas les mêmes caractères
d'inconstitutionnalité vous l'avez dit
vous-même monsieur le ministre que les
précédentes au motif qu'ell se
présentaiit comme la transposition en
droit interne d'une décision cadre des
instances européennes en date du 28
novembre 2008 relative à la lutte contre
certaines formes et manifestation de
racisme et de xénophobie au moien au
moyen du droit pénal or cet argument mes
chers collègues ne résiste pas à
l'examen puisqu'il ne propose qu'une
transposition très imparfaite de cette
dernière lisons l'article 1er de la
décision cadre je cite chaque
état-membre prend les mesures
nécessaires pour faire en sorte que soit
punissable l'apologie la négation la
banalisation grossière publique des
crimes de génocide crimes contre
l'humanité crimes de guerre tel que
défin aux article 6 7 et 8 du statut de
la Cour pénale internationale visant un
groupe de personnes ou un membre d'un
tel groupe lorsque le comportement est
exercé d'une manière qui risque
d'inciter à la violence ou à la haine à
l'égard d'un groupe de personnes ou d'un
membre d'un tel groupe ainsi
l'incrimination prévue doit viser
explicitement les comportements je cite
exercés d'une manière qui risque
d'inciter à la violence ou à la haine sa
finalité est donc de lutter contre le
racisme ou la xénophobie et non
seulement de protéger la mémoire or
l'infraction créée par la proposition de
loi ne comporte pas cet élément
intentionnel qui est absolument
essentiel ce qui fait perdre toute
pertinence à la référence à cette
décision cadre quand on veut nous
expliquer que la présente proposition de
loi est confme est conforme à la
Constitution
j'appelle enfin votre attention sur le
fait que si en l'état du droit seule la
négation de la choix peut donner lieu à
des poursuites pénales les rescapés
d'autres génocides ne sont pas pour
autant dépourvus de toute voie de
recours contre les propos
négationnistes d'abord la la diffamation
et l'injure raciale ou religieuse ainsi
que la provocation à la discrimination à
la haine ou à la violence à l'égard
d'une personne ou d'un groupe de
personnes en raison de leur origine sont
passibles de sanctions pénales tout
comme les l'apologie des génocides et
autres crime contre l'humanité c'est
déjà dans la loi par ailleurs si la
contestation des génocides autrees que
la choix ne peut donner lieu en l'état
du droit à une action au pénal la
jurisprudence estime que de tels faits
sont susceptible de donner lieu à une
action civile sur le fondement de la
responsabilité de droit commun et Dict
par l'article 1382 du code civil c'est
sur ce fondement je tiens à souligner
cela mes chers collègue qu'un historien
a été condamné en 1995 par le tribunal
de grande instance de Paris à un franc
de dommage et intérêt parce que cette
juridiction a considéré je cite qu'il
avait manqué à ses devoirs d'objectivité
et de prudence en s'exprimant sans
nuance sur un sujet aussi sensible que
ses propos susceptible de raviver
injustement la douleur de la communauté
arménienne était fautif et justifi une
indemnisation des voies de recours
existent donc déjà contre les personnes
qui contesteraient ou miniser
minimiseraiit de façon
outrancière l'existence de génocide et
autres crimes contre
l'humanité nous ne pensons donc pas mes
chers collègues qu'il soit pertinent de
s'engager dans la la voie pénale qui
présente les risques très sérieux
d'inconstitutionnalité que je viens
d'évoquer je rappelle aussi que cette
loi serait totalement inefficace si le
but est de lutter contre des propos
négationnistes tenus à l'étranger
puisque la loi pénale française ne
s'applique comme vous le savez qu'au
fait commis sur le territoire de la
République voilà à la tribune
jean-Pierre Sueur le président de la
commission des lois ici dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat Jean-Pierre suur qui est en
train de défendre euh sa première
exception d'irrecevabilité donc vous
l'avez entendu il explique à la tribune
les raisons qui lui font penser que
cette loi ce texte en cours de
discussion est
anticonstitutionnel des arguments qu'il
avait déjà avancé Jean-Pierre suer lors
de sa première intervention à la tribune
au début de cet après-midi à mes côté
Valérie Boyet député UMP de Marseille
madame Boyet c'est vous qui êtes à
l'origine de cette proposition de loi
actuellement discutter ici au Sénat en
première lecture comment doit-on mesurer
votre présence ici euh dans cette salle
des
conférences pour écouter les débats les
discussions autour de votre texte
bonsoir et bien écoutez comme celle que
comme ma précédente présence lorsque
j'étais venu lorsque j'avais été
rapporteur de la loi Fourcade donc
j'étais venu effectivement ici pour
travailler avec mon collègue à la
million et et d'autres collègues
parlementaires il était tout à fait
normal quand on est l'auteur d'unex et
son rapporteur de venir dans les deux
assemblées enfin dans une des deux
assemblées poursivre le texte et
continuer le travail accompli j'ajoute
quand même que ça a été un à titre
personnel un moment extrêmement fort de
mon mandat et même de de ma vie tout
court parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
texte qui est particulièrement chargé
d'émotion ça fait 10 ans qu'on attend de
trouver une solution législative le
débat mémoriel il a eu lieu en 2001 et
aujourd'hui dans le droit français on se
retrouve avec euh deux types de génocide
un qui est la choix avec euh des
dispositions qui permettent de pénaliser
les légationnistes et un autre qui est
la reconnaissance du génocide de 1915 où
les négationnistes ne peuvent pas être
pénalisés donc il était vraiment
nécessaire d'aller plus loin et de faire
en sorte que ce texte loi devienne
effectif j'ajoute que le texte que nous
avons voté à l'Assemblée nationale au
mois de décembre a un caractère
universel puisqu'il s'adresse et il et
il s'adresse à tous les g nocide reconnu
par la loi française pour des actes qui
se passent sur le territoire français et
qui intéressent des Français donc un
texte qui vous protéger nos concitoyens
un texte qui vous tient particulièrement
à cœur qui est également qui a reçu le
soutien de Nicolas Sarkozi oui c'est un
texte qui a reçu le soutien du président
de la République je rappelle que c'était
une promesse du président de la
République et je dirais que une fois de
plus les promesses du candidat Sarkozi
et bien se transformment en engagement
tenu il en va de de ce texte comme de
bien d'autres et donc là nous sommes là
pour défendre nos concitoyens je le
rappelle puisque ça s'adresse c'est le
Parlement français qui dispose pour le
territoire français et pour les citoyens
français il n'empêche je rappelle que je
l'ai dit hein vous êtes député UMP de
Marseille Marseille qui comporte une
très puissante communauté arménienne
d'ailleurs on a vu la présence également
du maire de Marseille he tout à l'heure
Jean-Claude
godinès présent de la loi de 2 bien sûr
et c'està dire que ce texte a aussi
quelque part peut-être des intentions
électorales c'est pas rien la communauté
arménienne de Marseille vraiment que les
textes de loi ont des intentions
électorales mais écoutez honnêtement
soyons soyons honnête d'abord moi je
récuse le terme communauté je n'aime pas
le terme communauté je m'adresse à des
Français qu'ils soi d'origine arménienne
ou pas d'ailleurs puisque je le répète
ce texte consacre des valeurs de dignité
humaine et de droits de l'homme ensuite
bien évidemment que nous sommes là pour
répondre aux attentes de nos concitoyens
et bien évidemment nous avons fait des
promesses pendant les élection tion et
bien évidemment nous les tenons donc il
est tout à fait normal que l'on tienne
ses engagements vous savez euh moi je
m'occupe beaucoup des questions de santé
et je vous le disais tout à l'heure
j'étais là par exemple dans le cadre de
de la loi Fourcade est-ce un texte
électoraliste que de tenir ses
engagements vis-à-vis des médecins par
exemple de refuser la cooherition ce
sont des engagements de notre parti
politique ce sont des engagements
aujourd'hui du Parlement français et je
suis fière d'avoir tenu ces promesses et
de ne pas avoir trahi ma parole il en va
de même pour le texte d'aujourd'hui
quelle loi n'est pas électorale je ve
dire est-ce qu'on peut reprocher aux
hommes et aux femmes politiques d'être
honnête dans leur engagement et de tenir
ses engagements lorsqu'ils sont élu
c'est la démocratie et si à l'occasion
des élections présidentielles il peut
avoir unanimité et consensus et bien
tant mieux presque on regretterait qu'il
y a pas des élections présidentielles
tous les ans pour que de grands sujets
comme ça de grandes causes universelles
trouvent le soutien de l'ensemble des
partis politiques vous auriez souhaité
qu'il y ait peut-être un peu plus de
monde dans les bancs de la droite
aujourd'hui ici dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat non vous savez la droite est très
bien représentée notamment par son
président de groupe euh maire de
Marseille maire de Marseille
effectivement moi je suis très fière
d'être adjointe au maire de Marseille
aussi
euh je pense que ce qui importe c'est
que nos engagements soient tenus nous
avons des mandats enfin ici au Sénat le
président de groupe a le mandat
puisqu'il y a un scrutin public qui a
été demandé de ses collègues et c'est
l'essentiel l'objectif pour ce texte
comme pour les autres hein c'est qu'il
soit voté conformément aux engagements
qui ont été pris vous avez quelques
doutes sur l'issue de cette discussion
ce soir mais je pense qu'il faut rester
vigilant mais si tout le monde tient ses
promesses ça devrait passer et je pense
qu'on vivra un grand moment de
l'histoire de notre pays et surtout de
l'histoire des droits de l'homme parce
que vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
aujourd'hui nous avons beaucoup de
collègues européens qui se sont
rapprochés du Parlement français que ce
soit le Sénat ou l'Assemblée nationale
pour faire en sorte que parmi tous ces
pays qui ont reconnu l'existence de
génocide et bien il y a un texte plus
généraliste qui s'impose à l'ensemble
des pays de l'Union européenne je
rappelle que ma proposition de loi voté
à l'Assemblée nationale et je l'espère
voter ce soir ici dans cet hémicycle
s'inspire très largement du droit
européen c'est une décision cadre he qui
nous impose de faire en sorte que ce
texte puisse être voté comment dirais-je
vous espérez donc un vote dans les mêmes
terme que le vote qui a eu lieu en
décembre à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
que quand même il y avait une urgence
tel que ce texte devait être discuté
aujourd'hui ici au Sénat on naurait pas
pu attendre peut-être un peu plus tard
on est quand même dans une période
politique un peu particulière en ce
moment en France bah on est dans une
période politique un petit peu
particulière mais je me permets de vous
rappeler que jamais je n'aurais déposé
ce texte si en mai 2011 je crois que
c'était en mai le ca n'avait pas rejeté
d'illeurs n'a même pas pu se prononcer
sur le vote le texte qui avait été voté
à l'Assemblée nationale en 2006 c'est
parce qu'il y a eu cet échec au Sénat
que j'ai réfléchi à une autre façon de
faire en sorte que les négationnistes
puissent être pénalisés en France et que
je me suis inspirée du droit au pain et
que j'ai déposé ce texte au mois de
septembre maintenant il est tout à fait
normal qu'il soit discuté pendant cette
mandature puisque je rappelle que
c'était une promesse et que Nicolas
Sarkozi et les personnes qu' le
soutiennent ont l'habitude de tenir
leurs promesses dans ce domaine comme
dans d'autres alors une toute dernière
question elle est un peu technique on
entend on a entendu Jean-Pierre suur
tout à l'heure qui expliquer pourquoi
selon lui ce texte est
anticonstitutionnel Jean-Jacques
yest le précédent président de la
commission des lois UMP au Sénat avait
grosso modo conclu à des mêmes
conclusion sur un texte similaire
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce ce
revirement aujourd'hui et bien la la
droite est en faveur de ce texte je
rappelle que ce texte est différent de
celui du mois de mai hein il n'est pas
du tout dans la même t d'abord il ne
cite aucun pays étranger en l'occurrence
ni l'Arménie ni la Turquie pour être
plus clair he et qu'il est totalement
généralist c'est la première chose la
seconde chose c'est que moi je partage
pas l'analyse constitutionnelle d'anti
constitutionnalité qui a qui a été faite
c'est vrai qu'il y a un débat
constitutionnel on verra s'il y a une
motion ce que le Conseil constitutionnel
en dira mais en ce qui me concerne je
rappelle que la Constitution donne au
parlementaires le droit et le pouvoir de
s'emparer de tout texte qu'il juge utile
et de les transformer en normme ça c'est
la première chose la seconde c'est que
moi je pense que aujourd'hui nous avons
et notamment si ce texte n'est pas voté
un vrai débat de droit de l'homme un
vrai débat constitutionnel comment se
fait-il que par exemple pour la loi
guesso il y a des personnes qui soient
protéger du négationnisme parce que le
génocide a été reconnu et comment se
fait-il qu'aujourd'hui le texte de 2001
ne puisse pas avoir de de de lien
effectif avec le droit français parce
qu'il ne suffit pas de déclarer en droit
français il faut aussi faire grief donc
aujourd'hui on a un vrai débat de
justice et d'égalité de nos concitoyens
face à la protection qu'ils sont en
droit d'attendre par rapport au
négationnisme je rappelle que le
négationisme c'est pas une simple
opinion nous on considère que c'est une
synthèse de tous les délits d'injure de
racisme de xénophobie le négationisme
est là pour empêcher les historiens de
travailler c'est l'antihistoire et qu'il
est absolument nécessaire de faire en
sorte que la négation du crime ne
prolonge pas le crime comme le disait
Bisel et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il est vraiment nécessaire et très
important que le négationniste puisse
être sanctionné c'est pas une lubie
c'est pas une lubie électoraliste c'est
un problème extrêmement important et on
voit bien combien d'ailleurs les idées
négationnistes s'expriment en toute
liberté moi une question à poser quand
même à nos concitoyens qui s'interrogent
sur la nécessité de ce texte est-ce
qu'il pensent vraiment que soit sans la
loi guesso aujourd'hui on pourrait
apprendre la choix dans les classes en
France on sait bien que non hein parce
que le négationnisme essaie de
s'exprimer il en va de même pour les
autres génocides reconnus par la loi
française et en l'occurrence celui de
1915 donc j'espère vraiment que ce texte
qui a une portée universelle va pouvoir
être voté tout à l'heure et que ensuite
et bien il pourra prospérer au niveau
européen encore une fois la France sera
à l'avant-garde de ces questions merci
beaucoup Valérie Boyet d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir je rappelle que vous êtes
la la
signataire l'auteur de cette proposition
de loi dont la discussion continue ici
au Sénat je vous le disais on en est aux
discussions autour des trois motions qui
ont suivi la discussion générale que
vous avez pu écouter attentivement sur
notre antenne c'est Jean-Pierre Sueur je
ne sais pas s'il est toujours
à sur les bands du du Sénat mais c'est
Sophie joissin euh S ce des bouches du
rô une de vos collègues madame Boyet qui
est en train de de s'exprimer que vous
allez écouter elle répond à Jean-Pierre
Sueur sur cette motion d'exception
d'irrecevabilité c'estàdire sur la
constitutionnalité de ce texte ou pas
tout ceci pour montrer qu'il y a bien eu
reconnaissance des faits par un tribunal
turc qui plus est mais que l'histoire
les intérêts de territoire ont une fois
de plus prévalu sur la conscience
internationale il est légitime dans ces
circonstances où tous les auteurs d'
gécide sont décédés et qu'il est donc
impossible de les juger de nouveau que
la loi puisse intervenir reconnaître un
génocide ne se fait pas facilement et la
loi française ne serait pas intervenue
de façon légère le tribunal des peuples
une commission de l'ONU l'Europe l'ont
fait avant nous la loi ici ne procède
pas d'un simple bon vouloir des
parlementaires la loi française a
reconnu deux génocides et il est
équitable de les traiter de la même
manière Serge clarfield si nous ne
votions pas la loi parle et ça a été
déjà dit tout à l'heure de défaite
morale de la France je pense qu'il a
raison sur le principe de la légalité
des délis et des peines le texte définit
clairement et précisément l'infraction
qui sera constituée lorsque seront
réunies les conditions suivantes une
contestation minimisation ou
transancière du génocide par l'un des
moyens visés à
l'article pardon 23 de la loi du 29
juillet 1881 qui définit les
déclarations publiques d'un ou plusieurs
crimes de génocide définis à l'article
2111 du du code pénal et 3ème condition
reconnue comme tel par la loi française
le renvoi à la définition du génocide
tel que figurant dans le code pénal et
le renvoi prévu à la reconnaissance par
la loi sont limpides la contestation
minimisation transancière ont en fait
constitué un amendement de Jean-Luc
farsman pour protéger le travail de
recherche de l'historien et ne
paraissant pas pouvoir donner lieu à une
interprétation incertaine il est aussi
fait grief à cette proposition de loi de
ne pas respecter la liberté d'opinion et
d'expression protégé par l'article 10 de
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme la liberté d'expression peut
faire l'objet de limit et admet des
restrictions destinées à protéger des
droits et libertés également reconnu par
la
loi le respect de la mémoire des
victimes est un droit pour les victimes
et leurs descendants mais un devoir pour
la République que nous sommes l'article
17 de la dite convention interdit les
abus de droit qui peuvent résulter d'une
interprétation excessive d'autres
dispositions de la convention
contester minimiser de façon outrancière
le crime de génocide relève bien d'un
abus de droit et cet abus doit être puni
par la loi guesso et par la présente
proposition de
loi encore une fois le génocide est un
acte d'une telle gravité que cette
restriction à la liberté d'expression
paraît proportionné aux objectifs
poursuivi la loi guesso tente à prévenir
la résurgence d'un discours antisémite
la présente proposition de loi tente à
prévenir en France l'influence en France
et pour les autres pays qui l'ont adopté
l'influence du négationisme d'État
pratiqué aujourd'hui par la Turquie
notre collègue Valérie Boyer rapporteur
de la de la de la proposition de loi à
l'Assemblée nationale a subi insultes et
menaces des sites Internet aineux ont
fleuri diffusant des thèses
négationnistes et racistes
anti-arméniennes anti-grec anti-urde je
tiens leur nom si vous le souhaitez à
votre disposition
il faut savoir aussi que la déchéance de
la nationalité turque n'existant pas nos
ressortissants franco-turques pourraient
s'il retournait en Turquie après avoir
tenu en France des propos reconnaissant
le génocide arménien tombé sous le coup
de l'article 301 du code pénal turc qui
punit la reconnaissance du génocide
arménien code pénal sur lequel amnistie
internationale s'est beaucoup exprimé et
reporter sans frontière aussi il y a
bien d'autres manifestations du
phénomène négationniste en France mais
nous sommes pas pour les unér toutes le
Conseil constitutionnel préserve comme
un étant fondamental le principe
d'indépendance des professeurs de
l'enseignement
supérieur le 21 juin
1995 la première chambre du tribunal de
grande instance de Paris le président
suur l'a cité condamne un historien
Bernard Lewis pour avoir qualifié le
génocide arménien de version arménienne
de
l'histoire attendu que l'histoire a par
principe toute liberté pour exposer
selon ses vues personnelles les faits
les actes et les attitude s'il a ainsi
toute l'attitude pour remettre en cause
selon son appréciation les témoignages
reçus ou les idées acquises l'historien
ne saurait cependant échapper à la règle
commune liant l'exercice légitime d'une
liberté à l'acceptation nécessaire d'une
responsabilité l'historien engage sa
responsabilité envers les personnes
concernées lorsque par dénaturation au
falsification il présente comme
véridique des allégations manifestement
erronnées ou hé par négligence grave des
événements ou opinions rencontront
l'adhésion de personnes assez qualifiées
et éclairé pour que le souci d'une
exacte information lui interdise de les
passer sous silence Jean-Luc varsem a
introduit dans la présente proposition
de loi les termes de minimisation ou
transcière dans le but de protéger la
communauté scientifique dans ses
recherches et je fais confiance à nos
tribunaux pour ne qualifier d'Ancier
qu'un travail partial non sérieux ou au
service d'une idéologie quelconque
l'historien a plus de droit dans la
liberté d'expression parce que sa
responsabilité est plus
grande dernier point cette cette
proposition de loi contrairement à la
précédente est ancrée dans la loi sur la
liberté de la presse et ne fait pas
courir de risque d'inconstitutionnalité
à la loi de
2001 je ne pense pas en toute bonne foi
et en toute sincérité que cette
proposition de loi puisse être jugée
inconstitutionnelle car elle n'apporte à
la liberté d'expression qu'une atteinte
limitée et justifiée dans une société
démocratique de plus il n'est pas du
tout évident que le Conseil
constitutionnel en soit saisi la loi
guesso a fait l'objet d'une question
prioritaire devant la Cour de cassation
laquelle dans un arrêt du 7 mai 2010 a
estimé ne pas devoir transmettre au
Conseil en considérant qu'il était
évident que le délit de révisionnisme ne
portait pas atteinte au principes
constitutionnel de liberté d'opinion et
d'expression le texte que nous votons
aujourd'hui que j'espère que nous
voterons tout à l'heure
est un texte juste circonscrit à
l'incrimination de génocide et je le
rappelle au territoire français le
révisionnisme est un crime nous ne
pouvons nous contenter de la loi
civile pour cela je vous demande de
rejeter l'exception desrecevabilités
constitutionnelle car elle est recevable
je vous demande aussi de rejeter plus
tard la question préalable et le renvoi
en commission n'est pas nécessaire car
il prendra encore des
années
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur le
Ministre merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président
Jean-Pierre Sueur nous nous connaissons
depuis
longtemps et nous avons partagé de
nombreux moments sur les bands de
assemblée nous avons développé des
rapports où le respect et l'amitié
existe je
crois je connais votre connaissance du
droit donc c'est avec beaucoup
d'humilité que je vais m'engager dans ce
débat mais je ne peux pas accepter vos
arguments je ne peux pas les accepter
parce qu'il ne correspondent pas à
l'objet du texte qui vous a présenté
aujourd'hui et je remercie madame
joisset à l'instant qui vient
effectivement de recadrer le débat et
expliquer où nous devons all
je comprends monsieur le Président que
dans le rôle qui est le votre
aujourd'hui en tant que président de la
commission des
lois vous vous vous inscriviez dans une
ligne d'argumentation conforme aux
travaux passés de votre commission et
dans le respect de la position défendue
par des sénateurs membres de la
commission aujourd'hui et y compris
d'anciens sénateurs je pense à Monsieur
Badinter à qui vous faites référence
souvent alors je vais vous répondre mais
je voudrais vous dire que je souhaite
puisque je je ne suis pas intervenu pour
répondre aux 15 sénatrices et sénateurs
qui ont parlé je souhaite en même temps
répondre à celle-ci et ceci vous
comprendrez que je sois un peu plus long
oui monsieur carucci tout en essayant
d'être le plus court
possible monsieur le Président sueur
vous consacrez une part importante de
votre rapport aux lois mémoriel vous
avez certainement raison si vous jugez
opportun de le
faire mais je le répète la proposition
de loi aujourd'hui examiner n'en est'est
pas une pour reprendre votre propre
définition écrite dans votre rapport de
ce qui est une loi mémoriel je vous cite
celle-ci au-delà des différences de leur
contenu semble procéder d'une même
volonté dire l'histoire voire la
qualifier en recourant des concepts
juridiques contemporains et cetera et
cetera alors je vous interroge mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs voici la
proposition de loi elle fait 14 lignes
monsieur le Président 14 lignes deux
articles qui ne traitent que de sujets
pénaux comment pouvez-vous dire que
cette proposition de loi refait
l'histoire et qualifie la qualifie en
recourant des concepts juridique
contemporain non non non monsieur Bay je
me contente simplement de m'ent tenir à
l'écriture de la proposition de loi au
fond de cette proposition de loi et à ce
qu'elle veut dire sur le plan du droit
c'est une proposition pénal qui permet
de rétablir une chose qui n'a pas été
faite c'est-à-dire de combler un vide
juridique qui existait dans notre dans
notre droit pénal alors j'ai pas pris le
code pénal mais je pourrais vous le lire
si ça vous intéresse monsieur le
Président vous écrivez donc vous-même
vous écrivez donc vous-même la
définition qui démontre qu'aujourd'hui
nous ne sommes pas dans une loi
mémorielle et je vous en
remercie à l'évidence cette proposition
de loi est bel et bien texte
d'harmonisation pénale et ce n'est que
cela
elle ne qualifie pas des faits
historiques elle ne fait que pénaliser
les négation de la loi et ce n'est que
cela et à cet égard cher Roger carucci
vous avez parfaitement raison il n'y a
pas il doit pas y avoir de hiérarchie
entre les
génocides lorsque la loi reconnaît un
génocide elle doit avoir la même portée
juridique qu'une autre loi identique qui
reconnaît un autre génocide vous avez
raison ne commençons pas à à comparer
les massacres ou à vouloir établir une
hiérarchie dans
l'horreur madame ben Bassa je vous ai
écouté avec respect et
attention vous avez longuement rappelé
l'histoire du génocide arménien et de
l'Empire ottoman mais là aussi vous vous
trompez de débat nous ne sommes pas ici
pour refaire l'histoire de la Turquie ou
de l'Arménie nous sommes ici pour créer
une infraction générale de négationnisme
cette loi vise à protéger justement les
descendants des victimes de tous les
génocides de et la négation de ces
crimes Jean-Vincent placer vous avez
aussi fait un plédoyer contre les lois
mémorielles mais vous avez probablement
raison comme je ne veux pas entrer dans
ce débat je prendrai pas position mais
je dis vous avez probablement raison et
je vous répète que c'est pas le débat de
ce jour quel que soit le talent que vous
utilisez pour essayer de nous le faire
croire Madame Isabelle Pasquet vous avez
stigatisé une déche démarche
prétendument électoraliste
cela aurait pu être le cas si la
proposition de loi visait un fait
historique particulier a pu considérer
dans ce cas-là que stigmatisant ou
traitant particulièrement d'une
communauté nous recherchions un
contreffet ou un effet électoral mais
c'est pas le cas c'est un texte de
portée générale qui vise à créé une
incrimination générique du négocianisme
ce n'est pas une infraction pénale
communautariste je voudrais là aussi
vous le rappeler alors monsieur le
Président
mesard vous vous relevez que le
gouvernement avait une position de
sagesse à l'Assemblée nationale je
voudrais je voulais vous préciser que
convaincu par les éléments qui ont été
exposé lors de ces débats et conforté
par le vote de l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement est aujourd'hui favorable à
ce texte et il ne change pas d'avis si
si vous avez pas ceux qui changer d'avis
change pas d'avis quand au fait que ce
dernier non non quant au fait que le
gouvernement a changé d'avis par rapport
au texte examiné le 4 mai dernier je
répondrais qu'il ne s'agit pas du même
texte que celui-ci non non non celui-ci
ne vise pas que le génocide
arménien celui le texte de Monsieur la
gauche n'était pas suffisamment précis
alors que le texte présenté aujourd'hui
renvoie expressément à la définition du
génocide prévu à l'article 211 du code
pénal monsieur catelbach a d'ailleurs
rappelé ce point juridique qui permet de
consolider juridiquement le texte u
égard au principe de l'égalité des
délits et des peines et je vous remercie
monsieur celbach de soutenir
l'argumentation du du gouvernement c'est
pour cela que le gouvernement apporte
son soutien à la proposition de loi qui
ne vise qu'à traiter de la même façon
les génocides reconnus par la loi et
cette position elle est transcourant
elle est transgoupe il y a pas des
groupes qui sont pour et des groupes qui
sont compte ça appel à la conviction de
chacun et effectivement nous sommes tous
et vous êtes tous prob
partagé monsieur Sueur monsieur le
Président sueur je le répète ce texte ne
vise aucunement à revenir sur un débat
tranché il y a 10 ans il y a 20 ans même
pour la choie et les génocides Juifs 20
ans et 10 ans ces débats sont tranchés
c'est la loi de la République ce sont
les lois de la République il nous
revient aujourd'hui de les appliquer de
la même manière l'une l'est à travers le
code pénal l'autre ne l'est pas 'agit
simplement de faire en sorte qu'elle le
soit toutes les deux et ce n'est que
cela qui est en cause aujourd'hui
monsieur Sueur alors vous avez
effectivement des arguments d'une grande
porté intellectuelle effectivement on
peut faire des dégagements émotionnels
en appeler à l'émotion de chacun au
rappel historique de chacun et que
chacun se replonge dans l'histoire et en
disant ah mais aujourd'hui ils
commettent un acte irresponsable de de
faire ce qu'ils font mais ce n'est pas
ce que nous faisons monsieur su je ne
vous demande pas je vous demande pas de
de répondre de répondre par une
argumentation qui n'a strictement rien à
voir avec le dispositif de cette
proposition de loi je vous demande de
rester sur le plan du droit dans ce
dispositif de deux articles et seulement
que dans celui-là alors vous avez
rappelé monsieur le Président sueur que
la commission des lois avait longtemps
débattu du champ de l'article 34 de la
Constitution vous avez raison vous avez
raison de vous poser cette question je
pourrais comprendre ces interrogations
parce que là elle s est fondé s'il
s'agissait d'une loi
mémorielle mais effectivement toute
argumentation qui est développée par
ceux qui sont contre cette proposition
et de nous ramener un débat qui n'est
pas le bon débat alors c'est c'est c'est
difficile madame Goulet d'autes aussi
d'entendre systématiquement parler
d'autres choses que de ce texte de loi
et seulement de celui-là n'y a-t-il pas
de de mission plus noble pour le
Parlement que de définir les crimes et
les délit monsieur le
Président nous sommes ici au cœur de la
du législateur au sens de l'article 34
ce texte là monsieur Sueur il est au
cœur de l'article 34 définir les
comportements qui doivent être réprimé
par la loi pénale nous sommes dedans et
seulement dans ce cette cette
interprétation plus qu'inprétation parce
que c'est l'article 34 lui-même donc je
ne peux pas recevoir comme valable les
arguments qui expliquent qu'il n'est pas
constitutionnel il n'y a par ailleurs
oui monsieur mard relisez relisez le
texte relisez le texte deux articles 14
lignes qui ne parlent que de droit pénal
pas d'histoire pas de loi mémorielle il
n'y a pas d'ailleurs il n'y a pas par
ailleurs aucune atteinte au principe de
l'égalité des délits car je vous ai
beaucoup entendu parler du principe de
l'égalité des délits et vous avez raison
monsieur le Président su de vous en
préoccuper les contours de l'infraction
sont clairement définis par la loi ces
contours résultent à la fois de la
nouvelle loi qui pélanise la négation
d'un génocide reconnu par la loi et des
lois précédemment adoptées qui proclame
la reconnaissance du G du génocide Juif
et bien sûr du génocide arménien de 1915
ce qui est interdit c'est donc le fait
de soutenir que ces génocides n'ont pas
existé ou de les minimiser de façon
outrancière de minimiser Dee façon
outrancière chez gnocide j'insiste sur
de façon outrancière parce que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure parler de la
recherche des intellectuels et cetera je
vais y revenir certains objet qu' aurait
fallu objet qu'il aurait fallu se
limiter à sanctionner le négationniste
de génocide
reconnu par une juridiction pénale
internationale peut-être pourquoi pas
mais que faire pour les génocides dont
les auteurs sont tous aujourd'hui
décédés je vous pose une question
répondez-moi que
faire lorsque les faits sont anciens la
justice pénale ne peut plus passer
puisqu'elle juge les hommes et non
l'histoire c'est pourquoi le texte en
discussion aujourd'hui est nécessaire
pour compléter notre dispositif légal et
cela me permet de répondre également à
monsieur le Président suur sur le grief
d'atteinte à la séparation des pouvoirs
et sur l'empiètement du pouvoir
législatif sur l'autorité judiciaire
vous avez longuement développé ces
points il n'y a aucune atteinte possible
puisque malheureusement je viens de le
dire les juges n'ont jamais condamné les
auteurs de ce génocide et ne pourront
jamais le faire premier point deuxème
point même s'il existait un risque de
contrariété entre une décision de
justice et la loi cela ne constituerait
pas nécessa ement un Grif
d'inconstitutionnalité alors moi je je
veux bien que des personnes connaissant
parfaitement nos textes constitutionnels
nous expliquent savamment dans les
articles et dans les les les
interventions que ce texte est
inconstitutionnel mais j'entends aussi
des personnes qui connaissent tout aussi
bien la Constitution et les textes
constitutionnels nous dire le contraire
et depuis 10 ans que cette loi a été
votée personne ne l'a déféré au Conseil
constitutionnel pas mais bonté divine
pardonnez-moi cette expression mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs pourquoi
l'avez-vous voté ici si elle était
inconstitutionnel dans cette hémicycle
d'une manière unanime d'une manière
unanime vous avez toutes et tous voté en
2001 pour voter ce texte sur le génocide
arménien alors
aujourd'hui monsieur le sénateur
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui alors que vous
avez tous voté unanimement vous
viendriez prétendre alors qu'à l'époque
alors qu'à l'époque alors qu'à l'époque
aucun groupe mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs n'a déféré ce texte au Conseil
constitutionnel vous pouviez le faire
c'est je parle de la loi mémorielle de
2001 je parle de celle-là et seulement
de celle-là car vous vous référez tout
et tous à
celle-là et je vous dis et je vous dis à
partir du moment où elle été votée à la
quasi unanimité où personne ne l'a
déféré aujourd'hui vous venez plaider
qu'un texte d'application de cette loi
car ce texte pénal n'est qu'un texte
d'application de cette loi et vous venez
m'expliquer que ce texte lui serait
inconstitutionnel pardonnez-moi je ne
peux pas accepter cet argument même si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi
monsieur carer et je peux le comprendre
si l'intérêt général le justifie je
crois qu'il le justifie ici la loi peut
mettre en cause des décisions des juges
aussi et c'est en effet le cas de toutes
les lois d'amnistie je vous le rappelle
aussi les lois d'amnistie non seulement
interdisent les poursuites mais elles
stoppent les poursuites en cours et font
disparaître les condamnations passé
voyez c'est c'est c'est c'est encore
beaucoup plus important que ce qu'on est
en train d'évoquer le plus souvent
sanctionne ceux qui rappellent des
condamnations passé je vous le rappelle
aussi c'est du droit français or elles
sont constitutionnelles ces lois
d'amnistie la présente proposition de
loi qui pénalise la négation des
génocides reconnus par la loi est une
forme d'amnistie à l'envers elle est
tout autant conforme à la Constitution
pardonnez-moi mais c'est la
démonstration que je veux vous faire et
je me sens fondé de laffire tout autant
que ceux qui qui me démontre dans les
articles de presse que je pourrais avoir
tort je vais mais je comprends monsieur
baayet que vous ayez une motion de une
question préalable à défendre et je
comprends que avant de la défendre vous
disiez que vous êtes pas d'accord avec
moi monsieur
baayet je le comprends même si je suis
moi pas d'accord avec vous deuxème
argument monsieur le président de la
commission des lois il n'y a par
ailleurs aucune atteinte à la liberté de
la
rechercheall dire chers collègues
pardonnez-moi je me sens encore
tellement parlementaire Mesdames et
Messieurs les sinatrices sénateur ne
vous engagez pas ne vous engagez
pas merci de lire dans les boules de
cristal monsieur carer ne vous engagez
pas dans dans ce débat ne vous engagez
pas dans ce débat non mais je comprends
vous cherchez à me perturbé mais vous
pouvez essayer vous n'y arriverez
pas vous n'y arriverez pas ce travail de
recherche est légitime madame Goulet l'a
largement répété il faut encourager la
recherche historique elle est nécessaire
et elle peut se poursuivre sans aucune
difficulté monsieur mzard je tiens à
vous le répéter et à vous le confirmer
de cette tribune au nom du gouvernement
elle n'est pas interdite par les
nouvelles dispositions qui ne sanctionne
que la négation de l'existence même des
génocides reconnu par la loi ou leur
minimisation transancière alors
pardonnez-moi de vous dire ça mais par
définition un travail scientifique n'est
pas
aurancier il faut quand même traiter ce
texte par rapport à ce qu'il dit et non
par rapport à ce qu'on veut lui faire
dire or c'est le caractère outrancier
qui que sanctionne cette proposition de
loi cette notion renforce la définition
du négationnisme et permet de distinguer
clairement négationnisme et travail
légitime de l'historien personne ne veut
empêcher les scientifiques et les
historiens de procéder à leur recherche
la la minimisation minimisation
transancière ça serait le fait de
déclarer enfin je pas revenir dessus que
par exemple le génocide aurait fait que
200 victimes je je vous dis des des
caricatures bien entendu c'est ça la
isation au transancière en revanche
cette notion n'interdit pas le travail
d'historien sur le déroulement des faits
et le nombre des victimes Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatries sénateur le
nécessaire travail de mémoire et de
recherche ne doit pas empêcher de
légiférer pour sanctionner la négation
d'un fait historiquement reconnu enfin
enfin 3è argument monsieur le président
de la commission des lois atteinte à
liberté d'opinion et d'expression c'est
ce que j'ai aussi
entendu il y a aucune atteinte à la
liberté d'opinion d'expression monsieur
le Président qui serait contraire à la
Constitution je me réfère bien sûr à
notre texte fondateur ou à la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
monsieur mzard comme vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure je souhaite vous répondre
précisément la liberté d'opinion n'est
évidemment pas en cause puisque seule
l'expression publique de la négation des
génocides reconnu par la loi sera
sanctionnée la question ne porte donc
que sur la liberté d'expression ce texte
limite cette liberté mais c'est le cas
de tous les délits prévus par la loi de
1900 de 1881 pardon tous les délits sur
la presse oui tous les délits prévus
concernant la presse par la loi de 1881
on on on est dans dans ce dans ce cadre
là on ne change rien la question est
donc de savoir si cette limitation est
justifiée ou si elle est excessive je
rappelle que tant que nos règles
constitutionnelles que la Convention
européenne reconnaisse que la liberté
d'expression peut connaître des limites
les deux textes mesdames et messieurs
sénatr et sénateurs reconnaissent le
fait que cette liberté peut connaître
des limites l'article 11 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyens vous me l'avez opposé tout à
l'heure proclame la liberté d'expression
tout en indiquant qu'on doit répondre
des abus de cette liberté dans les cas
prévus par la loi nous sommes dans ce
cas mesdames et messieurs nous ne sommes
que dans ce cas vous ne pouvez donc pas
nous opposer cet argument concernant la
liberté d'expression ni la liberté
d'opinion s'agissant de la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme son
article 10 protège la liberté
d'expression tout en reconnaissant
qu'elle peut faire l'objet de limite
elle aussi et l'article 17 de la
convention interdit les abus de droit
qui peuvent résulter d'une
interprétation excessive d'autres
dispositions de la convention monsieur
Kaltenbach l'a parfaitement rappelé je
ne reviendrai donc pas dessus statuant
sur la conformité d'une condamnation
prononcée sur le fondement de la loi
guesso la Cour de Strasbourg a jugé dans
un arrêt oui mais vous m'avez
pardonnez-moi mesdames et messieursur
vous m'avez posé des argument de droit
permettez-moi de répondre au droit par
le droit et c'est mon devoir en tant que
représentant du gouvernement de le faire
aujourd'hui un arrêt du 24 juin 2003
elle a indiqué qu'il existe une
catégorie de fait historiques clairement
établies dont la négation se verrait
soustraite par l'article 17 sur l'abus
de droit à la protection de l'article 10
la cour considère ainsi clairement qu'il
serait abusif d'utiliser la convention
pour obtenir le droit de nier
l'existence d'un génocide établi par
l'histoire monsieur le Président sueur
même si la décision de 2003 faisait
référence à l'holocauste son application
peut être sans problème transposée à la
négation d'autres génocides par exemple
le génocide arménien s'il constitue
également un fait clairement établi du
reste exposé des motifs déposé par
monsieur Sueur montre lui-même que la
pénalisation du négationnisme résultant
de la proposition de loi n'est pas
constitutionnellement ou
conventionnellement injustifié je je
vais chercher dans vos propres arguments
monsieur su cet exposé des motifs
précise en effet je vous cite que le
négationnisme constitue une atteinte
odieuse à la mémoire des disparus et la
dignité des victimes c'est vous qui
l'avez écrit alors si le négationnisme
constitue une atteinte
odieuse comment pouvez-vous défendre une
le contraire de ce que je défends moi
c'est c'est-à-dire comment pouvez-vous
défendre qu'il ne faut pas le
sanctionner comment pouvez-vous défendre
qu'il faut pas sanctionner si des propos
niant l'existence du génocide arménien
constitue bien une atteinte odieuse à la
dignité des victimes du génocide et si
vous qui l'écrivez en quoi c-il excessif
de les pénaliser monsieur carouci la loi
sur la presse pénalise bien les propos
diffamatoires ou injurieux qui peuvent
être beaucoup moins odieux que des
propos négationnistes et comme Monsieur
Carvounas l'a rappelé des actes de
négationnisme même s'ils ne sont pas
nombreux ont été commis dans notre pays
et notamment sur les génocide arméia
c'est vrai la protection et la dignité
des victimes ne permet-elle pas une
sanction pénale c'est une question
depuis la loi Guigou du 15 juin 2000
l'article 35 quit de la loi 1880 sur la
presse réprime par exemple la diffusion
d'image d'une infraction portant
gravement atteinte à la dignité des
victimes je vais essayer d'être plus
rapide pour pour conclure pourquoi enfin
refuser cette protection pénale au nom
de la liberté d'expression monsieur le
Président qui n qui n'est pas absolu
alors que le Sénat vient la semaine
dernière je crois à la quasi unanimité
d'accepter de pénaliser les injures et
diffamation envers les supplétifs aux
forces armées françaises j voilà avec
votre attitude d'aujourd'hui une
contradiction puisque cette décision a
quasiment été unanime il s'agit
également là d'une limite à la liberté
d'expression mais cette limite est
évidemment justifié comme le serait
celle interdisant la négation du
génocide
arménien le dernier argument que vous
avez développé le dernier argument en
faveur de la motion c'est le risque de
voir la loi 2001 déclaré par icocher
contraire à la Constitution là je vous
écouter avec une grande attention grande
attention
oui vous avez parlé de d'une
question d'une
QPC qui pourrait être déposée à
l'occasion de de poursuite pénale ce
grief ce grief me paraît infondé pour
trois
raisons pour trois raisons monsieur
Gorse pour trois raisons monsieur
Gor d'autre part d'une part comme je
viens de l'indiquer mais vous n'avez pas
me déstabilisé monsieur GS vous avez
essayé pendant des années à l'Assemblée
vous êtes pas arrivé vous allez pas
commencer ici au Sénat on se connaî trop
tous les deux allons d'une part je viens
vient de l'indiquer le gouvernement
considère que les nouvelles dispositions
ne sont pas contraires à la Constitution
même si certains l'affirment d'ailleurs
sans le prouver et je me sens
parfaitement au nom du gouvernement dans
mon droit d'affirmer que ce n'est pas
contraire à la
Constitution d'autre part on peut
observer que si la loi de 2001 pourrait
être considérée comme étant déclarative
car c'est vrai que la loi 2001
déclarative et de ce fait fragile
constitutionnellement et je vous suis
sur raisonnement et bien la présente
proposition de loi en lui donnant un
effet juridique la consolide parce
qu'elle la rend normative et la rendant
normative le fait que les deux textes
l'un rendant l'autre normatif entre
parfaitement dans l'article 34 de la
Constitution monsieur le Président qui
prévoit que la loi définit les délit et
nous sommes là dans la définition du
délit voilà une démonstration simple à
suivre qui prouve que le raisonnement
que vous que vous essayez de de
démontrer n'est pas conforme à la
lecture de la
Constitution non non non techniquement
parfaitement établi non mais je
comprends que ça vous gêne quand on
n'est pas d'accord si si mais je veux
vous provoquer pour réveiller un peu
l'hémicyclle bien alors enfin dans la
mesure où il est déjà possible d'engager
des procédures civiles contre les
négationnistes puisque cela a eu lieu
par le passé comme le rappelle le
rapport de commission des lois la loi de
2001 pourrait d'ors et déjà monsieur
mzard à l'occasion d'une procédure
civile faire l'objet d'une question
prioritaire j'observe enfin que le texte
qui est soumis au Sénat est différent de
celui de la proposition de loi initiale
qui était beaucoup plus large je
voudrais que vous acceptiez de de de de
reconnaître les travaux que l'assemblée
a réalisé sa commission des lois et dans
l'hémicycle et effectivement au départ
ce texte était totalement
différent aujourd'hui le texte qui vous
est proposé euh le texte qui vous été
proposé pardon visait non seulement la
contestation des génocides mais
également celle des crimes contre
l'humanité et des crimes de
guerre la limitation apportée par
l'Assemblée nationale à la proposition
initiale en ne retenant que le crime de
génocide qui constitue le plus grave de
tous les crimes susceptibles d'être
commis et un exigeant qu'il était
reconnu par la loi française a
considérablement limité le champ de la
réforme et je voudrais que vous
acceptiez de voir les progrès faits par
l'Assemblée dont il peut être considéré
qu'elle n'apporte à la liberté
d'expression qu'une atteinte limitée
justifiée dans une société démocratique
comme pour les lois que j'ai déjà évoqué
pour en terminer je ne veux taire non
non je ne veux taire une certaine
satisfaction lorsque votre commission
déclare en page 16 page 16 de votre
rapport monsieur le Président je cite
qu'à cet égard la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008 en
réintroduisant expressément cette
possibilité dans un nouvel article 341
la Constitution permettra à l'avenir au
Parlement d'assurer sa fonction
tribucienne en adoptant une proposition
une position formalisée sur un sujet
qu'il estime essentiel monsieur le
Président suur c'est une belle
reconnaissance de la réforme
constitutionnelle révision
constitutionnelle 2008 je tiens au nom
du gouvernement de vous remercier de
vous remercier de ce salut que vous
faites à l'initiative du président
Sarkozi en
effet mais mais voilà je reconnais je
reconnais ce qui est bien monsieur alors
en effet l'article l'article 34 ou vous
l'auriez voté vous seriez encore plus de
force pour reconnaître tout ça l'article
341 issu de la réforme bien c'est bien
ce que je reproche de faire donc je
m'arrête tout de suite je ne referai pas
l'histoire l'article 341 issu de la
réforme de la Constitution de 2008 que
votre groupe effectivement n'a pas voté
monsieur le Président offre des
opportunités de voter des résolutions
pour mettre un avis sur une question
déterminée les parlementaires que vous
êtes peuvent désormais utilement s'ils
le souhaitent dans leur fonction de
contrôle et d'information agir sur ce
sujet mais je veux insister sur ce point
il ne s'agit absolument pas aujourd'hui
de légiférer pour reconnaître lié ou ou
ou nier tel ou tel fait historique
monsieur placé à aucun moment le texte
présenté ne porte un quel une quelconque
appréciation sur des faits historiques
il s'agit d'un texte global qui vient
harmoniser notre droit pénal et Monsieur
Marseille je voudrais vous remercier
vous d'avoir rappelé l'objectif de cette
loi oui parce que Monsieur Marseille
était très objectif
assurer l'égalité des citoyens devant la
loi en traitant les victimes de génocide
et leurs descendants de la même façon
comme l'a fait Monsieur Bruno Gill que
je tiens aussi à remercier
oui oui et Monsieur Piras Piras voyez là
pour tout le monde également à souligner
ce point et je viens remercier Monsieur
Humber je ne voudrais pas terminer mon
propos sans vous répondre parce que vous
avez dit vous avez dit des vous avez des
propos auxquels j'étais personnellement
sensible sur un fait qui concerne le
Tibet pardonnez-moi nous sommes hors de
la portée de cette loi et je n'en dirai
pas plus pour vous répondre car je me
limite à la portée de cette loi alors
madame joissin pour terminer vous avez
combattu avec talent efficacité cette
exception d'reevabilité vous avez raison
et je vous en remercie notamment sur le
plan juridique alors j'ai essayé bien ou
mal de de démontrer que les arguments du
président sueur peuvent être retournés
je reconnais retourn contre la
proposition des loi tout comme les miens
vous allez tout à l'heure je pense
essayer monsieur suur de les retourner
également en conclusion est-ce que vous
pouvez accepter que deux génocides
soient traités différemment lorsqu'on
les nit de manière outrancière je suis
certain qu'au fond de vous-même au fond
de vous-même un législateur averti et
compétent que vous êtes vous ne pouvez
pas accepter que de lois traitant de
deux sujets identiques génocide soit
soit traité d'une manière différente en
ce qui concerne leur négation donc
tenons-nous en à une bonne application
de la loi sur ce point sur les point
vous avez pour justifier
l'irrecevabilité du présent texte le
gouvernement n'est pas susceptible de
rejoindre votre position je
souhaiteraiis mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que vous entendiez bien que le
Gouvernement est défavorable à cette
exception d'irrecevabilité et que vous
acceptiez de la rejeter je vous
remercie merci
ministre bien en application de notre
règlement nous allons passer aux
explications de vote par les groupes et
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas Alfonsi
pour le groupe
RDSE chers
collègues le génocide arménien a-t-il
exist la réponse est
oui la discussion de ce projet peut-elle
poursuivre la réponse est
non qui peut nier l'existence du drame
vécu par un si vieux
peuple puisant ses racines et sa culture
dans les trèfond d'histoire et dont les
de/ers de la population ont été anéanti
lors du
génocide qui pourrait douter de la
volonté d'extermination d'anéantissement
de déportation de tout un peuple
comment ne pas s'associer aux
souffrances encore vivaces des
descendants de ceux qui ont pu échapper
à ce massacre et dont nous savons la
richesse que par leur travail ils ont pu
apporter à la France eux qui l'ont
défendu dans des temps difficiles les
armes à la main je vous invite à relire
la lettre de manouchiant à sa femme
avant son
exécution mais qui parmi nos collègues a
pu connaître dans son entourage dans ses
relations bref dans sa vie publique une
seule personne qui a pu mettre en cause
publiquement la réalité de ce génocide
au point de vouloir par cette
proposition traduire devant les
tribunaux ce qui pourrai le
contester aussi ce débat ne saurait se
poursuivre car on peut douter de son
anticonstitutionnalité je m'en tiendrai
aux arguments du
rapporteur la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme le fait qu'ilétend les pouvoirs
du Parlement au-delà de sa compétence
législative et l'éger en tribunal de
l'histoire mondiale peut porter atteinte
à la séparation des pouvoirs portant
atteinte également à la liberté de la
recherche et de de la recherche
historique principe qui constitue autant
d'obstacles à l'établissement d'une
vérité officielle inacceptable puisque
ne pouvant se fonder sur une légitimité
analogue à celle tiré du tribunal de
nuramber projettons-nous demain au
lendemain de l'approbation de ce texte
si ce débat laisse poursuivre un vrai
problème se pose il a été évoqué à
l'instant par Monsieur le Ministre à
partir du moment où les deux groupes les
plus importants du Parlement sont
d'accord pour ne pas former pour des
motifs éloignés de considération
juridique aucun recours devant le
Conseil constitutionnel et s'il n'y a
pas eu le recours à l'occasion de la loi
de 2001 c'était bien parce c'était une
loi sans portée et que tout le monde
était d'accord seul demeure l'arme de la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité en commission des
collègues ont refusé de s'associer à la
motion non pour des motifs de fond mais
pour des motifs
d'opportunité car la question
prioritaire donnerait l'occasion sur
recours d'un négateur de réexaminer la
loi 2001 puisque le texte que que nous
examinons comme l'a souligné le
président vanadanter s en racine
contrairement à la thèse exposée à
l'instant pour le ministre qui lui
donnerait au contraire plus de vigueur
juridique au-delà de leur satisfaction
purement intellectuelle on mesure les
dégâts que provoqueraient l'annulation
de ces deux textes la déception
l'humiliation de la communauté
arménienne et la satisfaction de la
Turquie dans les efforts pour redoubler
pour perpétuer sa officielle sur le
génocide ne feront que se renforcer mais
faudra-t-il que la question de faut
encore fautil que cette question soit
posée quelle situation connaîtrions-nous
si faute de recours au juge pénal et à
son corps de fondant à l'occasion d'une
procédure qui miniserait qui
minimiserait de manière aurancière les
événements de 1915 allait être appelé à
statuer comme cela a été souligné par
certains juriste sans pouvoir de
qualification estimant peut-être qu'il
ne répond pas à la définition pénale du
génocide comment pourrait-on laisser aux
tribunaux le soin de trancher des
questions qui ne relèvent que de la
recherche historique on ne peut dès lors
que rappeler que la Commission àyé avait
conclu que valait mieux dans ce domaine
sensible s'exprimer par la voix des
résolutions que par des propositions de
loi mais si le recours allait prospérer
et nous ramener à la ce DESP
la résolution aujourd'hui inutile
puisque la loi de 2001 il supplit
retrouverait son
office parce que cette proposition est
inutile car des moyens du droit existent
parce que la France donnerait ainsi au
magistrat ce substituant aux historiens
un pouvoir qu'aucun pays n'a jugé utile
de leur donner le groupe RDSE votera
pour
l'irrecevabilité je vous remercie chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe ctonbach pour le groupe
socialiste mes chers collègu pour
répondre aux arguments de la commission
des lois je dirais tout d'abord qu'il
est reproché à cette proposition de
porter atteinte à la séparation des
pouvoirs en substituant le législateur
au juge j'entends bien sûr cet argument
tant il est essentiel dans notre système
démocratique de séparation des pouvoirs
et nul autre que le groupe socialiste
depuis ces 10 dernières années ne
peut-être plus résolu à protéger le
pouvoir judiciaire des ingérences des
autres pouvoirs exécutifs notamment mais
en l'espèce cette objection doit être
réfutée tout d'abord c'est ignorer
l'histoire que de prétendre que la
réalité de ce génocide n'aurait pas été
reconnu par un juge ça a été dit à
plusieurs reprises les cours martiales
de Constantinople en 1919- 1920 ont
rendu des verdicts à l'encontre des
principaux responsables sur le fond les
objections ne sont pas plus
convaincantes la loi de 2001 ne qualifie
pas les les événements de 1915 elle les
reconnaît comme étant un génocide
rapporté au texte de la proposition de
loi cette reconnaissance ne produit
qu'un seul effet celui de rendre
applicable la nouvelle incrimination
sans priver le juge de sa compétence de
qualifier juridiquement les massacres de
1915 cet effet limité de la
reconnaissance d'une situation comme
constitutive de génocide est confirmé
par le libél même de la proposition de
loi seul sont visé la contest ou la
minimisation trancière de l'existence
d'un ou plusieurs crimes de génocide
défin à l'article 211-1 du Code pénal
qu'il appartiendra donc au juge de
qualifier selon les faits soumis à son
examen il n'y a donc aucune atteinte au
principe de la séparation des pouvoirs
il n'y a pas non plus atteinte au
principe constitutionnel de la légalité
des délits puisque l'incrimination de
contestation minimisation repose sur la
définition pénale du génocide qui est
précise et totalement fidèle aux
définitions internationale de ce crime
la commission des lois fait encore rief
à cette proposition de loi de porter
atteinte à la liberté d'expression et de
recherche mais la rédaction de la loi
permet de laisser au juge la faculté et
le pouvoir d'apprécier ce qui est
outrancier ou raisonnable pour rendre
son jugement mettant ainsi à l'abri de
toute infraction la recherche et la
poursuite des travaux
scientifiques de manière plus technique
est opposé par monsieur le rapporteur de
la commission le risque de déclaration
d'inconstitionnalité de la loi de 2001
il nous semble cependant pas fondé j'ai
déjà répondu au grief tiré de la
prétendue violation de la séparation des
pouvoirs pour vous démontrer le respect
de ce principe et quand à l'objection
fondée sur l'absence de valeur normative
de la loi de 2001 elle doit justement
être levée par l'adoption de la loi
soumise à l'adoption de notre assemblée
l'effet de la loi de 2001 serait de
rendre applicable la nouvelle
incrimination et il est paradoxal de
refuser de voter une proposition de loi
dont les et de faire disparaître une
cause d'inconstionnalité d'une loi en
vigueur enfin dernier point la
proposition de loi réaliserait une
transposition imparfaite de la directive
cadre du 28 novembre 2008 qui impose aux
États-membres de prendre toutes mesures
pour punir l'apologie la négation ou la
banalisation grossière publique des
crimes contre l'humanité notamment mais
les objections présentées repose sur une
erreur d'analyse la décision cadre n'a
pas pour effet ni pour objet de limiter
la compétence de l'État membre de
l'Union elle est intervenue dans le 3ème
pilier de l'Union où l'Europe n'exerce
qu'une compétence partagée avec les
États membres par conséquent le
Parlement français n'est pas privé de
compétenence du simple fait de
l'adoption de la décision cadre la
portée de cette décision cadre le
confirme elle vise seulement à une
harmonisation minimale au fin d'un
rapprochement progressif des droits
internes et d'une reconnaissance
mutuelle des décision judiciirees rendu
dans le domaine de la lutte contre le
racisme et la xénophobie ainsi la
proposition de loi ne porte atteinte à
aucune obligation constitutionnelle à
l'occasion de cette transposition c'est
pourquoi mes chers collègues mes chers
collègues au nom du groupe socialiste
même si je sais que le vote du groupe ne
sera pas unanime mais une majorité
rejetera cette motion je vous demande de
bien vouloir rejeter cette motion
tendant à opposer l'exception
d'irrecevabilité sur ce texte je vous
remercie je vous remercie chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Vincent Placé pour le groupe écol
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègu pour qu'on ne
puisse pas abuser du pouvoir il faut que
par la disposition des choses le pouvoir
arrête le pouvoir cette jolie phrase de
montesquieux à l'origine notamment de la
théorie la séparation des pouvoirs bien
évidemment bien que les intentions
soient louables cette proposition de loi
établit une confusion des genres
dangereuse le Parlement ne peut
légiférer surt il ne doit se substituer
ni au juge ni à
l'historien l'article 16 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen du 26 août 1789 se réfère
également à cette théorie en disposant
que toute société dans laquelle la
garantie des Droits n'est pas assurée ni
la séparation des pouvoirs déterminés
n'a point de Constitution la séparation
des pouvoirs apparaît ainsi comme le
corollaire indispensable de la
protection des droits naturels de
l'homme or en se prononçant sur les
sanctions qui punissent la négation d'un
crime qui n'a pas été défini
juridiquement le Parlement outre pas ses
compétences laisse place à l'arbitraire
et porte atteinte à la libertés
d'expression ainsi qu'au principe de la
recherche déjà en mai 2011 nous l'avons
rappelé les membres de la commission des
lois et au premier plan JeanJacques
Yeste expliquer pourquoi cette loi était
entaché
d'inconstitutionnalité les écologistes
estiment que ces motifs
d'inconstitutionnalité sont réels
je ne déveloerai pas l'ensemble des
éléments qui ont été très bien dits par
Jean-Pierre suur tout d'abord la
proposition de loi opère d'évidence une
confusion entre la fonction législative
et la fonction
juridictionnelle il est absolument
fondamental que le pouvoir légiférer et
de justice soit séparé le voilà vous le
voyez à la tribune c'est Jean-Vincent
Placé he pour le groupe écologiste qui
est en train de défendre ce rejet de
cette motion
d'irrecevabilité sur ce texte jeanvant
plé qui pense donc qu'il est un
constitutionnel comme la endu tout à
l'heure jean-Pierre Sueur le président
de la commission des lois ensuite il
devrait y avoir un vote un vote public
autour de cette motion et c'est à ce
moment-là seulement qu'on devrait avoir
un une première idée de ce que pourrait
être le vote final sur ce texte aprement
discuté tout au cours de cet après-midi
ici au Sénat dans quelques instants le
19h présenté par Michel grossur mais
vous pouvez suivre bien entendu
l'intégralité de ces débats autour de
cette proposition de loi très
controversée sur notre site
publicsena.fr ou encore sur notre canal
2424 merci à tout à
l'heure